Scholastic Audio presents Wings of Fire
Book 8, Escape in Peril, by 2ET
Sutherland, read by Shannon McManus.
The Jade Mountain Prophecy.
Beware the darkness of dragons.
Beware, the stalker of dreams.
Beware the talons of power and fire.
Beware one who is not what she seems.
Something is coming to shake the earth.
Something is coming to scorch the
ground.
Jade Mountain will fall beneath thunder
and ice unless the lost city of night can
be found.
Prologue.
Seven years ago.
No dragon was safe in the Sky Palace, but
the ones in the most danger by far were
the daughters of Queen Scarlet.
Or was it now daughter singular?
Ruby hadn't seen her sister Tourmaline in
3 days, not since the night they went
flying together and high in the starlit
sky, glowing in the light of 2 of the
moons, Tourmaline had whispered that she
was almost ready.
Don't be an idiot.
You're only 10, and furthermore, you'll
never be ready.
Ruby had whispered back.
She killed her mother, plus all 3 of her
sisters and 11 of hours.
There's no way to defeat her.
She can't be queen forever, Tourmaline
said.
She has been queen forever, Ruby argued
24 years is a long time, but not that
long, said Tourmaline.
Queen Oasis was queen longer than that
and look what happened to her.
Are you planning to throw a scavenger at
mother?
Ruby asked.
Because I'm sure she'd appreciate a snack
before she kills you.
It's always going to be like this.
Tourmaline hissed.
She flicked clouds away with her dark
orange wings.
Until one of us challenges her and wins.
You and I are the only ones left now.
The only hope the Skywings have of a
decent queen.
Ruby.
If I defeat her and become queen, we can
get out of this war.
Ruby wasn't so sure about that.
She'd met Bern, and she suspected the
sand wing wouldn't let her allies go that
easily.
But it didn't matter.
There was no way Tourmaline could win a
battle with their mother.
The prophecy will take care of the war.
She argued.
The brightest night is in 4 days.
Right.
Tourmaline rolled her eyes.
I'll just wait for a bunch of eggs that
haven't even hatched yet to save us.
Ruby, I don't want to wait for things to
happen to me.
I want to make them happen.
I don't want to watch you die.
Ruby growled.
Her sister hovered in front of her for a
moment.
Stars glittered in her eyes, searching
rubies.
She's wondering if I want the throne for
myself.
Ruby thought.
She thinks I'm trying to talk her out of
it because I'm planning something like
I'm that stupid.
Well, don't worry, I won't do it yet.
Termaline promised.
Another few months of training, maybe.
I'm feeling really strong though.
I beat Vermilion in a fight the other
day.
Want to hear about it?
Ruby had listened to the entire long play
by-play of each move Tmaline had made.
They'd spent an hour soaring around the
peaks in the moonlight, and not once had
Tourmaline said anything about leaving
the palace.
But then she was gone.
And the most unsettling thing was, no one
had even mentioned her absence.
Her squadron was still here.
Training and hunting as though nothing
odd had happened.
There were no patrols out looking for her
no search parties scouring the woods, no
missives flying out to other queens to
ask if they'd seen, or abducted, the
older sky wing princess.
Just a quiet vanishing into thin air.
Ruby stood in the room she shared with
her sister, studying the piles of
blankets.
The scroll was carelessly tossed aside
the gold tasseled yellow curtains
flapping at the window.
There were no splatters of blood, no sign
of a struggle.
No note saying, oh, I've popped off to
one of the outposts for a few days.
See you soon.
Did Termaline change her mind and run
away?
Could she have gone to find the talons of
peace?
But Ruby knew that wasn't what had
happened.
Her big sister wasn't the kind to ever
run away.
More significantly, Queen Scarlet would
never let the peace movement get their
claws on her daughter.
She'd find them and destroy them all
first.
Heavy talons were slowly squeezing Ruby's
insides, digging their claws in harder
every minute that Tourmaline was gone.
If she found out, the tourmaline was
planning to challenge her.
What did mother do?
Princess Ruby?
She jumped and whirled around.
The guard in the doorway cleared his
throat.
The queen has requested your presence in
the throne room, he said.
Immediately.
Requested?
Ruby echoed.
The expression on his face said quite
clearly that he didn't approve of the
question.
Never let them see that you're
terrified.
That's what tourmaline said.
Act like a queen, so that one day they'll
be cheering for you to slit mother's
throat.
But now, Tourmaline was gone.
And perhaps acting like a queen was
exactly what had gotten her killed.
Thank you, Ruby said, inclining her head
of the guard as she went past him.
Her heart beat drummed through her
shoulders and out to her wing tips.
The tunnel felt too small, as though she
were the size of a 1000 year old dragon
instead of just a 5 year old dragonette.
Whatever happened to Tourmaline?
Am I next?
Dragons huddled by the throne room
entrance, whispering.
They all straightened their heads and
wings as she approached.
Curiosity gleamed in their eyes.
They must have known Tourmaline was
missing, even if no one would talk about
it.
They must have been wondering, like Ruby
was, whether Queen Scarlet had decided to
dispose of all her potential, threatening
airs.
But I'm not threatening.
I'm not.
Ruby ducked her long neck as she entered
the room.
Blinking in the blaze of sunlight that
reflected off all the gold inlaid in the
walls.
It felt like walking into a funeral pyre
oppressive heat, and the smell of dragon
fire, radiating off the crowd of
courtiers, closed in around her scales.
Queen Scarlet wouldn't kill her daughter
in front of all these dragons.
Would she?
Ah, Ruby!
The queen's voice lilted over all the
others.
And the room fell silent.
At last.
Court, many of you don't know my daughter
Ruby, because she's been away in training
and even when she is here.
She mostly sits in her cave like a sleepy
bat.
If you ever have seen her, she's probably
had her nose in a scroll.
But despite the fact that she's nothing
like me, she is still somehow my
daughter.
There was a dutiful smattering of
applause.
Well, now everyone is here.
Everyone important, I mean.
I have such a thrilling announcement.
Ruby, don't lurk by the wall. like a
jittery centipede.
Come stand by your brothers.
I want you, especially, to see this.
The crowd parted to let Ruby through.
Their avid orange and amber eyes peeling
off her scales as she slid by.
There was just enough space for her to
fit between vermilion and Hawk, both of
them towering over her.
Her other 2 brothers were on Hawke's
other side.
All of Scarlett's children were here
except tourmaline.
Vermillion snorted, and Edge just step
away from her, but Hawk gave her a
friendly-ish nudge of acknowledgment.
Ruby always got the feeling that Hawke
was cheerfully being nice to her because
he knew she'd be dead soon.
He'd seen the rest of his sisters die
under Scarlet's claws.
Ruby suspected his good humor came from
the security of knowing he could never
have the throne, so he wasn't worth
killing.
Their mother glowed like a poisonous
orange from the top of her throne, peering
down at the dragons that packed the
room.
The sharp sparkle of diamonds above her
eyes, and along her wings seized the
light.
Ruby's breath caught in her throat, at
the sight of the hulking dragon at the
queen's side.
Burn, their sandwing ally, her face
twisted in disgust and boredom.
Everyone had been instructed to call her
queen burn to her face.
But Ruby found it hard to think of her
that way.
For one thing, she hadn't won the war
yet.
And for another, there was only one queen
in Ruby's world, closing her deadly
talons around everything in it.
On the other side of Queen Scarlet, was a
tall, oddly piled arrangement of black
rocks that seemed to be smoking.
Finally, Scarlet said, rolling her eyes
as though including the rest of the court
in her impatience with Ruby.
A chuckle eddied around the crowd.
Get on with it.
Burn snapped.
Queen Scarlet flicked her tail and
stretched her wings with deliberate
languor.
Ruby had time to wonder if the thrilling
announcement had anything to do with
Tourmaline.
I have the thrillingly murdered one
daughter.
Why stop there?
Who needs daughters anyway, right?
You may all have heard of a certain
prophecy.
Queen Scarlet said instead.
Mumbling about special dragonettes, who
will hatch on the brightest night and
stop the war, and you may all have
noticed that the brightest night is
tonight.
Isn't that terribly exciting?
Tiny little heroes crawling out of their
eggs any minute now.
That is, unless something simply dreadful
happens, of course.
She cast a sidelong glance at Bern
smiling maliciously.
What you all don't know is that someone
tried to steal a sky wing egg last
night.
A gasp ran around the room.
I know, said Queen Scarlet.
A nasty ice wing thief, got all the way
in here, and actually escaped with an
egg.
The largest one in the hatchery, as it
happens.
The air crackled, as if it might burst
into flames at any moment.
Ruby tried to imagine life as a sky wing
raised outside the sky kingdom.
The thief couldn't have been planning to
take it to the ice kingdom.
A sky wing would never survive there.
So was he one of the talents of peace?
Were they assembling the dragonettes of
the prophecy?
Was the dragonette in that stolen egg
going to save them all?
Oh, don't worry, her mother said.
Queen Bern chased him down, killed him
and destroyed the egg.
We don't particularly like tiny little
heroes after all, especially ones who
might try to tell us what to do.
So.
She clapped her front talons together
suddenly, snapping the tension in the
room like a bowstring.
Just to be perfectly safe.
Queen Bern and I had a marvelous idea.
We're going to make sure there are no sky
wings hatching on the brightest night, not
even one.
Not even close.
Bring them in.
She called.
Ruby watched in confusion as 7 guards
filed in, each of them carrying an egg.
Red and orange shapes moved under the
thin surface of the eggshells, and she
could see cracks already spreading across
3 of them.
Queen Scarlet narrowed her eyes.
There should be eight.
She hissed.
We'll find it, Your Majesty, said the
tallest guard.
I promise, she won't get far, and it was
a runty one, anyhow.
A skittering noise came from the pile of
rocks beside the queen, and one of the
stones trembled for a moment.
Then came tumbling down and bounced
across the floor, rolling to a stop at
Ruby's talons.
Fine, said Queen Scarlet, putting on her
annoyed, but it's a celebration, so I'll
just kill someone later, face.
I have someone just wonderful.
I want to introduce to you all.
And this seemed like a perfect way to do
it.
Ooh, the suspense.
A puff of impatient smoke snorted out of
Burns nostrils.
Always a spectacle.
She muttered.
Can't just kill something efficiently and
be done already.
Queen Scarlet ignored her.
She was busy removing rocks from the top
of the pile, slowly taking off the roof
of the makeshift structure.
Another scrabbling noise came from inside
the rocks.
There's something alive in there, Ruby
thought.
And then suddenly a little head popped
over the edge of the rocks.
Only a heart beat away from the queen's
talons.
Scarlet jerked back, and Ruby was shocked
to see something that looked like a flash
of fear in her eyes.
She craned her neck to see better.
What could possibly scare mother?
She's not afraid of anything.
It looked like an ordinary dragonette.
About a year, or maybe a year and a half
old, with unusually bright, coppery
orange scales.
But then, the dragonette swiveled her
head, and her eyes met Ruby's.
Her eyes.
They were blue.
The weirdest, creepiest blue Ruby had
ever seen.
Far beyond the color of the sky.
Like, someone had bundled up the sky and
immersed it in fire until it burned from
the inside.
That's it, Ruby thought.
This dragonette looked like she was
burning from the inside.
Smoke was even rising from her scales.
Over Ruby's head, Hawk and Vermilion
exchanged looks.
Did you know about this?
Hawk growled softly under the hubbub of
voices, whispering all around them.
I thought it was dead.
It should be dead.
Don't question the queen.
Vermilion muttered back.
Keeping his eyes forward, and his mouth
tensely still.
It's an abomination.
Hawk hissed.
Skywing Law commands us to kill creatures
like that at hatching.
Ruby had a dim memory now of something
that had happened over a year ago.
An egg hatching with twins inside.
The mother trying to escape with both of
them.
The palace had been in an uproar for
weeks, but Ruby got only tiny scraps of
gossip, usually through tourmaline if she
was lucky.
She thought they were all dead.
The twins and the mother.
Could this be the one with too much
fire?
The strange dragonet squeaked and tried
to scramble up to the top of the rock
wall, her tiny wings flapping hopefully.
Scarlet seized a long metal scepter
propped beside her throne, and jabbed the
center of it into the dragonette's
chest.
Down, she snarled.
The dragonette fell back with a yelp.
As Scarlet withdrew the scepter, Ruby
could see that the round tip of it had a
blobby melted spot where it had touched
the dragonette's scales.
A worrying molten metal smell joined the
heat in the room.
Your majesty.
Set a squat rust colored dragon near the
front of the crowd.
He was one of the oldest dragons in the
palace, and had served as an advisor to
Ruby's grandmother when she was queen.
Whenever he saw Ruby, he invariably made
an odd clicking sound with his teeth
commented on how peculiarly long her neck
was, and told her that the secret of long
life was eating a goat kidney every day.
And yet, she could never remember his
name.
She and Tourmaline called him kidney
breath.
Ahem, said kidney breath importantly
waiting for the murmurs to die down and
for everyone to look at him.
Your majesty.
Please assure us that this is not what it
looks like.
Queen Scarlet gave him a glittering all
teeth smile.
Does it look like I have the most
fabulously dangerous new toy?
Because that's exactly what this is.
She flourished one of her wings in the
dragonette's direction.
Behold, my new and future champion.
The dragonette poked her head out again
regarding them all with those sinister
blue eyes.
She glanced up at Scarlet's wing overhead
and reached for it, but the queen kept it
well out of her grasp.
Your majesty is the wisest of all dragons
said kidney breath.
Your every thought is genius, and all
your decisions are perfect in every way.
But.
Are you sure this is safe?
Keeping that, that monster alive?
She is not just any monster.
Scarlet said smugly.
She's my monster, and she's so very
useful.
Here, darling, show them what you can
do.
The queen plucked one of the eggs from a
guard's talons and passed it casually to
the dragonette.
At least, she made it look casual.
But Ruby could see how carefully Scarlet
avoided touching the dragonette's claws
and how quickly she snatched her talons
back.
The dragonette looked down at the egg
which was almost a quarter of her own
size.
Her expression was curious and a little
delighted, as if no one had ever given
her a toy before.
And then small tremors began to run
across the eggshell, and the translucent
whiteness began to fade gray, and the
orange shape inside gave a shudder, and
then turned black, black as coals, black
as dead burnt husks of trees, before the
whole egg went black, and no one could
see inside anymore.
A hush fell over the room.
Nobody spoke.
Nobody could speak.
Ruby thought.
She felt as though she couldn't even
breathe.
Like perhaps it would be safer to never
breathe again.
The egg crumbled into a pile of ash in
the dragonette's talons.
The dragonette stared down at her claws
with an unreadable expression.
Was she surprised?
Pleased with herself?
Did she know that with one simple act, by
merely holding an egg, she'd managed to
terrify every dragon in the room?
She tilted her head slightly to peer up
at the queen, and in that moment, Ruby
caught a glimpse of something familiar in
those weird eyes.
The dragonette with too much fire was
worried that Scarlet would be angry with
her.
It was Burne who finally broke the
silence.
Impressive, she growled.
Now deal with the rest of them, or let me
smash them myself.
Scarlet reached over with a scepter and
knocked down the wall of rocks in the
dragonette's way.
Go touch the rest of the eggs.
Peril she ordered.
Peril, Ruby thought.
The monster has a name.
Peril glanced at the eggs, then down at
her talons, then back at Queen Scarlet.
She looked very small next to the 2
queens.
But, she said.
Her voice swallowed by the hot air in the
hushed room.
But I burned it.
You are my champion, said Queen Scarlet
coldly.
You do as I tell you to.
Peril hesitated for a moment, looking
around the wall of scales and wings and
unfriendly, suspicious eyes around her.
She stepped forward, and the guards
holding the eggs all quickly place them
on the ground, stumbling out of her way.
One by one, peril stopped at each egg, and
laid her claws on it, until the
dragonette inside was dead.
She could do that to anyone.
Ruby realized.
She can probably kill a full grown dragon
just by touching him.
She's the deadliest weapon mother has
ever found.
A ripple of horror ricocheted through her
scales.
Is that what happened to Tourmaline?
She couldn't unhook her gaze from the
murderous dragonette.
Is my sister now a pile of ashes
somewhere?
As peril reached the last egg, Ruby
finally tore her eyes free and lifted
them toward the queen's.
Scarlet was watching Ruby, with a
satisfied, sinister look, a look that
said, who would dare challenge me now?
You, my dreaming daughter.
Go ahead and try.
If you even think about it, now you know
whose talons will find your throat in the
middle of the night.
She was right.
No one could stop Scarlet now.
Ruby would never be queen.
Peril would always be there.
The threat lurking behind the throne, the
smoking scales that lay in wait for any
dragon who showed even a hint of
ambition.
So I won't, Ruby thought.
I won't dream of the throne.
I'll be obedient, loyal, agreeable
anything she wants me to be.
Anything that keeps me alive and as far
away from that monster as I can get, You
win, mother.
The dragonette lifted her claws from the
last smoking egg and turned to Queen
Scarlet with a hungry look in her eyes.
Ruby recognized that look too.
The, do you love me now?
Look.
Excellent, said Queen Scarlet, flicking
her tongue between her teeth.
A thrilling demonstration.
Everything I was hoping for.
As you say, Queen Burn.
So much for that prophecy now, right?
Peril.
Back to your place.
I hope you know how to control your new
champion, mother.
Because she's not just a threat to me.
The crowd of dragons surged back
struggling to stay out of peril's path as
the dragonette walked slowly back to the
little cage of rocks.
This dragon could destroy the entire
world.
Part one.
Scales of fire.
Chapter one.
Deep in a cave in Jade Mountain, the most
dangerous dragon empire was hiding.
Which she was not particularly pleased
about.
Just until Ruby's gone, Pearl muttered
pacing.
That's what he said.
Hours ago.
He said he'd come get me as soon as it
was safe.
Ha!
As if I should be afraid of her.
I'm not afraid of anyone.
Three moons.
It's been forever.
How long does it take to collect a body?
And why should she have to hide anyway?
That's what she wanted to know.
Yes, she was banished from the Sky
Kingdom, but Queen Ruby couldn't banish
her from Jade Mountain 2.
Clay had said it himself.
This wasn't the Sky Palace.
He'd said, you have every right to be
here.
Was that true?
Did she actually have the right to be
anywhere after everything she'd done?
But all she wanted was to be with Clay.
Near him, around him, breathing the same
air and watching the same skies.
That wasn't asking too much.
And if it meant she wasn't hurting anyone
anymore, wasn't that what everyone
wanted?
Maybe not.
Maybe Queen Ruby wanted peril to be
miserable and alone.
Well.
Peril hissed a tendril of smoke, and
marched to the cave entrance, peering
out.
If any dragon, tried to keep her away
from clay, she would melt off their
head.
Even if that dragon was the new sky wing
queen.
Unless Clay told me not to, I guess.
Peril went back to circling the small
cave, flicking her wings at the
claustrophobic stone walls.
There had been a moment, months ago, in
the chaos of the Skywing transition, when
Pearl thought things were going to be
different.
After she'd helped Clay and the others
escape from Scarlet's arena, she'd flown
back to the palace, only to find Queen
Scarlet and Queen Bern gone, and the
whole tribe in a state of panic.
Who'd be in charge now?
What had happened to their invincible
queen?
The relief when Princess Ruby arrived and
took over?
Peril remembered it clearly.
With a wince of pity for her idiotic
hopeful former self.
Along with everyone else, she had thought
a new queen, one who isn't terrifying
everything's going to change.
It was true.
Everything had changed.
For the better. generally, for everyone
but peril.
There had been no thank yous, no
celebrations or medals.
Idiotic, hopeful former self had hoped
for them.
Idiotic hopeful former self was very
stupid.
In fact, there hadn't been any
acknowledgment at all that peril had
helped the dragonettes of destiny defeat
Queen Scarlet.
I mean, they did most of it, but I did
help.
Didn't anyone notice?
Instead, Ruby's very 1st act as queen had
been to banish peril from the Sky
Kingdom.
Peril could still hear her hissing.
I never want to see you again.
And she could still feel the strange
falling vertigo it had given her, as if
her wings had been sliced off.
Until that moment, Ruby had always been
not friendly, exactly, but not hostile
either.
Mostly she'd been quiet.
She'd stayed out of peril's way, nodding
politely in the halls, or leaving the
room when peril came to talk to Scarlet.
She'd never seemed very queenly, to be
frank, so where did this imperious
decisive dragon come from?
But why?
Peril had asked, trying to ignore the
expressions on the guards that surrounded
Ruby.
Why did they look so pleased?
Because you're a murderer?
Ruby replied, as if that should have been
perfectly self evident.
But aren't we all murderers?
Peril had thought.
Didn't we all do terrible things because
Queen Scarlet told us to?
Can you find me one dragon who defied
her?
Why am I the only one getting punished
for obedience?
Then she'd looked into Ruby's eyes, and
realized it was personal.
Ruby actually hated her.
Peril had never known that.
And even now, she still wasn't sure why.
Hadn't they both been loyal Skywing
subjects?
Hadn't they both always followed
Scarlett's orders?
Couldn't Ruby, of all dragons, understand
everything that peril had done?
Leave now, Ruby had said, or die
whichever.
And how do you plan to make me?
Peril had felt fiery rage swelling under
her scales?
I could kill you right now as easily as
breathing.
I could kill everyone in this cave just
by spreading my wings.
She nearly had?
She'd really, really wanted to.
The only thing that had stopped her was
thinking of clay.
He said he saw good in her, which
probably meant he didn't want her setting
large groups of dragons on fire every
time she got mad.
He thought she could be more than Queen
Scarlet's pet killer.
And so, for him, she would be.
Well, she would try.
It was hard though.
Dragons could be awful.
Some of them really deserved to be set on
fire.
And she didn't like being told to sit in
a cave for hours, just because the sight
of her might make Ruby angry.
The Skywing Queen was on her way to Jade
Mountain to collect the body of the
student who died, carnelian.
So, yes, she probably wouldn't be in a
very good mood to begin with.
Peril could understand that it would be
easier for Clay and his friends if she
stayed out of the way, so that Ruby's
visit would go as smoothly as possible.
But why was it taking so long?
Carol paced to the cave entrance again
peering out into the dimly lit tunnel.
Farther along the tunnel, deeper in the
mountain, the faint sounds of splashing
and laughter echoed from the underground
lake.
The sea wing students had decided the
lake was their exclusive clubhouse and
were there all the time now.
Peril was always careful to avoid them.
She avoided all the students as much as
she could.
Everyone here was afraid of her, but no
one was careful of her, the way they'd
been in the Sky Kingdom.
Only the sky wings knew how to steer a
wide path around her.
The dragons in Scarlet's palace had been
experts at avoiding peril.
Wherever she'd gone, empty space opened
up around her.
Here, she had to be the cautious one.
She was responsible for staying out of
their way, even though they were
terrified of her, the other students kept
forgetting she was there, but what if she
bumped into one of them, what if her tail
brushed someone's wing by accident?
How would Clay look at her then?
He said she deserved a 2nd chance.
But if she burned one of his students, she
knew there wouldn't be a 3rd.
Peril's claws twisted and clenched
thinking of all the dragonettes Clay was
protecting here.
Did he love them more than her?
He must.
He should.
Why wouldn't he?
They were innocent symbols of the bright
future he always talked about.
None of them had murdered.
Her mind shied away from the numbers, a
whole lot of dragons.
But none of them had saved his life
either.
And his friends. didn't matter.
They still hated her.
Those shining friends who stood between
her and clay, like blue and green and
gold flames, flaring suspiciously
whenever she so much as looked at him.
Down on the sands of Burns stronghold
after she'd saved him.
Under the eyes of all the tribes, Clay
had said, maybe peril is our wings of
fire.
And for one surreal moment, she'd thought
maybe I am.
Maybe this makes up for everything I've
done.
Maybe by saving clay, I've saved the
world.
Maybe everyone will forgive me now.
Maybe everyone will love me now.
But that wasn't what it happened.
After the end of the war.
Peril had searched for Queen Scarlet for
months, all across the continent, and
everywhere she went, dragons fled
screaming at the side of her.
Or they fainted, or they threw spears and
rocks at her, along with anything else
sharp or pointy, or heavy that they could
get their talons on.
Once, she'd been walloped in the face by
a dead crocodile, flung from the depths
of the mud wing swamps.
It was strange to realize that things
like that could hurt more on the inside
of your scales than the outside.
It was strange to realize that a dragon
who couldn't be hurt on the outside could
have so many ragged holes on the inside.
There, talons thumping on stone.
The rough slither of a tail.
Was it him?
Peril nearly leaped into the corridor, and
came within a wing flicker of colliding
with a dragon who definitely wasn't
clay.
The dark green sea wing dragonette, didn't
scream, or faint, or stagger back in
terror.
He simply froze, slamming his eyes closed
as though danger would obligingly
disappear the moment he couldn't see it
anymore.
What are you doing?
Pearl yelped, jumping away from him?
Um, he said in a low, rumbly voice
walking in the halls, back to my cave.
He risked opening one eye to peer at
her.
Well, that was very stupid of you, she
snapped.
He thought about that for a moment, then
opened both eyes and regarded her
peaceably.
Oh, he said.
Sorry.
What a peculiar dragon.
He seemed to have no fire about him at
all.
That wasn't a sea wing thing.
Tsunami was a fireball that blazed up and
down and sideways, and everything that
made her mad, which was most things.
And her sister, the little sea wing
princess, at least from a distance, seemed
to be a shower of bright orange sparks on
the inside.
This sea wing, on the other talon, was a
puddle, a fireless puddle, blobbing
quietly into the rocks in front of her
not even trying to get away.
Your peril, aren't you?
he said.
Queen Scarlet's.
He trailed off.
Perhaps realizing there was no good way
to end that sentence.
Champion, weapon, notorious death
monster?
Yes.
She hissed.
I'm Queen Scarlet's notorious Death
Monster.
He made an odd hiccuping noise and ducked
his head.
Uh, okay.
I'll just go then.
What would Clay want her to do in this
situation?
Maybe you'll make some friends here, he'd
said, in that oblivious, magical way he
had of thinking that any other dragons in
the world might have open hearts like
his.
Who are you?
She asked.
Hmm.
That came out more menacing than it
sounded in my head.
I mean, who are you?
She tried, adding a sunnyish, cheerful
lilt to her voice.
Now I sound manic.
I'm not being creepy, she added hastily.
I'm not, like, putting you on a murder
list or anything.
I don't have a murder list, not a to be
murdered list.
I mean, wait, no.
To be clear, I have no kind of murder
list at all, definitely out of the
murdering business me.
Maybe I should stop saying the word
murder.
That would be great.
The Seawing said.
If you wouldn't mind.
I just did what I was told, she said in a
rush.
She couldn't remember another dragon
standing still long enough to hear her
say that, not since Ruby had thrown her
out of the Sky Palace.
I was doing what my queen told me to do.
Isn't that what everyone does?
I can't help what I'm like. and what she
made me do.
Can I?
Maybe it was that he didn't look scared.
He didn't look thrilled to be having this
conversation, but he hadn't run screaming
yet.
His green eyed gaze traveled thoughtfully
along her smoking scales, shifted for a
moment to his own talons, and then
dropped to the ground.
I guess, he said.
Turtle.
Peril puzzled over this for a moment.
Was it some kind of sea wing code?
Was he calling her a turtle?
Was that a good or a bad thing?
Moose?
She tried out, just to see what would
happen.
He squinted at her.
Uh, I mean, my name is Turtle.
Oh, she said.
Right.
Hello.
Thank you for not screaming or fainting
or throwing a crocodile at me.
I thought about it, he said.
I mean, not the crocodile.
Definitely not in the reptile throwing
business, me.
Now it was her turn to narrow her eyes at
him.
Was he making fun of her?
Ha ha.
He tried.
Friendly joke.
Are those allowed?
Why aren't you scared of me?
She asked.
I am, he said.
I just, you're not the only dragon I know
with dangerous powers.
Really?
She said.
What did that mean?
Who was he talking about?
But before he could answer, a roar
billowed down through the corridors like
a rolling smoke cloud.
Turtle flared his wings, his green eyes
wide.
What was that?
Probably Queen Ruby?
Carol said.
Was Ruby yelling at clay?
Was Clay all right?
Did he need her to come protect him?
She glanced back at the row of fire
globes leading uphill to the school.
Maybe they just told her that I'm here?
Want to go find out?
Turtle asked.
Pearl frowned at him.
So I can get roared at face to face?
That does sound more fun.
I don't mean go say hi, turtle
protested.
I mean, I'm going to eavesdrop to see
what's happening.
So do you want to come?
Peril curled her wings in.
Severely tempted.
Oh no, I shouldn't.
Clay would be upset with me.
He told me to wait here.
He doesn't have to know, Turtle said with
a shrug.
That's kind of the point of being
stealthy, and if he doesn't catch you
then you're not doing anything wrong.
Are you?
That sounded true.
That sounded very true.
Really, Clay just wanted her to stay out
of Ruby's way.
So if she didn't let Ruby see her, that
was basically the same thing, right?
After all, he didn't specifically say you
must hide in a cave for hours like an
obedient snail?
Stop for a moment.
Think this through.
On the one talent.
She was still pretty sure Clay wouldn't
approve of this plan.
On the other talent, it sounded a lot
more appealing than sitting in a cave
waiting to be released.
On the 3rd talent.
Why was this strange sea wing offering to
hang out with her?
Did he have an agenda?
Was it because if they got caught, she
was sure to get in a lot more trouble
than he would?
Then again, on the 4th talon, shouldn't
she say yes to the 1st friendly dragon
she'd met at the school?
Clay did want her to make friends, so in
a way, she was doing something he would
approve of.
Right?
Unless Clay secretly thought she was too
dangerous for anyone to be friends with.
He might think that.
She kind of was.
Her only friend before Clay, had been
killed by Queen Scarlet for telling peril
too much.
Well, then, maybe she needed more friends
so that some of them could be
expendable.
If anything happened to Clay right now, it
would be the end of all things.
She would literally burn down the world.
She couldn't even think about it, or else
the tunnel would soon be full of rage
smoke.
But if she had clay and turtle as friends
and then Turtle got himself killed by
Queen Scarlet, or accidentally set on
fire.
Well, then she'd survive okay, because
she'd still have clay.
It occurred to her that this was a rather
morbid train of thought to be having
about a new friend.
Yes, she said decisively, making him
jump.
Let's go.
You walk in front, so I don't whack you
with my tail by accident, but don't move
too slowly or I might accidentally step
on you.
She ducked into the cave again to let him
buy safely.
Turtle had an, I am now sensing this was
a terrible idea, expression on his face
but he took the lead without arguing, and
managed to walk fast enough that peril
wasn't annoyed.
The roar echoed from above again.
Together, more or less, Turtle and Peril
headed straight for it.
Chapter 2.
For the past week, Carnelian's body had
been kept in a cave near the peak of Jade
Mountain.
According to Skywing tradition, their
dead were offered to the sky for 7 days
before being burned.
An old dragon named Osprey, the only one
in the sky palace who would speak with
peril voluntarily, had told peril that
this was to make sure their spirits could
fly free and return as sky wings, instead
of coming back as any other kind of
dragon.
That kind of talk always made Queen
Scarlet roll her eyes, though.
She let her tribe follow whatever rituals
they cared about, but she was not much
interested in what happened to dragons
after they were dead.
Peril had visited the body twice, at
night, when everyone else was asleep.
She didn't remember ever meeting the
fierce red dragonette in the Sky Kingdom
but then she didn't know most Skywings by
name.
Queen Scarlet didn't like it when Pearl
tried to talk to other dragons.
To be honest, neither did the other
dragons.
So peril had seen the morning cave by
moonlight, the tall, arched roof, the
towering slender pillars of pale gray
rock.
All the windows and skylights that opened
to the air.
And she'd seen the burned dragon wrapped
in white silk, as still and empty as any
of the charred bodies Peril had left on
Scarlet's arena sands.
But she hadn't seen the cave in the
daytime before.
She hadn't seen the sunlight pouring in
white and gold and backed with blue sky
or the wind rippling the silk, so it
looked like carnelian was breathing.
Now it really looked like a place where
spirit could be set free.
A place where a new sky wing might rise
again.
Unless it was scared off by the angry
dragons gathered around the body anyhow.
On the plus side, at least all the
shouting meant no one could hear turtle
and pearl sneaking out the passage toward
them.
Turtle crouched behind a boulder near the
cave entrance.
Peril peeked in, long enough to see at
least a dozen skywings crowding the
chamber, and decided to stay farther back
keeping a few curves of the wall and
several columns between her and the Queen
who hated her.
I smell lies all over this story, snarled
a Sky Wing, not Ruby, but Pearl didn't
recognize the voice.
First, you tell us you're harboring a
violent bloodthirsty criminal.
And then, you show us a dragonhead who
has died in exactly the way that creature
kills.
Oh, that's me, Peril realized.
I'm the violent, bloodthirsty criminal.
Unfair.
I don't thirst for blood.
If I need to fry someone to cinders, I
will, but I'm not rampaging around
killing dragons for fun.
I haven't even killed anyone in months.
Bloodthirsty indeed.
It was a fire.
Tsunami's voice interjected.
I don't like peril any more than you do
but I promise she didn't do this to
Carnelian.
Very supportive.
Thanks, tsunami.
The unfamiliar Sky Wing hissed with
disbelief.
What sounds more likely to you?
he snarled.
That Scarlet's pet monster has murdered a
dragon loyal to Queen Ruby, or that some
mud wing figured out how to set off a
dragon flame bomb and accidentally killed
our soldier instead of her supposed ice
wing target.
I want to know where the mudwing is.
Queen Ruby's voice was unreadable without
her facial expression.
Was that cold fury or grief or calm
decisive leadership?
Peril had no idea.
This queen was so different from the
submissive daughter she'd played all of
peril's life.
Carol couldn't figure her out at all.
You don't seriously believe them.
The other Skywing cried, his voice rising
again.
Look at cardnelian.
Look at these burns, here, and here.
These marks even look like talon prints.
Peril coiled into herself, remembering
the weight of the dragonette she'd
dragged out of the burning cave, too late
too late to save her.
But if she had, if it had worked, if
Carnelian were alive now, would Ruby have
forgiven her?
Would Clay have been proud of her?
Would he have called her his wings of
fire?
Again?
And would it have changed anything?
Don't touch the body, the queen said
sharply.
Carol pulled Carnelian out of the fire.
Sonny said, her voice more subdued than
usual.
So you will find Pearl's prints on her.
But it's because she was trying to save
her.
Multiple hostiles snorts.
The arguing Skywing clearly wasn't the
only one suspicious of the true story.
Tell me what you're doing to find and
punish the mudwing who did this, said
Queen Ruby.
What is her name?
Sora.
That was clay.
It felt like wings spreading inside her
heart.
Clay was speaking in his wonderful, warm
voice.
She, she's my sister.
He sounded so, so sad.
Peril wanted to burst into the cave and
wrap her wings around him.
No, that would only hurt him more.
What she should do instead was wrap her
wings around the sky wings who were being
mean to him.
Then she could watch them burn between
her claws.
Now, that was the kind of thought she
probably shouldn't share with clay.
Your sister.
Said one of the other Sky Wings.
This escape is looking more and more
convenient, isn't it?
Queen Morehen has agreed to meet with you
Sonny said, a little desperately.
Here or at her palace, whichever you
prefer, we can send a messenger to her
right now.
She wants to help you find justice.
We all do.
Peril always thought of Clay's soul as a
torch that never went out, burning clear
and true all night long.
Sunny, on the other talon, was a blaze of
warm sunlight.
The annoying kind, they gave a dragon
headaches, and made you want to scorch
things because stop smiling already, the
world is horrible, go away.
Peril knew this was bad.
Sonny was the only one of Clay's friends
who tried to be nice to Peril, and yet
Peril still wanted to push her off a
cliff on a daily basis.
Sometimes she dreamed that she'd left
Sonny in Scarlet's cage and run off with
clay, and at the end, he'd turn to her
and say, you were right.
We don't need anyone else.
Forget all the smiling sand wings and
brave sea wings and beautiful rain wings
we've ever known.
But then, she supposed, he wouldn't be
clay.
Her clay.
Who loved his friends so much, he kept
trying to die for them.
That was a plan, by the way, that was
never going to happen on peril's watch.
Your Majesty.
A new voice cut in suddenly.
Someone is approaching from the north.
Queen Warren?
Someone else asked.
No, said the watcher.
I see orange scales.
She trailed off, and in the silence that
followed, peril felt an overwhelming wave
of horror, surge slowly, inexorably
toward them, and then crash over everyone
listening.
It's Queen Scarlet.
Ruby whispered.
You are right.
She's still alive.
And coming to kill you, I bet.
Peril thought.
Since I wouldn't do it for her.
It was the night after peril had freed
Scarlet from Burns Weirdling Tower.
The 2 of them were huddled around a fire
in the unfriendly wasteland between the
ice kingdom and the kingdom of sand.
Scarlet was picking bits of reindeer out
of her teeth.
And Peril was trying not to stare at her
queen's newly disfigured face.
We'll go home tomorrow.
Scarlett growled.
I'll figure out how to kill those
prophecy brats from there, with or
without you.
You should know.
Carol hesitated.
What?
Scarlet threw a hoof at her, whacking
peril hard just above her eyes.
Don't mumble.
I'm furious at you already.
I cannot handle you being annoying as
well as disobedient right now.
Peril rubbed her forehead, and tried to
remember why she thought rescuing Scarlet
was a good idea.
Or maybe she'd always known it was a bad
idea.
But she'd still felt as though it was her
responsibility.
Or maybe she'd just needed Scarlet to
stop slithering through her dreams, making
every night even worse than the days of
crocodile throwing, and dragons screaming
at her.
It's just that Ruby is queen now, Pearl
said.
And the Sky Wings really love her.
She added, a little vindictively.
Scarlet flapped one dismissive wing.
I know about that.
But Ruby will roll right over and hand
back my throne.
She's a good daughter, unlike some
dragons, I could mention.
I don't think she will, Pearl said.
She's made a lot of changes already.
She doesn't do what Bern wants her to
do.
She's pulled back on all the fronts of
the war, since destroying the Summer
Palace, as if she is consolidating her
power, and gathering her warriors to
defend the palace, and herself.
Plus, she, um, She banished me.
She's a lot scarier than I thought she
was.
A lot scarier than you think she is.
Scarlet glowered at peril, her yellow
eyes full of flames.
After a long moment, she said, That's
what Byrne thought too.
That if I tried to return, Ruby would
defeat me.
She threw back her head and laughed, a
strange hollow cackle.
Ruby, of all dragons.
She's a mouse.
She's not, Pearl said.
Truthfully, peril wasn't sure what Ruby
was, but a part of her knew.
She was digging in her claws about it
because she wanted to hurt Scarlet.
She wanted to hurt her the way she'd been
hurt, and she wanted to scare Scarlet
away from the Sky Palace.
True, if Scarlet returned to the Sky
Palace, then peril could too.
She'd have a home again.
But it wouldn't be worth it, because then
Clay would be in danger.
The minute Scarlett had her army back
she'd go after him, and peril wouldn't be
able to stop her.
Scarlet unconsciously reached one talent
toward her scarred face but didn't touch
it.
You think Ruby would fight me?
she asked.
She couldn't win.
Not against me.
But peril could see it in her eyes.
Scarlet knew what it was like to be
afraid now.
The venom attack had melted more than her
scales.
It had eaten away some of her
confidence.
The time she spent trapped in burns tower
of horrors probably hadn't helped
either.
Pearl shrugged.
I guess you'll find out.
There was a pause.
No, Scarlett said.
I have a better idea.
She bared her teeth at peril.
You return to the Sky Palace and kill her
before I get there.
I can't do that, peril cried.
I'm not even allowed in the Sky Palace.
Ruby said she'd have me executed if I
went back.
She can't have you executed if you kill
her first.
Scarlet said.
Well, I'm not going to kill her.
Pearl said, you can't make me.
You can't make me kill anyone else for
you.
I'm not that kind of dragon anymore.
Scarlet's eyes narrowed.
Oh, really?
You think you've changed so much.
I know you.
You like killing dragons.
You've always liked it.
It's one of the things I can stand about
you.
None of the simpering, moaning guilt
another dragon might have.
You were born to burn your enemies, and
mine.
Mostly mine.
I don't have to be, Peril said
stubbornly.
Clay says I can be whoever I want to be.
She knew right away that mentioning him
was a mistake.
Oh, that mud wing.
Scarlett snarled.
He wouldn't like it if I killed Queen
Ruby, Pearl said.
He wouldn't like me at all if I did
that.
But I won't like you if you don't, Scarlet
pointed out.
Peril couldn't believe the stab of dismay
that made her feel.
Why did she still care?
After everything Scarlett had done to
her.
Why did she feel suddenly horribly
desperate to be Scarlet's favorite pet
again?
I don't care.
Stop caring.
Just one more dragon, Scarlet purred.
Kill Ruby for me.
And then you can go follow your
aggravating mud dragon.
It's the least you could do after you
wouldn't let me kill that sandwing
spitball.
Peril poked her claw into a scorched
circle of grass under her talons.
This could be a way to please Scarlet, and
perhaps save clay as well.
Could she bargain Ruby's life for clays?
Would Scarlet promise to let him live?
But, for one thing, she couldn't trust
Scarlet to keep her word, and for another
Clay still wouldn't like it, even if she
only did it to protect him, she knew he'd
be disappointed in her.
The last time they'd seen each other, he'd
been hopeful.
He could see another possible future for
her.
She wanted to be that dragon for him.
No, she said.
That's my final answer.
Then you're useless to me.
Scarlett hissed furiously.
The next morning.
Scarlet was gone.
Carol had not been able to find her, and
no one else had seen her for months, even
in their dreams.
Until she tried to get an ice wing
student to kill the dragonettes for her.
Still trying to make other dragons do her
killing.
So something had kept her scared.
Maybe peril's words, or maybe hearing
what had happened to burn and blister.
But if she was coming this way now, then
she wasn't scared anymore.
Or perhaps her rage had finally surpassed
her fear.
Who was she looking for?
Did she know peril was here?
I'll go face her, Ruby said.
Her voice clear and strong.
No, cried one of the sky wings.
We'll fight her off, all of us.
That's right, said another.
She's not a challenger.
You don't have to face her alone.
She is an enemy, said a third.
And you're a much better queen than she
was.
We want you, not her.
I agree, said Clay.
The throne is yours now, and she can't
have it back.
We'll all fight beside you.
A long pause.
Peril stabbed at a crack in the rock wall
beside her, scowling.
She didn't like the sound of clay acting
all loyal and supportive to someone who
wasn't her.
That was her special clay voice.
That's the one he used when he told peril
she would always have a place at Jade
Mountain and said things like, I want you
to stay.
He wasn't supposed to use it willy-nilly
on dragons who hated her.
Ruby cleared her throat.
Thank you, she said.
If that's how you all feel, then we'll
fly out there together.
Harold heard claws scraping on the
rocks.
She pictured the queen spinning toward
the sky.
A moment later, the cave echoed with the
sound of flapping wings as they all took
off.
Two sky wing queens who both dislike me
quite a lot.
I should hide.
I should run.
I should run and hide.
But if Scarlet was out there, And Clay
was flying toward her?
Pearl couldn't let him face her alone.
Scarlet was still her responsibility.
She darted into the cave, barreling past
Turtle.
Where are you going?
He called.
What happened to stealth?
I have to protect Clay, she called back
spreading her wings.
She couldn't hear his answer over her
wing beats as she shot through one of the
skylights.
It was Scarlet.
Pearl recognized the curve of her wings
instantly, and she could see the dark
scar on the side of her face, even from a
distance.
The former sky wing queen was beating her
way toward them.
Her whole body radiating fury and
vengeance, Ruby and her soldiers were
forming into a defensive wing to confront
her.
Peril spiraled up into the clouds, and
hovered above the mountain peak
indecisively.
Should she fly down to join the soldiers
around Queen Ruby and Clay?
What if her appearance sent them into a
panic, or distracted them from fighting
Scarlet?
As long as Clay was not in immediate
danger.
Maybe she should wait to see what
happened before joining in.
Why was Scarlet even here?
She couldn't be planning to attack Jade
Mountain all by herself, could she?
Perhaps this had something to do with the
students who'd gone looking for her.
A group of 4 dragonettes had gone in
search of Scarlet about a week ago, right
after Cornelian died.
Peril knew from Clay that they'd been in
the rainforest with glory for a day, and
then they'd flown away to find an ice
wing that Scarlet supposedly had
imprisoned somewhere.
But no one knew if they'd found Scarlet
and Perel sort of expected that if they
had, they'd all be dead.
Was that why Scarlet was here?
Had the dragonettes done something to
push her over the edge, from caution, to
rage?
She felt a sudden compression of alarm in
her chest.
Scarlet was carrying something in her
claws.
It was too small to be a body, surely.
Scarlet wheeled about in the air suddenly
out of flaming distance of the wall of
Sky Wing soldiers facing her.
Traitors, she shrieked, all of you
disloyal cowards.
She lifted whatever she was holding and
shook it at them.
I destroy anyone who opposes me.
I will have my vengeance.
And I will get my throne back.
This is just one of the dragons I'll
kill.
And you'll all be next.
She flung the object at them as hard as
she could, then abruptly whirled around
and flew away, her enormous wings eating
up the distance with powerful strokes.
One of the sky wings lunged forward to
catch the missile.
Peril couldn't hold back her curiosity.
She swooped closer as the Sky Wing looked
down at the thing in his talons, then
turned, shuddering, to show it to Ruby
and the others.
Sonny began to scream, as though her
heart was being ripped out of her chest.
Clay reached to catch her before she fell
out of the sky.
The sky wing was holding the severed head
of Queen Glory of the rain wings.
Chapter 3.
Tsunami's roar should have flattened the
mountains and ripped holes in the sky.
She shot after Queen Scarlet, a blue blur
against the clouds.
Go with her.
Queen Ruby shouted at her soldiers.
She grabbed the head from the dazed sky
wing who held it.
All of you, go now.
They obeyed in one glittering mass of red
and orange, except for one who turned the
last minute to face Ruby.
If we catch her.
He said hesitantly.
Do you want to?
Do you want us to?
Yes.
Kill her, Ruby said.
I don't mind who does it.
He nodded, and wheeled around to follow
the others.
Should I go with them?
Peril wondered.
Surely there were enough dragons chasing
Scarlet without her.
What she really wanted to do was take
care of clay.
Knowing how he was about his friends?
peril guest, with a stab of jealousy that
she was immediately ashamed of, that he
must be devastated.
Would he be devastated if that was my
head?
Stop thinking about yourself, peril?
Worry about clay.
He was half carrying Sonny down to a flat
shelf of gray rock that angled out of the
mountain below them.
Ruby glanced at the head in her talons
and then followed.
So, this would be awkward.
But it was clearly an emergency.
Ruby would just have to deal with peril's
presence, and if she didn't like it, it
was her own fault for standing so close
to clay when he was clearly suffering and
needed peril.
Peril dropped out of the sky, landing
with a thump in front of clay and sunny.
Sonny was sobbing too hard to notice her
and at first, Clay didn't seem to see her
either.
His brown eyes stared blankly down at the
little sand wing, as if his brain had
been incinerated.
So it was only Ruby who reacted
immediately, recoiling with a hiss of
fury at the side of peril.
What are you doing here?
Ruby demanded.
In my mountains.
These are my friends, Pearl said, lifting
her chin.
You can't make me stay away from my
friends.
Monsters don't have friends, hissed
Ruby.
Peril gave Clay a sideways glance, waiting
for him to say something like, she's not
a monster, or, we are her friends, but he
still wasn't even looking at her.
How could she have killed glory?
Sonny cried.
Gloria is amazing, and indestructible, and
has magical death spit, plus death
bringer, and a whole army of rain wings
who would die for her.
Clay, please, please tell me that's not
her.
Maybe it's a trick, Clay said, turning
numbly toward the head in Ruby's talons.
It didn't look like a trick to peril.
That was definitely the head of the rain
wing queen.
Peril remembered Glory clearly from her
time in the Sky Palace before she venomed
Queen Scarlet.
She also remembered her on the sands of
burns stronghold, holding clay down while
peril burned out the snake bite poison in
his leg.
She was the one who ruined Scarlet's
face.
The one Scarlet hated the most.
But you'll be next, she thought, glancing
at Ruby.
And then, maybe me.
Or maybe the other dragons from the
prophecy.
Was Clay on Scarlet's list?
If she dared.
If she came anywhere near him, Peril felt
molten lava rippling under her scales and
curled in her tail with a soft growl.
Clay's big mud wing wings trembled as he
tried to reach out and touch the severed
head.
If only she could do it for him.
Then she could examine it and tell him
the horrible truth.
But she couldn't touch it at all.
Or it would turn to charred black cinders
in her claws.
It looks like Queen Glory to me, said
Ruby.
I'm sorry for you both.
Sonny broke down. covering her face with
her talons and curling into a ball with
her wings over her head.
Clay closed his eyes, and his head
dropped.
Can I see?
Pearl and Ruby both looked up and found
Turtle flapping down from the sky.
He landed, and carefully took the head
for Ruby, studying it from all sides.
Who are you?
Ruby asked.
Did you know Queen Glory?
No, I never met her, he said.
I'm one of the sons of Queen Coral. and a
student here, but I feel like, I don't
know, just...
There's something strange about this.
It is weird, Carol agreed.
Glory was probably the best guarded
dragon in Pyria.
How did Scarlet get to her?
Why go for her first?
Killing Ruby 1st would make much more
sense.
Then she could have taken the whole Sky
Wing army to attack the rainforest.
That's Queen Ruby to you.
The red dragon snarled.
And I'm not that easy to kill either, no
matter who you are, or what your claws
can do.
Peril glared back at her.
Turtle squinted and held the head up
toward the light.
Does she have something in her ear?
He tilted it toward Ruby, enough so that
peril could see a flash of yellowy white
tucked inside the dragon's ear.
A message?
Ruby guessed, taking it back from him.
More threats?
With careful claws, Turtle reached into
the ear canal and slid out a small, rolled
up scrap of paper.
As he lifted it out, Glory's head began
to move.
The scales started rippling, as though
they were flipping over, from emerald
green to brown.
The snout widened, and the brow went flat
and the venomous fangs slid into the gums
and banished.
Ruby shrieked and dropped the head on the
ground, where it bounced and rolled to a
stop near Peril's talons.
She peered down into a face that was now
most definitely a mud wing and not glory
at all.
What in the name of all the moons?
Clay grabbed Sonny and nearly lifted her
off the ground as he turned her to look.
What happened?
he cried.
What happened to glory?
Who is that?
Ruby demanded.
Not Queen Glory after all, said Turtle.
This is magic, an enchantment of some
kind.
He held up the unrolled scrap of paper
then brought it close to his nose to read
it aloud.
Enchant this piece of scroll so that
whichever dragon wears it tucked inside
his or her ear shall look exactly like
glory of the rain wings.
There was a long, confused silence.
It's not glory.
Sonny whispered, exhaling.
Clay.
Glory's still alive.
Alive, Clay said.
His whole face glowed with relief.
But we have to warn her that Scarlet's
definitely going after her.
He took a deep breath, his wings drifting
down like falling leaves.
I wonder who this was, he said softly
nodding at the head.
Was Scarlet trying to trick you?
Turtle puzzled.
But why?
I mean, you'd have figured out the truth
sooner or later, once you heard from
glory.
No, Carol said.
It wasn't about tricking them.
She just wanted to scare them.
That's her favorite kind of power.
Ruby let out a hiss, and peril met her
eyes.
She saw it then.
The new queen was scared of her mother.
As scared of her as peril was.
The peril caught a glimpse of something
else, something bitter and deep inside
Ruby.
It had to do with peril herself.
She curled her talons in.
She'd been thinking of the ways Scarlet
always terrified her.
Not all the ways Scarlet had used her to
terrify others.
Ruby's dark red wings flapped open and
closed, like a rug briskly thrown over a
body.
Wait, she said.
An enchantment?
Doesn't that mean that Scarlet must have
an animus?
No, Sonny said, stretching her neck
uneasily.
No.
We'd all be dead already if that were
true.
Turtle pointed the piece of paper at the
mudwings head.
But, ah, what else is this?
Ruby whipped around suddenly to glare at
peril.
You must know, is there an animus dragon
working for her?
Why would I know?
peril demanded.
Argh.
It would be so satisfying to just stomp
on this dragon's tail and watch it burst
into flames.
She didn't tell me things.
I was her her weapon, not her friend.
You're her daughter.
Why don't you know?
No one can stop an animus, said Clay.
Right?
Except another animus.
He exchanged a glance with Sonny that
looked aggravatingly stuffed with
secrets.
What was that?
Do they know an animus?
Why do they have secrets I don't know
about?
Doesn't Clay know he can tell me
anything?
Peril flicked her tail irritably, and
Ruby leaped away from her, even though
her tail hadn't been anywhere near the
queen's precious scales.
I thought the Sky Wings didn't have any
animus dragons, Turtles said, not for
100s of years, if ever.
Not just Sky Wings, said Ruby, none of
the tribes.
Animus dragons are so rare.
I don't think there's been one in Pyria
in centuries.
The next pause had an extremely strange
awkwardness to it.
Peril glanced from clay to turtle to
sunny, and realized they all knew
something she and Ruby didn't.
What?
peril demanded.
What is it?
Um, my father, Sonny said quickly.
Stone mover, he's an animus.
The old night wing who lives under this
mountain?
Turtle asked.
Judging from his tone of surprise, that
wasn't the secret he'd been thinking of.
Peril wondered if she could threaten it
out of him later.
Wait, no.
This was one of those things Clay had to
remind her about sometimes.
Apparently, friends didn't threaten to
set each other on fire, not very often
anyhow.
Yes, Sonny admitted.
He made the tunnels that lead from the
rainforest to the Nightwing Island, and
the kingdom of sand, but he doesn't use
his powers anymore.
He might have to, Ruby said.
If there's a new animus on the loose
working for Scarlet, and he's the only
one who can stop her.
Could it be another night wing?
Turtle guessed.
Someone who escaped the volcanic island
and went to team up with Scarlet?
Clay shuddered.
That would be not great for us.
I'm not afraid of any animus, peril
blurted.
I bet I could stop it.
Him, her, whatever.
I just have to sneak up on them and then
pow, brain melted, claws a pile of
cinders.
No more creepy enchantments.
Everybody cheers.
For me, everybody cheers for me.
Or at least, Clay tells me I'm
wonderful.
Clay didn't have his your wonderful face
on, though.
He looked all troubled and worried
instead.
But it might not be a bad dragon, Sonny
said.
This animus could be someone Scarlet has
tricked or forced into working for her.
We shouldn't just kill them without
knowing the whole story.
This is definitely not me agreeing with
her, Ruby said, flicking her tail at
peril.
But I think we absolutely should.
Animus dragons are so dangerous, and more
so the more they use their powers.
According to our history, the sky wing
tribe used to kill them the moment we
figured out what they were.
But, Sonny looked aghast, as did Turtle.
You mean, when they were still
dragonettes?
Before they'd even done anything?
Before they could do anything, Ruby
said.
That's our policy with all dragons who
are too dangerous to live.
She slid her narrowed eyes over to peril
who had already figured out the subtext
of this conversation.
Thanks very much.
Oh dear, Sonny said, in a small voice.
That's not fair, Turtle protested.
Animas dragons can maybe do good things
too.
Let's save worrying about it until we
know she really has one, Clay said.
And who it is.
We have enough else to worry about
already.
Like the rest of my winglet, Turtle
said.
Lowering his head.
Do you think Moon and the others are
safe?
Weren't they going after Scarlet?
They were.
But I don't know what's happened, Sonny
said, pressing her claws together
anxiously.
I tried to dream visit Kinkaju and Kibli
last night, but couldn't get into either
of their dreams.
I haven't been able to since they left.
Oh, I hope they're all right.
They probably are, peril said, or else
Scarlet would have been throwing their
heads at you.
She thought that would be very reassuring
but for some reason, it made Sonny look
even more ill.
Someone's coming back.
Play said, standing up and spreading his
wings to catch the attention of the
dragons in the sky.
Three of Ruby's soldiers swooped down
spiraling gracefully until they spotted
peril, at which point they all started
flapping like insane pigeons on fire
until they finally landed in a thumping
row between her and Ruby.
Don't you come near our queen.
One of them snarled.
I wasn't planning on it.
Peril snapped back.
Do you actually think you could stop me
if I was?
Peril, Clay said softly. warningly.
Blah.
It wasn't fair that they could be rude
and she couldn't set them on fire, or
even growl back at them.
But Pearl bit her tongue, sat back, and
folded her wings across her chest, making
sure she took up as little of the space
on the rock ledge as possible.
Clay gave her a sweet, grateful smile
which almost made it okay.
Ignore her.
Ruby ordered her guards.
What happened?
We overtook the sea wing.
But couldn't find Scarlet, said the tall
orange soldier.
The rest are still looking, but we wanted
to come back and make sure you were
guarded, in case it was a trick.
It was in a way, said Ruby, nodding at
the head.
Someone has to catch tsunami, said
Sonny.
We had to tell her it's not glory.
She.
Clay said.
She was somebody.
Even if she's not glory.
He took a deep breath and picked up the
head.
Peril wished she could turn it to ashes.
She didn't like the way the dead brown
eyes were staring at her.
Piles of ashes were much tidier and less
horrifying than stray body parts.
Wait, if we can figure out who she is and
where she's from, Ruby said suddenly, it
might be a clue about where Scarlet is
hiding.
You're right.
Let's take her to Queen Warren.
Clay turned toward Ruby, wincing as he
set his weight on his injured leg.
That's the best place to start.
She nodded.
Tilting her diamond shaped head toward
the orange dragon.
Go catch the sea wing and tell her to
return, she ordered.
My soldiers should split up.
Half keep looking for Scarlet, and the
other half return to me.
We'll leave for Warren's Palace at
midnight.
All the sky wings whirled into the air.
The orange soldier went north, while
Queen Ruby and the other 2 swept south
toward Jade Mountain.
I'm going to try the dream visitor again
Sonny said to Clay.
He reached over, and twined his tail
around hers, and peril felt a stab of
jealousy so fierce.
She was surprised flames didn't come
shooting out of her eyeballs.
They're all right.
I'm sure they are, Clay said quietly to
Sonny.
She shook her head without answering, and
lifted off into the sky.
Only clay and peril were left on the
ledge.
At last, she gazed deep into his warm
brown eyes.
So Scarlet is pretty scary, huh?
Oh, right.
And turtle.
The sea wing edged closer to them
twitching his wings curiously.
Peril tried giving him a significant look
of the go away, we're having a moment
variety, but he didn't seem to notice.
Yes, she is.
Clay said with a sigh.
What kind of sigh was that?
Peril wondered.
Was it an, I wish I were alone with peril
Si?
Or a, worried about my students, Si.
Knowing clay?
It could also be a, we're all out of
goats and I really wanted one, Si.
What are you going to do?
she asked him.
I should stay here and guard the
academy.
He said thoughtfully, but if Ruby agrees
to leave enough guards to protect the
students.
I might go with her to see Queen Warren.
Carol didn't like that plan.
She had a feeling she wouldn't be invited
along on any diplomatic missions
especially any that involved going inside
other queens' palaces, and possibly
incinerating their national treasures by
accident or whatever.
What about me?
She asked.
What should I do?
He gave her a rueful smile that lit
candles in her heart.
Whatever you want to do, peril.
That's the whole point of being free from
scarlet, isn't it?
But what do you want me to do?
She pressed.
Peril, Clay said.
I'm not going to be a new scarlet for
you.
You get to make your own choices now.
I am making my own choices.
Peril thought grumpily.
I'm choosing to do whatever you think I
should do.
Maybe she could figure out what he wanted
from the clues.
Sometimes, when Queen Scarlet was really
angry, She wouldn't speak to peril for
weeks, and then peril had to figure out
on her own what she'd done wrong and how
to fix it to make Queen Scarlet happy
again.
So, what did Clay want?
She studied him from horns to tail?
He had turned to gaze back at Jade
Mountain, his wings drooping heavily.
All right, it was pretty obvious.
He wanted his friends and his school to
be safe.
And the only way to do that was to get
rid of Queen Scarlet forever.
Peril inhaled a sharp breath.
That was it.
Clay would never say it out loud.
He'd never ask her for it directly.
But what he really wanted her to do was
find Queen Scarlet and kill her for him.
She might be the only dragon empire who
could.
Especially if an animus was protecting
Scarlet now.
So as much as she never, never wanted to
see Scarlet again, and as much as the
idea of leaving Clay to find her was
heart wrenching, that was what she was
going to have to do.
It's all right, Clay, she thought.
You don't have to tell me.
I know what you want, and I'll do it for
you.
I'll find Queen Scarlet, and I'll make
sure she never, ever hurts you again.
Chapter 4.
The plan was to sneak away in the middle
of the night.
That sounded like something a hero would
do.
She would set off on her quest alone.
Boldly, but quietly, without giving
anyone a chance to talk her out of it.
Peril could imagine flying bravely into
the night, and even better than that, she
could imagine the scene the next morning
when Clay found her gone, and threw back
his head and cried, no, peril.
She's gone to save us all.
She's so noble and self sacrificing.
But what am I going to do without her?
Oh, the unbearable pain.
But here was the problem.
When she kept going with that scene in
her head, The next thing that happened
was sunny, or a tsunami, or a Starflight
showing up.
And then one of them would say something
like, Or, hey, maybe she's run off
because she's actually evil and in
cahoots with Scarlet after all, and or, I
knew we couldn't trust her.
And it all went downhill from there.
Carol didn't want to leave Clay wondering
what she was really up to.
She didn't care what the others thought
of her, but in all the world, Clay was
the only dragon who saw more good in her
than bad.
She didn't want him to have even a moment
of, is peril really as dangerous and
unstable as everyone's been telling me?
So clearly, she had to say goodbye to
him.
That was obvious.
It wasn't just that she wanted to see him
one more time, or that she was hoping
he'd tell her not to go.
No, no none of those.
It was for his own sake.
Really?
She waited until the halls were quiet, and
then she slipped out of her sleeping cave
which was as bare and empty as the day
she'd stepped into it.
Everyone else in the school had to share
their sleeping cave, but then, no one
else could accidentally burn up her claw
mates just by rolling over in the middle
of the night.
Clay had offered peril a cave closer to
the other students, but he seemed
relieved when she refused it.
So hers was close to the dragonettes who
ran the school instead, but she still had
to go through the main central cave to
get to clay.
Which is where she nearly ran into Turtle
for the 2nd time that day.
Seriously?
If a dragonette insisted on flopping like
a lumpy boulder in the middle of a dimly
lit cave, wasn't it his own fault?
If he got set on fire?
Ah!
Why are you always in the way?
she demanded, backpedaling at the last
minute to avoid stepping on his talons.
Am I?
He said sleepily. lifting his head.
I'm not usually, I don't think.
Other dragons go around me, or over me
pretty well.
You won't be pleased if I go over you
Peril pointed out.
Why aren't you in your own sleeping
cave?
Turtle gave a little shiver.
It feels weird in there now that umber is
gone.
And all the rest of my winglet too.
I should have gone with them.
He mumbled.
Not if they're all dead now.
Peril said sensibly.
If Scarlet has killed them, then staying
here was obviously the smart choice.
He sat up fast.
And peril tilted her head, trying to read
his expression, alarmed or horrified?
Anxiety?
Guilt?
All of the above?
No.
Turtle protested.
Are you crazy?
That would be even worse.
What if you're right, and they're dead
and I could have saved them.
Really?
You?
Peril said.
I do not appreciate your skeptical tone
he said, sounding briefly like an actual
prince.
Just because I don't particularly like
danger or uncertainty or or exercise
doesn't mean I couldn't be useful in a
fight.
Peril paused, trying to figure out how to
say what she wanted to say without the
skeptical tone.
Really?
She tried.
Infusing the word with as much
enthusiastic curiosity as she could.
You?
Turtle burst out laughing.
You're so weird, he said.
I'm not the one sleeping in the entrance
hall, Pearl said, asking to get trampled
and scorched.
Well, the other thing is that tsunami
isn't back yet, he admitted.
I'm sort of waiting for her.
Uh-oh, peril said.
He gave her an anxious look, and she
added quickly, I mean, that probably
doesn't mean anything.
Anything involving decapitation, that
is.
You have this uncanny ability.
To say whatever is the opposite of
comforting.
He observed wryly.
That wasn't comforting?
she asked.
Um, how about, I'm sure she's fine
because a sea wing dragonette like her
could never possibly catch up with a full
grown sky wing like Scarlet.
Oh, unless it was a trap, and Scarlet
ambushed her.
Turtle wrinkled his snout at her, imperil
shifted on her talons.
Okay, I know.
I heard it that time.
But it was a smart thought, wasn't it?
He turned to look out at the stars.
So what do we do?
He asked.
Send more dragons to look for her?
What if Scarlet ambushes everyone?
We don't know how many dragons she might
have working for her.
What if this is her plan?
And she kills everyone we send after
tsunami.
She can't kill me, Pearl pointed out.
I'd like to see her try.
Ha.
Turtle gave her an odd glittering look.
You're right, he said.
You and me, we should go.
That's what I...
Wait, no, she said.
What?
She can definitely kill you.
Maybe not, he said.
Anyway, tsunami's my sister, and my
winglet is out there somewhere.
You hope, Pearl interjected.
Err.
I mean, yes, they are.
Turtle lifted one of his wings to shush
her, tilting his head.
Someone's coming.
He whispered.
Hide.
He ran over to the enormous gong in the
center of the hall and dove behind it.
Startled, Pearl twisted around in a
circle before she found a shadowy corner
where there was an outgrowth of
stalagmites to hide behind.
She tucked herself into the darkness and
whispered loudly, Why are we hiding?
Turtle answered.
Peril tried to remember the last time
she'd ever hidden from anyone before
she'd met Turtle.
Maybe in the kingdom of sand, when she
was trying to sneak up on Burns
stronghold to rescue Scarlet, but hiding
was not normally her approach to
problems.
Why hide?
When you could always set your problem on
fire.
Now she could hear voices approaching.
One of them sounded like Clay, who was
exactly the dragon she was looking for
except now, if she popped out of her
hiding place, he'd be like, um, what were
you doing back there?
And it would look so, so weird and maybe
suspicious too.
Argh!
Thanks a lot, turtle.
What is with this dragon in the
eavesdropping?
10 soldiers should be enough to guard
this place.
Ruby's voice said.
Peril heard 3 sets of talons enter the
cave, and she pressed herself closer to
the floor.
And with luck, we'll be back in 3 days.
I don't want to be away from the Sky
Palace for too long.
I have someone waiting for me.
Thank you, Queen Ruby.
That was Starflight, the Nightwing
librarian.
Did your student tell you anything else
we should know?
Ruby asked.
Apart from the disturbing news about my
mother's new ally?
Not much, play said with a sigh.
Moons in Possibility with Kibley.
Sunny is dream visiting with glory now, so
she can send someone up to the town to
take care of Kinkachu.
Poor Kinkaju, Starflight said softly.
Uh-oh.
Peril thought.
She had seen the bouncy little rain wing
from a distance, but mostly she'd only
heard about her from clay.
If she was hurt, he must be upset.
And what had happened to the other
missing dragonette?
Winter, the ice wing who hated her.
Peril would be all right with him being
dead out of the 4 dragonettes, but Clay
wouldn't, of course.
He'd feel all responsible and protective
and worried.
Oh dear, was he all right?
She wished she could see his face.
One last word of warning, although I know
you won't listen to me, Ruby said
stopping with a loud swish of her tail.
You cannot trust my mother's creature.
She's unpredictable, and knows nothing
but killing.
If you won't banish her, at least don't
leave her unguarded for an instant.
I can trust peril.
Clay said.
And in her shadows, peril felt her entire
soul turn into a fireball.
She saved my life.
Plus, she's in love with Clay, Starflight
added.
Pearl wondered if anyone would notice if
she flew over, ripped out his tongue and
vanished into the night sky forever.
Ah, clay said. 3 moon Starfight.
That's not, it's not even, we're, no, no
no.
I trust her because there's good in her.
And we just need to give her a chance to
show it to us.
She may have a fragment of good in her
somewhere, Ruby said doubtfully, but
she'll never be good enough for you.
And if he's right, and if she ever thinks
you don't love her back, she will set all
your friends on fire.
That's just the truth.
Um, said Starflight.
For the record, I don't like the sound of
that at all.
Peril closed her eyes.
Was it true?
What would happen if Clay didn't love
her?
Or if he ever tried to send her away?
It was a horrible, soul crushing
thought.
But she wouldn't really set his friends
on fire, would she?
Not all of them anyway?
No, she told herself severely.
None of them, not even if it's their
fault he doesn't love me.
But what a tsunami convinced him to get
rid of her.
She might totally do something like
that.
Then could peril set just the tiniest
part of her on fire?
No, no, no.
Because there's always the chance he
might still love me one day.
But he definitely won't if there's any
friend burning at all.
Let's not talk about this, Clay said
awkwardly.
Your majesty, I'll meet you back here at
midnight.
All right, well, she said.
You've been warned.
She swept majestically out of the cave.
Her tail making quiet, dramatic swishing
noises against the stone floor.
Should I be worried?
Starflight asked.
Am I going to wake up on fire one day?
How worried should I be?
Not at all, Clay said.
Peril is not going to set you on fire.
I wonder if I have any scrolls about
sociopaths.
Starflight muttered.
Stop that.
Clay stamped one of his feet.
I'm going to ask Sonny to dream visit
tsunami and see if she can find her.
Queen Ruby will never believe peril has
changed, Starflight called after him.
There was a pause as Clay's footsteps
faded away.
Not sure we will either, he added to
himself, and then peril heard his talons
scrape against the rock as he bustled off
to the library.
Silence, fell across the cavern.
Pearl curled her claws in and took a deep
breath.
Sorry about that, Turtle said.
His voice whispering across the empty
space.
A few moments later, his head popped
around the edge of the rocks she was
hiding behind.
I've been doing that all my life, and
I've never heard anyone say anything
about me.
That's because you're boring and
forgettable, Pearl snapped.
I know, he said unexpectedly.
I try to be.
Well, I don't have that option, she said
spreading her smoking talons.
Roar.
This would be a really good time to have
a dungeon full of enemies.
What?
He said.
Why?
Because, she said, when you're mad, it's
useful to have dragons around that you
can set on fire without getting in
trouble.
He rolled his eyes.
Somehow, I don't think Clay and
Starflight would be pleased if you said
anyone on fire, even their enemies.
That makes no sense, Pearl said.
Everyone wants to see their enemies on
fire.
Are you telling me your mother never
cheered herself up by having someone
torch a bunch of bad guys in front of
her?
Um, no, said Turtle.
First of all, we're sea wings, so we
don't have fire, remember?
Secondly, my mother mostly cheered
herself up by writing scrolls about all
her problems.
And third, she used her prisoners as
bargaining chips, not toys.
Our prisoners were definitely Scarlet's
toys, Pearl said.
And so were you, it sounds like.
Carol snorted a burst of flame, and he
jumped back.
No, I was more than that.
I was like a daughter to her.
All right.
All right, he said.
So what are you going to do about Ruby
and Clay and all of that?
What can I do?
She said.
You heard Starflight?
They'll never trust me with clay, and
they're right.
I'm not good enough for him.
He's good all the way through, not just
in little fragments.
I mean, if Saving Clay's life wasn't
enough, what else is there?
I can think of one thing, he said.
I bet it would make everyone forgive you
even Ruby.
Well, Pearl said.
Yes, I thought of that.
You have to kill Queen Scarlet, he said
and I'm coming with you.
Chapter 5.
The clouds swept past them like ribbons
of smoke, sliced and scattered by the
slash of their wings.
Below them, the claws of the clouds
mountains lurked like the long, long
spine of a giant sleeping dragon, black
except where the craggy peaks were
studded with light from the moons.
Peril could see the silver flicker of the
winding tail river, running along the
eastern edge of the mountain range.
They were about to fly over the curve
where it veered east and then north
again.
She loved flying.
And not just because she was a sky wing
and all Sky Wings loved to fly.
It was more than that for her.
There was nothing else in her life that
she could love in such a joyful
uncomplicated way.
Up in the sky, she could stretch her
wings as wide as she wanted.
She could whip her tail and dive and soar
and spin, and she didn't have to keep all
her limbs so carefully close to her
watching her perimeter every moment.
Up here, there was nothing to burn.
Everyone and everything was safe from her
as long as she was in the sky.
At least, that was usually the case.
She didn't normally have a sea wing
flapping around on her tail.
He was doing a reasonably good job of
keeping his distance, but she felt a
startled jolt every time she saw him out
of the corner of her eye.
Peril still wished she could have talked
to Clay before she left.
But she wasn't sure she could look him in
the face anymore, after the conversation
she'd overheard.
Not until I am bringing him the charred
bones of Queen Scarlet anyway.
Where are we going?
Turtle called from behind her.
She twisted in midair to give him an
incredulous look.
To kill Queen Scarlet, she said.
Remember?
There was a whole conversation a few
hours ago.
I'm pretty sure you were there because I
was like, you're not coming with me, and
you were all, how are you going to stop
me?
And I was all, I can think of a pretty
good way, and you were like, by setting
me on fire.
That sounds like cutting off your tail
despite your wings.
And I was like, I could cut off your tail
and you were all, let's just go before
Ruby comes back.
All right.
Turtle finally interrupted.
I know all that.
I mean, where are we going to kill Queen
Scarlet?
How do we even start looking for her?
Or my sister?
Oh.
Carol did a looping flip in the sky.
She had searched for Scarlet for months
after releasing her from Burns Weirdling
Tower with no success.
What did she think would be different
now?
The mountains?
she suggested Maybe we could fly around
them.
A lot.
Forgive me for mentioning this, Turtle
said, but I'm getting the impression that
you're not much of a planner.
What have I ever needed to plan?
Peril demanded.
Do you know anything about my life?
Here's how it went.
Wake up, eat breakfast.
Queen Scarlet tells me to kill one of her
prisoners.
I kill that prisoner, eat dinner, go back
to sleep.
Pretty simple.
Not a lot of big decision making
involved.
Really?
Turtle asked.
Were you happy?
Peril let herself drop to a warmer air
current, trying to think, happy.
Was that how she'd felt back then?
It was definitely easier than life after
Queen Scarlet?
Or rather, life after meeting Clay?
In the Sky Palace, she'd had a purpose.
There was a reason for her scales to be
as deadly as they were.
She'd been loyal to the queen, and she'd
thought the queen cared about her too.
Most of the time.
Maybe half the time.
Well, some of the time anyhow.
She was probably supposed to say
something about how terrible it was to
kill all those dragons, how it ate her up
inside every night and made her miserable
but it didn't.
Not back then, not while it was
happening.
She'd been killing dragons for Queen
Scarlet for as long as she could
remember.
That was just... her life.
I had an idea, Turtle said.
I bet tsunami will head for water if
she's stopped anywhere.
Can we check for clues down by the
river?
Peril was too busy thinking to argue with
him.
She followed him down in a drifting
spiral. until they reached a rocky spot
along the riverbank.
Turtle landed in the water with a splash
while peril came down gently on the
shore.
She'd tried to aim for a spot with
nothing but rocks and sand, but her tail
accidentally flicked against a small
shrub growing near the water.
It instantly burst into flames, and
almost as quickly burned out into a
blackened heap, shriveled branches
sticking out of it like skeletal claws.
Ach, Pearl said, curling her tail in.
Sorry.
Turtle blinked at the planned, but didn't
say anything.
He stuck his nose in the river and then
shook it, spraying droplets everywhere.
A few hit peril, sizzling on her scales.
Maybe I wasn't happy.
She blurted.
He looked startled and a little confused
as if he'd forgotten what they were
talking about.
She couldn't stop herself from barreling
on, though.
But I also wasn't so worried all the
time.
I only had one dragon to please, and I
didn't always manage that, but at least I
understood what I needed to do.
Now everything is confusing.
I guess.
I mean, which would you rather be?
Lonely?
or insecure?
The seawing spread his wings across the
surface of the water, sending ripples out
in all directions.
Well, he said.
I've tried lonely, so maybe I'd pick
insecure.
He pounced suddenly, sending a cascade of
water over Parel's talons, and then sat
up, brandishing a fish speared on one of
his claws.
Hungry?
No thanks, Pearl said.
She glanced up and down the river.
Two of the moons were up, so she could
see the outline of trees on the far side
and the small flutterings of owls
swooping through hunting.
Turtle began splashing upriver, and peril
followed him, pacing along the river bank
and avoiding anything that looked
flammable.
Maybe we should head to possibility.
Turtle said.
We can meet up with Moon and Kibley there
and find out what happened to Winter and
Kinkaju.
His voice hitched slightly on the last
word, and peril gave him a sharp look.
What was that?
she demanded.
Are you about to cry?
No, he said, biting a head off the fish.
I'm just worried about them They're safer
in possibility than anywhere.
Pearl said.
It's a town full of dragons, and more
than half of them aren't too fond of
Queen Scarlet.
At least, they really, really don't like
being asked about her.
They tend to throw things, which they
also do when you set even the smallest
basket of snails on fire.
By accident, mind you.
Frankly, I think they should rename the
place unnecessary violent overreaction.
In the moonlight.
She couldn't tell if turtle's expression
was concerned or mildly amused.
Anyway, she went on, I'm not looking for
an entourage.
If I take more dragons with me to face
Queen Scarlet, it just means more dragons
for her to kill.
Is that what you think is going to happen
to me?
he asked.
Probably, she said.
I mean, wait, what's the reassuring thing
to say?
No, he said.
That one's pretty easy.
The correct answer is no.
Oh, she said.
Okay, that.
But Moon and Kibli might know where
Scarlet is.
Turtle pointed out.
A choir of yawping frogs had been
burbling away nearby, but cut off
abruptly as the dragons approached.
Ruby said they told Sonny something about
a new ally of hers.
Remember?
Peril frowned.
How could Queen Scarlet have a new ally?
Who was it?
And where did he come from?
Does she like him more than me?
She called herself with a stamp of
annoyance that sent sparks flying off one
of the stones underfoot?
Of course, Scarlet would like her new
ally more than peril.
Whoever it was must have agreed to help
her when peril wouldn't.
Also, more importantly, peril shouldn't
care anymore.
It was habit to want Scarlet to like her
more than anyone, but it was a bad habit
and she wished she could scour it out of
her brain.
The new ally.
Was it an animus dragon?
The one who had enchanted the severed
head?
Did that mean other magic was lurking up
ahead for them?
Um...
Does it seem quieter than it should be?
Turtle asked, pausing in the center of
the river.
Peril stopped and listened too.
The water shivered softly around turtles
talons, as if it were trying to echo the
rustling leaves in the wind overhead.
But there were no more owls swooping, no
frogs glurping.
It seemed as though even the insects had
fallen silent.
Peril slowly twisted in place, scanning
the dark trees, wishing she had night
vision.
Was that a glimmer of silver scales off
to the left?
Did she just imagine the crack of a
branch snapping under talons?
Could she smell a hint of smoke on the
air?
And then, all of a sudden, the river
exploded.
Turtle let out a yell of fright as 3
dragons burst out of the water almost
directly beneath his talons.
They seized his wings and tail, and
pinned him down with a violent splash
that cascaded over Peril's scales.
At the same moment, 2 more dragons flew
out of the forest, their claws
outstretched and teeth bared.
Carol whirled to face them, flinging her
wings open.
Try to grab me.
Just try.
A dazzling thrill darted through her like
lightning.
These dragons were attacking her.
She could totally set them on fire
without getting in trouble.
I'm not being bad, Clay.
I'm just defending myself.
She flexed her talons and tried to squash
her grin.
Don't touch her, turtle bellowed
thrashing around like a vomiting whale.
It'll kill you.
Her scales are fire.
The 2 dragons skidded to a stop just out
of her reach.
Their claws left grooves in the pebbled
sand, and their wings flung a blanket of
hot air in her direction.
Way to spoil my fun, turtle.
Although, yes, fine.
Warning them was probably the clay
approved thing to do.
He's right, she said, glowering at her
attackers.
I am peril of the sky wings.
Perhaps you've heard of me?
One of the dragons was a big red sky wing
and Perel definitely saw her flinch and
take a step back.
But if you'd like to find out whether
he's telling the truth, come a bit closer
and we can do a fun experiment.
She spread her wet front talons in front
of her, and smiled wickedly at the coils
of steam still rising from them.
It's true, said the sky wing.
I recognize her now.
Stay back, Sirius.
The other dragon, a severe looking ice
wing, gave peril a scornful look, as if
he highly doubted anyone, even a fire
scales dragon could possibly be a match
for him.
Ooh, please try it, peril thought, giving
him an innocent expression.
So it's not scarlet.
Asked one of the sea wings.
The Skywing lashed her tail.
No, this is peril, who might be worse.
I beg your pardon, said peril, genuinely
offended.
Maybe you haven't heard?
I'm friends with the dragonettes of
destiny now.
I don't set other dragons on fire
anymore.
Not unless they provoke me, she added
shooting the ice wing of fierce glare.
That is one of the rumors going around
said the Sky Wing, but we all know a
dragon can't change her scales.
Maybe not, but I can change my mind, peril
said defiantly, unlike some dragons
apparently.
I've not only heard of you, little
monster, said the sky wing.
I was one of the guards sent after your
mother when she tried to escape with
you.
She took a step toward peril, lashing her
tail and looking murderous.
Avalanche, one of the sea wings said
softly.
Careful.
My biggest regret, said avalanche, smoke
billowing from her mouth and ears.
Is that we didn't kill you then?
I don't care that Kestrel got away.
But if I'd known Scarlet would keep you
alive.
Wait, said Cyrus, flaring his silver
white wings.
Did you say kestrel?
Avalanche gave him an irritated look.
Yes, what?
Kestrel of the sky wings.
Sarah said.
Big, red, grumpy looking.
You've just described 50% of all Skywings
said the mudwing, sitting on top of
turtle.
The other half is big, orange, and grumpy
looking.
What does she have to do with anything?
Cyrus asked.
She was this creature's mother.
Avalanche said, the one who wouldn't hand
her over to be killed.
Cyrus frowned, carving deep canyons
across his forehead.
That can't be right.
Kestrel never had any dragonettes.
Ha!
Avalanche muttered.
We all wish that were true.
Did you know her?
Harold asked Sirius.
He was shaking his head, but there was
something weird in his expression.
I doubt you would have met.
Said the sea wing who'd spoken before.
She joined the talons of peace before you
did, and then she was assigned to
guarding the dragonettes underground
before you came to us.
Once the guardians went into hiding with
the eggs.
Most of the talons of peace never saw
them.
But you did?
Peril asked the ice wing again.
Cyrus looked as if a pile of ashes was
slowly turning back into a dragon right
in front of his eyes, but was he happy?
Angry?
confused?
She couldn't tell what he even thought
about Kestrel, although he was clearly
feeling something.
No.
He said, shaking his head again more
vigorously.
Not.
That is, only by reputation.
Peril wondered if he was lying.
But how could an ice wing have known her
mother?
If they didn't meet in the talons of
peace.
Can I get back to my menacing story now?
Avalanche demanded.
Oh, let me skip to the ending, Peril
said.
You failed to catch or kill my mother as
she escaped.
You were punished.
Then you discovered that I was still
alive, instead of flung off a cliff like
most fire scales dragonettes, and you've
been seething about it ever since.
Which is funny because I have never had
even one thought about you in my entire
life.
Avalanche glowered at her for a long
moment.
Peril flicked her tail gently, casually
and a clump of reeds burst into flames
behind her.
Oops, she said.
There was something very satisfying about
how the sea wings yelped and went
scrambling around, splashing water over
the fire with their wings.
Of course, peril had really done it to
see that expression of powerless fury on
avalanches' face.
Are you in league with Scarlet?
One of the sea wings asked breathlessly
when the fire was out.
We heard she was recently seen not far
from here.
Do you know where she is?
No, peril snapped.
We're looking for her too, turtle
offered.
His voice muffled by the mud winged tail
draped across his face.
I mean, he added hastily, not to join her
to, uh, kill her and stuff.
We need to have a chat about oversharing
turtle.
Who are you?
Pearl demanded, hoping to turn the tables
on them?
We're from the talons of peace.
My name is Nautilus, said the green
seawing, who done the most talking.
We spotted you flying, and we've been
tracking you for a while.
There are several groups out looking for
an orange sky wing tonight.
Since I'm clearly not Scarlet, said
Turtle's squash sounding voice, is there
any chance I could get up now?
Oh, yes, sorry.
Nautilus flicked his tail at the other 2
dragons, motioning them away.
The mud wings scowled as she heaved
herself off turtle's wings.
How did you know Scarlet was around?
Turtle asked.
Stretching his wings and neck with little
crackling noises?
Did someone see her?
One of your alleged friends, in fact
avalanche sneered at peril.
Tsunami tried to chase her, but when she
lost Scarlet not far from here.
She came to the talons of peace for extra
help.
Nautilus puffed up his chest.
With all of us looking, Scarlet won't get
far.
Tsunami is with you, turtle blurted.
Where?
Can we see her?
We have a message for her.
She's out hunting Scarlet with riptide in
his group right now.
Nautilus said haughtily.
But I can pass along anything you want
her to know.
All right.
Tell her glory isn't dead, Turtle said.
Tell her it was a trick.
It was a different dragon.
Glory is fine.
You have to tell her that as soon as
possible.
Nautilus and Avalanche exchanged glances
and peril realized that now they believed
them.
So maybe Turtle's forest fire approach to
blathering information was not so
terrible after all.
Oh, go, said the other Seawing.
I think I know where their patrol went.
He spread his wings and took off from the
water in one smooth motion, like a small
island suddenly whisking into the sky.
Nautilus watched him go, but peril saw
that the ice wing, Sirius, still had his
glittering eyes on her.
Are you wondering if my fire works on ice
wing scales?
She asked him.
The answer is yes.
Your wings and talons and face will melt
and shrivel into ash just like anyone
else's.
I know from experience.
We're not going to release them into the
wild.
Sarah's hissed at the others, ignoring
her.
You said it yourself.
She's even more dangerous than Scarlet.
Wow, you have a very confused and amusing
view of this situation, Pearl said.
We're not your prisoners.
You couldn't take me a prisoner even with
an army of ice wings, not even if all of
them had arrogant foreheads like yours.
There isn't actually a world in which you
need to decide whether to release me.
I released myself a long time ago, but
thanks anyway.
She thought she was actually showing
remarkably noble restraint here.
He was basically asking to have his
talents scorched off.
We have no reason to hold them. said
Nautilus.
Especially since you literally can't
peril pointed out.
Maybe she needed to set something else on
fire to make this point.
Hey, we're all on the same side here
Turtle said.
Avalanche snorted, sending tiny puffs of
smoke out of her ears.
We all want to catch Scarlet.
And where are you going to look for her?
Siri demanded.
We're going to possibility first, said
Turtle.
Not that it's any of your business, Peril
said, giving Turtle a stern look.
To find our friends, Turtle added, as if
stern looks completely meant nothing in
his universe, please tell tsunami that
too.
We will, said Nautilus.
He nudged one of turtles' wings with
his.
It was one of those casual things peril
saw dragons due to other members of their
tribes all the time.
In this case, it was the kind of touch
that she guessed meant, we're both sea
wings, so in the end we'll stick
together.
Nobody had ever nudged peril that way.
Apart from the fact that it would
probably kill them.
No other Sky Wing had ever wanted to
acknowledge that they were in the same
tribe.
There was this whole language of nudges
and tail flicks and wing brushing that
peril couldn't speak.
Except with clay.
But trying to speak it with clay, made
her feel like a dragon with no tongue and
no ears.
What did it mean when he brushed her wing
with his as he went by in the tunnels?
Did it mean, I love you as much as you
love me, even if our deep, powerful
feelings cannot be expressed aloud?
Or don't worry.
I see how nervous you are, but remember
I'm always here to take care of you.
Or it's a dark world, peril, but you and
I will stand in the fire and be safe
because we have each other.
Sometimes she worried that it just meant
hey.
But she couldn't ask him.
She couldn't let him know that she was
even weirder and more confused than he
realized.
Good luck, Nautilus said.
You too, said Turtle.
I hope you die.
Avalanche said to peril.
I would say it's mutual, said peril
except that I'm going to forget you exist
in about a minute, so I don't actually
care.
She was rewarded for that brilliance with
another expression of helpless rage.
That's right, you self-righteous fish
nose.
I learned a few things from Queen Scarlet
who could burn dragons without touching
them.
Shooting a scornful look at avalanche and
cirrus, peril leaped into the sky with
turtle not far behind her.
As she wheeled to fly north, she thought
about what she'd said to avalanche.
I'll forget you exist in a minute.
I don't actually care.
If only it were true.
Part two.
Possibility.
Chapter 6.
They flew north toward possibility for 2
days.
Two days of soaring over the mountains, 2
days of arguing over weather to even go
to possibility at all, although in the
end, peril gave in, because she couldn't
think of any better ways to track
Scarlet.
She quickly learned that Turtle didn't
have half the stamina as she did for long
flights.
That was probably a sea wing sky wing
thing, or possibly a turtle would rather
be napping than exercising thing.
They had to rest, ridiculously often.
He would find a lake and float around
moaning about his sore wings, while she
swooped in ever widening circles, scanning
the ground with sharp eyes.
There was no sign of Scarlet anywhere
though.
Once, they saw another wing of dragons
who were probably from the talons of
peace, given the different colors of
their scales, but it was far off in the
distance.
Perhaps they had heard about the
encounter by the river, because they
didn't come over to investigate peril.
Peril also spotted several sky wings
spiraling around the mountain peaks.
She wondered if Ruby had sent out more
soldiers to search for Queen Scarlet.
Ruby's throne was in danger, now that
everyone knew the former queen was
definitely alive and out for vengeance
until someone killed her.
Scarlet would always have supporters in
the sky kingdom.
What if one of them decided to kill Ruby
on her behalf?
I bet she wishes she'd been nicer to me
now.
Who'd be a better guard than me?
Yes, I'm dangerous.
That's exactly what's awesome about me.
That's why she needs me.
I should be right next to the queen, not
banished from the whole smoldering
kingdom.
But then, if she'd stayed with Ruby, she
couldn't be wherever Clay was.
So I'll do this one thing for Ruby.
I'll find Queen Scarlet, turn her into a
pile of ashes, get all redeemed and
pardoned, and welcomed back everywhere
and then return to Clay as a beloved Sky
Wing who can go anywhere I want.
And be with anyone I want, because I'll
be a hero too.
Peril did 3 backward loops in the sky
waiting for Turtle to catch up.
She could see the rosy, fuzzy glow around
the ridiculous fantasy she was building
in her head, but she couldn't help it.
She still kind of believed it could come
true.
Turtle flapped up, panting a little.
I think, he wheezed, someone might be
following us.
Really?
Peril scanned the horizon behind them.
They were out of the mountains now, flying
over the rocky, sloping hills that led to
the river plain, and then north to
possibility.
The smudge of the town was visible in the
distance.
They could probably reach it by
nightfall.
Well, she could, if she were flying
alone.
With a gasping sea wing on her tail
they'd probably have to sleep on it and
get there in the morning.
In any case, the landscape below and
behind them was relatively flat compared
to the claws of the clouds mountains, so
it would be harder for a dragon following
them to hide.
I don't see anything, she said.
That grove of trees back there.
Turtle pointed.
I thought I saw a dragon dive into them
when I turned around.
Peril squinted, trying to figure out if
she could see wings moving in the
scraggly clump of wishful forest.
One way to find out, of course, would be
to go set the trees on fire.
It didn't seem worth the effort, though.
Was it an orange dragon?
she asked.
No, Turtle said.
Black, I think.
Pearl shrugged.
All right, whatever.
She lifted herself to another current, so
she could spin around at a safe distance
from turtle, and began flying north
again.
Really?
Turtle said, beating his wings to keep
up.
We're not worried about that.
Why would we be?
Pearl asked, amused.
As long as it's not Scarlet?
Who cares?
It's not like anyone can hurt us.
Well, me, no one can hurt me.
I guess you are welcome to worry.
Oh, thanks very much, Turtle said.
And that's not true.
I'm sure dragons can hurt you.
How?
Peril demanded.
No, they can't.
I'm fine as long as I don't listen to
them.
They're all stupid anyway.
Who cares what a bunch of ruby butt noses
say?
Not me, that's for sure.
I mean, come over here and say that with
my talons up your snout.
Ha!
He gave her an odd look.
Actually, I meant with a spear, or frost
breath, or something.
Oh, peril said, I guess, maybe.
The dragons in the arena never had
spears.
And their wings were bound, so they
couldn't fly, right?
Turtle asked.
Peril frowned at him.
I didn't fly while we were fighting
either, she said.
That wasn't to make them easier to kill.
That was so they wouldn't be boring and
run away.
You mean be sensible and run away, Turtles
said.
He twisted around to look behind them
again.
Nothing.
Whoever it is is still hiding.
Or you hallucinated it.
Perl said grumpily.
Frost breath doesn't do anything to my
scales, by the way, and I bet a spear
would burn up before it could stab me.
Not if someone threw it at you really
hard.
Turtle mused.
Then it would be like, bam, spear through
the heart.
And even if it did then burst into
flames.
Well, too late.
This conversation is fun, Perl said.
Next, let's talk about all the ways you
could possibly die.
I have a few ideas.
Or if Scarlet has an animus, she could
enchant something to kill you, Turtle
pointed out, then there's nothing you
could do about it.
But if she could do that, glory really
would be dead already, Peril argued, and
Ruby.
Those are the 2 she would start with.
I'm only like 7th or 8th on our list
probably.
So I'm not going to worry about imaginary
animus dragons until those guys start
turning up dead.
She fell silent abruptly.
Realizing that Clay was probably in
Scarlet's top 5 on her to be murdered
list.
Maybe I shouldn't have left him alone.
Maybe he's the one I should be guarding
all the time, day and night, never
leaving his side.
She let herself imagine that for a while
before coming back to reality with a
sigh.
No, the best way to protect Clay was
exactly what she was doing, going after
Scarlet.
How are you going to find your friends
and possibility?
she asked Turtle.
It's a big city, full of dragons who have
irrationally negative feelings about me
and too many wooden buildings too close
together.
I don't like it.
For the record, it's a stupid place.
You've mentioned that, Turtle said
glancing over his shoulder again.
Can we rest for the night and figure it
out in the morning when we get there?
My wings are so sore.
I swear they're about to fall off.
They've never been in this much pain
ever.
Harold traced the river below them with
her eyes, up to the town in the near
distance.
It was so close.
Then again, why was she hurrying to get
somewhere?
She didn't even want to be at all?
All right.
Pearl agreed.
Let's find a spot with fewer trees and
more rocks.
The sun was sinking way out beyond the
desert when they came down to land near
the river, in a spot where giant boulders
overlapped one another halfway into the
water, and small rapids bustled noisily
around them.
Peril tried to be careful, but there were
too many patches of moss, and she felt a
twinge of familiar guilt as some of them
curled into blackened ash below her
claws.
Also, as she settled on a boulder, her
tail slipped into a little pool nearby
and immediately boiled the 2 fish
swimming there, they floated to the
surface, white bellies turned up to the
purpling sky.
Shoot, peril said.
I mean, hey, look, dinner.
Turtle splashed over through the river
speared one of the fish with a claw and
winced.
Ouch.
I don't think I could ever get used to
eating hot prey.
And such a weird feeling in my mouth.
I've never eaten prey any other way, Pearl
pointed out.
It's always black and crunchy.
A little like the black rocks Queen
Scarlet tricked me into eating when I was
younger.
The queen had convinced Pearl that
because of her fire scales condition, she
needed to eat a certain kind of black
rock every day.
It could only be found in the mountains
and Scarlett took charge of Peril's
supply.
I'm the one keeping you alive.
That's what she always said.
But it was a lie, a trick, to keep peril
confined to the Sky Palace, and dependent
on Queen Scarlet.
Even though peril had always obeyed the
Queen's every order, Scarlet still never
trusted her.
What did she think I would do?
Run away?
Try to steal the throne?
Join the talons of peace?
Think for myself?
Peril shook off that thought with a
growl.
It wasn't personal, though, she had to
remind herself.
Queen Scarlet manipulated everyone she
came into contact with, not only peril.
Well, that's just sad, Turtle said.
And after a minute, peril realized he was
still talking about how she only ate
burnt prey.
He rolled his shoulders back and forth
stretching his neck and making agonized
faces at his sore muscles.
You should try its normal way.
Here, open your mouth and I'll throw some
in.
He snared another fish from the river
beside his boulder.
That sounds insane.
Peril observed.
What are you talking about?
Keep your mouth open and the fish won't
touch your scales, he said.
Placidly ripping the fish into small
pieces.
That way it won't get burned, and you can
see what it tastes like to most dragons.
Dubiously, Pearl stretched her jaws wide
open.
A fish head smacked her in the eye.
Yuck!
she roared, surging up with her wings
flared.
Try that again, Seawing.
I'm sorry, he yelled.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
I missed.
Here, let me try again.
She eyed him suspiciously.
He looked not so much deeply repentant as
trying to hide his giggles.
Did you do that on purpose?
She demanded.
No, I swear, he said, but I don't have
very good aim, not a lot of practice.
Give me another chance.
Growling softly.
Peril opened her mouth again.
The next 2 pieces sailed straight past
her head, but the 3rd finally splatted
between her teeth, and she snapped her
jaws shut around it.
It felt like a cold, slimy frog had just
leaped into her mouth.
She chewed for a moment, as long as she
could bear it, and then swallowed fast.
No, she said, definitely no.
Horrifying amounts of no, that was 100
disgusting.
Turtle laughed.
You're so wrong, he said.
It's awesome.
That's how fish should be eaten.
Pearl said strongly.
She hopped to the next boulder, heading
for the shore.
I'm going to find something that is the
opposite of fish, scorch it, and then
coat my tongue with char to get that
taste out of my mouth.
Yuck.
You are the worst.
I would be so justified in setting you on
fire while you're asleep tonight.
Duly noted.
Turtle said serenely.
Did I mention I'll be sleeping in the
bottom of the river?
You know, if you're looking for me.
He grinned at her.
Peril paused on the river bank, squinting
at him.
She had been joking, of course.
There were a number of excellent reasons
not to set turtle on fire, which
outweighed any potential benefits to
doing so.
But it unsettled her for a moment to
realize that by sleeping in the river
even by standing in the river right now
he could foil any plan she did make if
she ever needed to burn him up.
Not that I would, probably.
I most likely would never need to, and I
wouldn't want to, of course, that too.
But she'd never run into a situation
where someone could stop her like that
apart from clay.
Maybe I did have an unfair advantage
fighting sea wings in the arena.
If I were fighting them in their own part
of the world, somewhere they could go
underwater to escape, or even drag me
underwater with them.
She didn't like that train of thought.
She didn't like one single thing about
it.
I'll be back in a minute, she snapped.
I'll be here, apologizing to my woebegone
wings, he said.
She stomped off, ignoring the trail of
scorched grass she left in her wake as
she searched the shoreline for prey.
After a few minutes, a hare bolted out of
a burrow in front of her, and she was
able to catch it and wolf it down.
On her way back, she caught sight of
turtle lying on one of the boulders.
The sun was halfway down, casting warm
orange light across his dark green scales
and the seawing was doing something odd.
She paused to stare at him for a moment.
It looked as if he was rolling a small
river stone across his shoulders.
What are you doing?
she asked coming up behind him.
He jumped, looking fascinatingly guilty.
There was definitely something not right
about this.
Nothing, he said.
Just trying to work out the kinks in my
back.
I've never flown this much before.
So you've mentioned a few 100 times, Pearl
said.
Can I see the rock you're using?
Oh, this?
he said.
Just a rock I picked up from the river.
He held it out casually.
The smooth gray white stone, looking like
a hawk's egg in his webbed talons.
Does it really help?
She asked.
Uh, he said, a little.
He rolled his shoulders again.
Anyway, woo, I'm tired.
I'll see you in the morning.
He dove into the water and vanished below
the surface, taking the rock with him.
Pearl sat down on her boulder and flipped
her tail over her talons.
It was hard to tell in the growing dusk
but she was pretty sure the blurry shape
of turtle was still applying the rock to
his scales underwater.
That was weird, she mused.
He could have stayed up here and talked
to me for a little bit longer.
Did he think I was going to steal his
rock?
Is it some kind of sea wing secret?
I shouldn't know?
River rocks can heal them or something?
That sounded pretty implausible.
Even to someone who had been raised not
to know much about other tribes.
Maybe he was simply trying to get away
from her.
Maybe he'd finally realized, like every
other dragon in the world, that she was a
terrible dragon to be friends with.
But he'd been laughing with her only a
few minutes earlier.
Doesn't matter, she thought fiercely.
Whatever it is, that's just fine.
He can keep his secrets or stop being
friends with me or whatever he wants.
I can always go back to clay, my real
friend.
You're not that important to me either
Sea Wing.
Humph.
She lay down and closed her eyes, but
sleep was a long time coming.
Chapter 7.
The next morning, Turtle was mostly
normal, a little jittery, but it could
have been excitement about being so close
to finding his winglet again.
His friends, and then he'll probably
ditch me.
Carol realized.
She guessed the others wouldn't be too
thrilled about her coming along
especially that ice wing, if he was still
alive and around anywhere.
Well, if she had to find Scarlet on her
own, that was probably better anyway.
She sat on the boulder where she'd slept
watching turtles splash around after his
breakfast, he had a small waterproof
pouch around his neck, which looked
heavier than usual this morning.
From the way it thumped against his chest
Perl guessed that he'd put one of the
river rocks in there.
His only other accessory was a gold
armband with 3 sparkly black rocks set in
it, +3 holes where it seemed as though
other rocks should have been.
Peril had noticed that he fiddled with it
when he was nervous.
Sticking his claws into the holes and
tugging the armband up and down.
Why are you glaring at me?
Turtle asked.
I'm not glaring, Pearl snapped.
This is my face.
Your face kind of looks like it hates me
today, Turtle observed.
Can you remind it that I'm really quite
nice?
Carol concentrated on her expression for
a moment, but she could feel her frown
only getting deeper.
All right, now I'm glaring at you, she
said.
Can we get on with this annoying day
already?
Are you nervous about going to
possibility?
Turtle said shrewdly.
We won't have to be there long.
Maybe no one will even notice you.
You really have no idea what it's like to
be me.
Pearl said, arching her neck and flaring
her wings.
The rising sun slammed into her scales
scattering into bright orange reflections
in the water below her.
I've never not been noticed.
That's not an option for me.
Imagine my life as the literal opposite
of yours.
He didn't answer.
Pearl squinted at him and realized he was
peering at a spot along the muddy shore
of the river.
What?
she demanded.
What's so fascinating?
I'm guessing these talon prints aren't
yours, he said.
Peril hopped into the river and splashed
over to him, sending up clouds of steam
all around her.
Turtle didn't flail away in a panic like
most dragons would.
He moved over quietly, so she could see
the mud, where a set of prints were
clearly embedded, along with the sweep of
a tail around them.
Someone had been standing here.
Then sitting here, very recently, someone
bigger than Pearl, facing the river
facing the boulder where she'd been
sleeping.
Hello!
Pearl yelled, making turtle jump.
If you're spying on us, just come out
already.
Turtle rubbed his ears.
So stealth isn't your strong suit either
I see.
Sorry, Carol said, unrepentantly.
I know it's your only suit.
Whoever you are, just come out and say
whatever you have to say.
There was no response.
The leaves on the trees whispered quietly
as if gossiping about the crazy copper
dragon shouting at nothingness, Pearl
shrugged.
I guess they left.
Maybe they just wanted to catch a glimpse
of a fire monster.
Or maybe they thought I was scarlet, and
then realized who I am and fled in
terror.
That could be it.
Hmm, Turtle said, with just a shade too
much skepticism in his voice.
He twisted around, scanning the trees and
sky and river, but there was no sign of
anybody.
I have a plan for possibility, Perl
said.
Let's go.
She spread her wings and launched herself
into the sky like a burst of flames.
The sun had crept over the mountaintops
spilling in golden stripes down the
canyons and across the hills.
To the west.
Pearl saw a line of camels plodding
across the desert, with smaller shapes on
their backs and around their heels
scavengers perhaps.
Turtle flapped wetly up beside her
splattering her with spray from his tail
and wings.
In the sunlight, his jewel toned scales
looked more like emeralds than ever.
A plan would be good, he said.
Tell me your plan.
Easy.
We'll just dive right into the middle of
the market, and then all those dragons
will start stampeding around yelling
about what a menace I am, and then you
shout, Moon and Kibli, meet us outside
town, and then we fly away again.
Peril nodded with satisfaction.
I think that would work.
Turtle wrinkled a snout at her.
I have a slightly less insane idea, he
said, if you can swim.
I can do anything, Pearl said, tossing
her head.
There was a lake by this waterfall near
the Sky Palace that I swam in once.
I didn't like it though.
It was weird, being surrounded by water.
In a way, it was like flying because she
couldn't exactly burn anything while she
was underwater, but it was also
unsettling.
Dragons shouldn't be underwater.
Fire shouldn't be underwater.
If we swim into the city, no one will
notice you.
Turtles said.
We'll be able to scout it out without
attracting a lot of attention.
I don't care about attention, Perl said.
If a dragon wants to stare at me and hate
me and think horrible thoughts about all
the things they can't do to me, then they
can go right ahead.
She twisted around to glance back at
Turtle.
A movement far below them caught her eye
and she angled one wing to look down.
There was a black dragon, standing on the
boulder where Peril had slept the night
before.
He lowered his snout for a moment
studying the moss she'd burned, and then
lifted his head to scan the sky.
Although he was miles away now, Peril
felt his eyes snag on her scales, like
wickedly sharp fish hooks, he didn't
move.
He didn't come flying after them.
He just stared, eerie and still, watching
her beat more and more distance between
them, getting smaller and smaller.
Whoever he was.
Peril had a feeling he wasn't done with
her yet.
Turtle did a flip in the sky to see what
she was looking at.
He nearly lost the wind under him as he
spotted the dragon.
I was right, he cried.
See?
He's following us.
He's not, Pearl pointed out.
Mostly he's just staring at us.
It's creepy, but to be fair, if he tried
to do that from any closer up, I'd have
to stick something sharp and burning into
his eyeballs.
All right, Turtle said.
Thank you for that visual.
Do you know any night wings?
Starflight, peril answered.
And that other fluff brained one at the
school, but it's too big to be either of
them.
Turtle flicked his tail nervously and
beat his wings faster.
Keeping up with her easily for the 1st
time since they'd left Jade Mountain.
I did hear a rumor.
He started.
A rumor?
Pearl asked.
Or dragons having a conversation you
weren't supposed to overhear.
Nobody said I couldn't stand in the
tunnel outside and listen, Turtle said
defensively.
Anyway, Sonny was telling tsunami that
some Nightwing prisoners had escaped from
Thorn's stronghold.
Maybe it's one of them.
Why would a night wing prisoner be
interested in us?
Pearl asked.
True.
Maybe it's someone working with Scarlet
Turtles said.
Maybe it's her new ally.
Peril swiveled violently around in the
sky.
How did I not think of that?
What if it's a nightwing animus, coming
after me on Scarlet's orders?
Maybe I'm higher on her vengeance list
than I thought.
The Black Dragon was gone.
Wonderful, she said.
You couldn't have mentioned that a bit
sooner?
Now all I can do is worry about it.
I hate worrying about things.
It's almost time for us to swim, Turtle
said cheerfully.
You can worry about that instead.
He canted his wings and swooped down
toward the river.
Uneasily, peril followed him.
Don't think about it.
There's nothing I can do about this night
wing right now anyway.
I have to wait until he shows his face a
bit closer to me.
And then I can burn it off, and then
everything will be fine.
She flexed her talons, feeling the warm
shift of her fire scales, and then
splashed down right behind turtle.
The river was cold, and extremely wet, and
full of flappy slippery things.
Peril did not like it, one bit.
The flappy slippery things.
She assumed most of them were fish, kept
touching her, and then not bursting into
flames, and that was so weird.
Even the feeling of water all around her
scales, pressing in on her was extremely
unsettling.
She was also not particularly fond of how
much faster than her turtle could
suddenly go.
He powered forward in huge wing beats
steering gracefully with a current, while
she flopped around snorting water upper
snout, and generally feeling like a
hippo.
A hippo floated past, eyeing her with
serene scorn.
Fine, not like a hippo, like an ostrich
suddenly plunked in the middle of an
ocean.
How about that?
Far ahead, turtle swerved majestically
around a bend in the river and clambered
onto a submerged boulder to wait for
her.
Peril floundered toward him.
Finally finding pebbles below her talons
and a moment to gasp for breath.
Couldn't we fly a little closer?
She spat.
Not if we want you to arrive incognito.
Turtle pointed to the increasing number
of dragons flying overhead.
The wings flashing in the sky were mostly
red, orange, or sandy yellow.
Although peril spotted shades of brown
and blue up there as well.
Don't worry.
Soon we'll be swimming into possibility.
Hopefully, no one will notice your scales
underwater, and hopefully we'll be able
to spot Moon and Kibli from the river.
He dove back into the river, and peril
had no choice but to follow him.
The outskirts of possibility swept up on
either side of the riverbank.
These were the smaller dwellings of
dragons who'd moved to the city
recently.
Peril swam past a family of sea wings who
splashed in the shallows, blue scales
flickering like broken shards of sky.
The 2 dragonettes yelped and wrestled
while their father watched, smiling in a
way that no one had ever, ever smiled at
peril.
A little farther downstream, on the other
side of the river, 3 mud wings near
Peril's age were planting a garden.
The biggest one pointed to a crooked
furrow, and thwapped one of her siblings
Bossily.
Her brother flung a carrot at her, and
the 3rd sibling giggled until she nearly
fell over.
It wasn't until the mud wings were behind
them that peril realized the littlest
sister had been missing an arm.
She took a closer look at the next set of
dragons they passed and spotted another
war wound, a scar that ran nearly the
length of the sky wing's tail, but this
dragon too was smiling, leaning over to
show a smaller dragon how to fix a broken
door frame.
He must have felt her staring at him
because he turned his head toward the
river, but peril submerged her head and
swam faster, and when she surfaced again
there was an island between them.
More islands began to dot the river as it
widened out and the current slowed
sometimes trailing into wandering streams
or muddling about in clumps of tall
reeds.
Peril and turtle swam under a bridge
packed end to end with merchant stalls
and dragons calling out to customers.
The finest rugs and possibility.
The actual finest rugs and possibility.
Roaster crocodile on sale.
Don't eat that.
His crocodile was riding in the streets
yesterday.
We have seagulls caught in the air this
morning.
The next bridge glowed with bright colors
and shook with thumping talons as dragons
danced along its length.
Peril could feel the music vibrating in
the water around her.
Beaten silver circles hung from the
railings, and under the bridge like giant
coins.
A full moon festival, Turtle said, popping
his head out of the water right next to
her.
It used to be a sand wing tradition, but
they didn't have much time for them
during the war.
I heard they were coming back.
Peril floated under the bridge, watching
the whirling dragons overhead, as they
clapped their wings and twined their
tails together.
She would never dance in a crowd like
that, wearing bangles of silver moons, and
singing until her voice cracked.
She would never paint huge canvases side
by side with other sky wings, and sand
wings, dipping their tails into the same
buckets of moonlit white, and midnight
blue paint, and laughing as it spattered
across their claws and snouts.
She'd been in this town only 4 months ago
searching for scarlet, but something was
different now.
It felt lighter and more open than before
as if the war was starting to melt away
as if their world was starting to feel
safer under thorn and ruby than it ever
had been with burn and scarlet.
But it's not safe.
Not as long as Queen Scarlet is still out
there.
Smoldering with hate.
Moon should be easy to spot here, Turtle
said.
His snout half buried in the water, so
his voice rose through bubbles.
Not a lot of night wings around.
No night wings at all that peril could
see.
She wondered if they knew about this
place, and whether any of them would
eventually choose to come here.
It wouldn't suit their tribal air of
mystery, mingling with so many other
dragons like this.
But on the other talent, it might give
them more self-respect than living under
a rain wing queen's claws.
She'd never been to the rainforest
herself.
Clay had strongly discouraged the idea
saying something about how many trees
there were and forest fires and blah, blah
blah, but that was fine.
Peril was sure she wouldn't like feeling
so hemmed in anyway.
It sounded claustrophobic.
Plus, full of dragons who could sneak up
on you with like, invisibility scales.
That sounded absolutely creepy.
Not to mention that Queen Glory was far
from peril's biggest fan.
The drums and zithers of the full moon
festival were starting to fade behind
them, and peril could see glimmers of the
open bay ahead in the distance.
This part of possibility seemed to have
older, bigger, sturdier buildings set
around open, cobblestoned plazas.
The palm trees looked more deliberately
spaced, casting strategic patches of
shade, bright yellow trumpet shaped
flowers swarmed along dark green vines
that seemed to be tangled everywhere.
Wait, Turtle said, turning so suddenly
that he splashed water up Peril's nose
she backpedaled against the current
scowling at him.
What?
she said.
Can we give up now?
We could just fly over the town.
It'll be easier to spot a black dragon
from up there anyhow.
It's not like anyone is going to come up
and try to fight me.
I thought I saw Kibley, Turtle said.
He spread his wings to float in a circle
and craned his neck, peering at the
dragons along the waterfront.
Those sand wings over there, arguing with
the red sky wing.
Doesn't one of them look like Kibley?
Pearl realized that she didn't have the
faintest idea what Kibley looked like.
Had she ever met him before?
All sand wings looked pretty much the
same to her.
Apart from Sonny, of course, who had
oddly colored scales and a perpetually
cheerful expression that was just asking
to be clawed off.
Uh, sure?
Let's go see.
Turtle charged out of the river before
peril could argue.
His emerald green tail left a slick wet
path on the cobblestones behind him.
She scanned the nearby dragons, but they
were all focused on their own business.
No one was watching the river.
And now she could see the dragon's turtle
was aiming for.
The red sky wings stood with his wings
folded back, and his head cocked
arrogantly at the 2 burly sand wings in
front of him, one of whom was lashing her
menacing tail.
Both sand wings were wearing medallions
around their necks, stamped with the
image of a large bird.
Arranged on the stones around their
talons, were several odd looking, brownish
greenish pink spheres, studded with
little spikes.
Pearl slithered out of the water and
hurried after turtle, keeping her head
low, and her wings tucked in close.
You said 30, she heard the bigger sand
wing yell.
That was the agreement.
You are welcome to come to the mountains
and try harvesting these yourself, spat
the sky wing.
It is much more difficult than your
paltry pouch of gold would cover.
Let's just take them.
The male Sandwing growled.
He won't be pleased, and you know it.
His partner snapped.
Turtle paused several feet away from them
and turned back to peril, shaking his
head.
Not Kibley.
She stopped too, in the most empty patch
of stone she could find.
From here, the plaza became cluttered
with wares spread on carpets, flowers
growing out of window boxes, and dragons
blithely trampling around everywhere
without worrying at all about whose
scales they might blunder into.
Danger tingled just beyond peril's
reach.
She could sense all the terrible things
that might happen if she stepped any
farther into the town.
She needed to get back to the river, where
she wouldn't be such a threat.
She glanced around and began to
cautiously turn, keeping her tail curled
safely in.
And then, one of the sand wings muttered
something furious and kicked one of the
spheres.
Oh, it's a cactus, Peril realized
spotting the roots as it bounced across
the stones toward her.
I've seen those in the mountains, I
think.
She glanced up.
And the last thing peril saw was turtle's
green eyes widening, as the sphere rolled
up to her talons, brushed against her
scales, and exploded in an enormous
fireball.
Chapter 8.
Peril came too, because her body decided
not to drown.
She surged up out of the water, where the
explosion had thrown her, coughing and
sputtering, into a cloud of thick black
smoke that was not particularly fun to
breathe either.
Her eyes were stinging, and everything
was blurry and muffled.
But she could see there were dragons
yelling and screaming all along the bank
and more flapping in from the rooftops.
At least 3 dragons were rolling in the
river with scorch marks on their scales.
Small fires flickered in the smoke all
across the courtyard.
She wasn't burned.
Her scales couldn't burn, but there were
incredibly sharp blossoms of pain spiking
all up and down her body.
What was this?
Why did it hurt so much?
Who could she set on fire to make it
stop?
She roared her agony as loud as she could
but it made barely a scratch in the
jangling chaos all around.
A dragon suddenly came galloping into the
river beside her, and she jumped back
hissing at him before she recognized
Turtle.
You, he said, shaking his head, are
without question, the least stealthy
dragon in all of Pyria.
That wasn't my fault, she snarled
writhing in pain.
Nothing had ever managed to hurt her like
this.
There were tiny teeth eating under her
scales.
Everything hurts, and I hate the world.
Let's find a safer place to be before
someone sees you and connects the dots
Turtle said.
She realized that trickles of blood were
running down his shoulders and along his
tail.
He waded into the water until it covered
everything but his head and began
swimming upstream, back toward the full
moon festival bridge.
It was agony to move, but she did
flailing after him, and hoping the smoke
would hide her shining copper scales.
Turtle finally coasted to a stop in
clearer air on the muddy bank of one of
the small islands, not far from where the
festival music was still going on, he
pulled himself half onto the shore
wincing, and peril crawled up into the
mud as far away from him as she could.
The reeds and shrubs below her curled
into a dark scorched mess, but she was in
too much pain to worry about it.
She wondered if this was what being on
fire felt like to other dragons.
Why?
she growled.
What is happening?
It was a dragon flame cactus, Turtle
said.
He twisted and started to pry at
something stuck under his left wing in a
small pool of blood.
Like the one that exploded in the history
cave at school.
I have no idea why anyone would want to
buy one now that the war is over.
They didn't want to buy just one, peril
remembered.
They wanted to buy 30.
Whatever their reason was, she thought
perhaps burning out their eyeballs would
make her feel better.
Turtle extracted the object from his
scales and held it out for her to see.
It's like a little ball of thorns, he
said.
The dragon flame cactus seed pod.
You have about 100 of them stuck all over
you, since it exploded right at your feet
but I don't know what to do.
I can't pull them out of your scales
without getting burned, but we can't
leave them.
Oh.
He trailed off, staring at her.
What?
Carol demanded.
She was starting to feel a little better
maybe, now that she was out of the
water.
They're burning up, Turtle explained.
Your scales are burning the seed pods
away.
Peril held out one front leg and saw a
ball of thorns embedded between our claws
right before it caught fire and shriveled
into black ash.
That's right, she said.
Die, you little monster plants.
May your roots always be thirsty, and
your seeds all meet a fiery death until
you're extinct forever.
I hate you.
Yow.
Turtle said.
You don't ever have mild feelings, do
you?
Peril wasn't sure what a mild feeling
would feel like.
She turned to blink downriver at the
pillar of black smoke rising from the
distant courtyard.
Was, um, did you see if the explosion, uh
peril trailed off?
I don't think anyone was killed, Turtle
said.
It looked like your body blocked the
worst of the fire and caught most of the
seed pods.
I saw other dragons injured, but nobody
liked nobody liked carnelian.
Peril finished.
She tried to hide the relief in her
voice.
Although Clay would forgive her for an
accident, surely, even if someone had
died.
It wouldn't really be her fault, except
in the sense that everything was her
fault because she was a walking menace to
the entire universe.
Anyway, peril said indignantly.
What kind of idiot spreads a bunch of
flammable cacti all over the street?
Anyone could have set one of those off by
accident.
Not a sea wing, Turtle said
thoughtfully.
Or an ice wing?
Oh, hey, now we know one more thing that
can't kill you.
They shouldn't be allowed to sell things
like that to just anyone.
Pearl went on, ignoring him.
She twitched her tail around to check for
any more thorns, but they all seem to be
gone.
Would they sell a sword to any dragon who
came along?
Um, Turtle said.
Yes.
His smile fell off his face as he winced
again.
Another ball of thorns was dripping blood
down his tail, but he couldn't twist far
enough to reach it.
I could set it on fire, Pearl offered
spreading her claws, but it might burn
you a little bit.
I don't know if that would be worse.
Turtle thought for a moment, then
shuffled a step toward her.
Yes, do it.
If I jump straight into the river after.
I'll be fine.
Peril hadn't actually expected him to say
yes.
Nobody ever let her help with anything.
Even Clay usually got sort of flappy and
nervous whenever she offered.
She folded her wings back and reached
forward tentatively with one claw.
Turtle closed his eyes, frozen in place.
Peril's claw lightly brushed the thorny
seed pod, and it burst into flames.
Immediately, she saw a dark scorched
patch start to spread where the thorns
touched turtle's scales, but she only
caught a glimpse of it before turtle dove
into the water and swam to the bottom.
She paced along the bank, trying to
squint at him through the shifting
reflections.
He was a huddled green lump at the bottom
of the river for way too long.
It made her own lungs ache to wait for
him, but he was clearly fine, definitely
moving, and fiddling with something that
flashed white gray.
Weird.
Finally, he surfaced, spraying water out
of his nose and looking extremely pleased
with himself.
Parel's eyes went straight to the spot
where she'd burned him.
But there was no scorch mark there
anymore.
His scales looked whole and unblemished
all over, as if neither fire nor thorns
had ever wounded him.
She couldn't even figure out where the
seed pods had been.
How did you do that?
she demanded.
Water doesn't heal sea wings that
quickly.
It wasn't that bad, Turtle said with a
shrug.
I'm fine.
Don't worry.
I'm not worried.
I'm deeply suspicious. peril clarified.
That's not normal scale behavior right
there.
Turtle?
They both jumped at the voice that came
from the sky.
Peril realized she'd been watching
turtles so closely.
She hadn't kept an eye out for
approaching danger, or anyone who might
realize she'd set off the cactus.
Genius peril.
If there is an animus night wing stalking
you, you're making it pretty easy for
him.
But the dragon above them was a sandwing
and Turtle gave a cry of delight when he
saw him.
Kibli!
Turtle leaped into the air and nearly
bowled him out of the sky.
They swooped around each other for a
moment, doing cheerful flips in the air
and thumping one another's wings, which
appeared to be some kind of code for
happy to see you.
A moment later, a small night wing came
soaring over from the direction of the
explosion, and Turtle made more dopey
delighted noises at her.
I guess we found his friends.
Carol flicked her tail and accidentally
splashed herself in the face.
Probably thanks to me, by the way.
I bet they came to check out the fire.
I wonder if Turtle will realize that.
She stood up and paced in a circle in the
mud.
All the places she'd been stabbed with
thorns still hurt, but at least the seed
pods were gone.
Maybe she should fly away before Turtle
came down with his judgmental friends.
Maybe she didn't need anyone else to look
for Scarlet anyhow.
But it was too late.
Green and black and yellow wings were
descending toward the island, along with
3 dragon faces that ranged from friendly
through wary, and straight on to hostel.
Which is fine, Peril thought, meeting
Kibley's eyes with all the fires she
could put into hers.
I am prepared to dislike you too.
Who cares what you think?
Are you the most dangerous dragon in
Pyrea?
No, I think not.
Peril, this is Moon and Cubli, said
Turtle, beaming all over his stupid round
face, as if this should be the most
delightful thing that had ever happened
to any of them.
She couldn't remember noticing either of
these dragons before.
They looked completely ordinary, not like
anyone worth crossing an entire continent
to find, not like dragons who are so much
more awesome to be friends with than
her.
The night wing had a glittering silver
scale at the corners of each eye, like
teardrops, and little furrows in her
forehead as though she had a perpetual
headache.
Now that everyone knew Nightwings didn't
have powers after all, Peril was sure
Moon would be an easy opponent to take
down in the arena.
Hypothetically, if there still had been
an arena, of course.
The sand wing didn't look like much of a
threat either, apart from that venomous
tale.
Peril had been in plenty of fights where
her 1st move was grabbing a sand wings
tail to burn off the barb at the end.
As long as Scarlet didn't need her to
drag out the fight, most sand wings only
took a few minutes to defeat.
No doubt this one was pretty dim and
correspondingly slow.
You're wrong about that, Moon said.
Peril shifted her gaze to the black
dragon, who was studying peril intently.
What?
Pearl asked.
Kibley is probably one of the smartest
dragons Empirea, Moon answered.
I bet he's already figured out 5
different ways to defeat you right here
if you needed to.
Kibli cocked his head, and gave Moon a
delighted sideways smile.
Only 3 so far, he said.
But thanks.
Peril blinked at moon, feeling like
little dragon flame cacti were going off
inside her head.
Did you?
But, Yes, Moon said.
I'm a mind reader, so you should probably
stop thinking about how exactly you would
kill us if you needed to.
Was she really?
Turtle said. sounding perfectly
astonished, as if that wasn't the 1st
thing most dragons thought about when
they met dragons outside their own
tribes.
Wasn't it?
Peril whipped her head around to glare at
Turtle.
You brought me to meet a mind reader, she
said, and you didn't think that might be
worth mentioning sometime before now?
Was this a test?
Maybe this was his plan all along.
Maybe he never trusted me, like Scarlet
never trusted me, and he wanted to see
what moon would find in my head.
Turtle shrugged.
It's Moon's secret.
It's up to her who she tells.
I'm not entirely sure why Scarlet's
dancing monkey of fiery doom gets to be
on that list, frankly, said Kibley.
And remind me?
Your thorns dancing monkey of what
exactly?
Peril demanded.
At least I was useful to my queen.
I told her, Moon interjected, opening one
wing pointedly between them before Kibley
could lunge at peril.
Because it's the right thing to do.
And because there's no way to give her
any skyfire.
And also because I am hoping that if she
knows I'm listening, she'll try to have
less disturbing thoughts.
That sounded complicated.
Peril wrinkled or snout.
How am I supposed to change my thoughts?
They just appear in my head.
I've never had to worry about them
disturbing anyone before.
Maybe you should stop listening instead
peril said.
Moon shook her head.
It doesn't work that way, but don't worry
about it too much.
Your thoughts are actually really hard to
hear.
Mostly all I get from your mind is heat
and flames and she broke off, twitching
her wings back awkwardly for a moment.
Anyway, it's not as clear as most minds.
You're mostly safe from me.
Tremendously comforting, Peril said.
She tried to fill up her head with more
fire, hoping to burn out anything she
didn't want Moon to see, although really
that was either everything or nothing.
Whenever Moon already thought of her, from
whatever scraps of thoughts she'd heard
none of the rest would make any
difference.
Either she could stand all of peril just
the way she was, or she'd hate her for a
small piece of her as much as for all the
rest of it.
Now she was giving herself a headache.
Is Kinkajou all right?
Turtle asked, where is she?
And you're a hostile ice dragon?
Peril added.
Winter has gone back to the ice kingdom
Moon said.
She glanced at Kibley.
Kibley thinks he's coming back, but I'm
not so sure.
Kinkachu is, well, she's recovering, we
think, but she still hasn't woken up.
She blinked several times rapidly.
She would be so excited to see you here
she said to Turtle, with a sad smile.
We were attacked by a dragon who's
working with Scarlett, Kibley said.
He squinted at peril, then turned to
Moon.
What did she think about that?
Can you tell if she's working for Scarlet
too?
No, I don't think she is, said Moon.
But now she's gone back to fantasizing
about ways to kill you.
Because that was rude. peril flared
poking around inside my brain to find the
answer to a question I've already
answered over and over.
You can go stuff a mountain goat up your
nose, Sandwing, horns first.
I'm looking for Scarlet to stop her, not
help her.
Why are there so many stupid dragons who
can't see that?
Well, Kibley said.
You did help her escape from Burns
stronghold not that long ago.
That, peril sputtered.
That was just that, that Byrne was the
bad guy then.
I couldn't leave my queen trapped in that
place.
Nobody would.
Your queen?
Kibley challenged.
Isn't Ruby your queen now?
Parel drew herself up, glaring at him
knowing that Moon must be hearing all her
fears about Ruby scattering about inside
her head.
I don't have to explain myself to you
sand snorter.
We are only here to find out what you
know about where Scarlet is.
She turned her fierce gaze on Moon. and
the night wings lynched.
Then I'll take my disturbing thoughts
right out of your life forever is the
plan.
It's true.
We have to find her.
Turtle explained.
She attacked Jade Academy.
Moon blinked, and Kibley's tail arched
reflexively.
His talons digging into the mud.
She did not, Peril said, rolling her eyes
at him.
She flew by, threw a decapitated head at
us and flew away again.
That wasn't an attack.
That was more like a declaration of war.
If she ever decides to really attack you
you'll know.
A decapitated head?
Moon echoed with alarm?
Sonny said Scarlet was there making
threats, but she didn't mention a head.
Was it our fault?
Kimberly asked immediately.
She must be furious about us escaping
with Hillstorm.
What if we enraged her into coming out of
hiding?
That seems extremely likely, Peril said.
I imagine just meeting you would enrage
Queen Scarlet to the point of wanting to
kill several dragons.
Ha ha, Turtle said, as though peril were
kidding, which she clearly was not.
So where did you encounter Scarlet?
In a part of the mountains not far from
here, Moon said.
But I'm sure she wouldn't still be
there.
I don't see how we can help you.
The only way we found her before was
because she was using the dream visitor
and left clues.
Pearl hated that dream visitor.
Scarlett showed up in her dreams all the
time, and half the time, peril wasn't
even sure if she was real.
Whether she was or not.
There was always yelling and guilt and
ominous remarks about Clay's future.
I knew they wouldn't be helpful.
She said to Turtle.
Well, Turtle said uncertainly, maybe if
you show us on a map where she was.
We can at least start searching from
there.
Kibley looked up at the sky, where the
sun was meandering toward the midpoint.
Sure, but right now we should get back to
the clinic.
The dragons from glory are supposed to
arrive soon.
Carol wondered if he was changing the
subject because he didn't trust her.
Consider the feeling mutual sandwing, she
thought, eyeing him narrowly.
The clinic?
Where Kikachu is?
Turtle's face brightened hopefully, then
fell as he turned toward peril, but peril
can't go into the city.
She spread her gold veined wings to
indicate, remember?
Deadly fire scales over here?
But she accidentally hit a branch
overhead, which burst into flames.
Kibli promptly smacked his tail in the
river, sending up a wave that cascaded
over the branch and peril, soaking her
and putting the fire out.
Peril regarded him coldly, water dripping
from her snout.
Don't feel bad, Moon said to Turtle.
Kinkaju wouldn't know you were there
anyway.
Turtles' wings drooped.
And peril had a sudden, very strong
feeling that there was a right thing to
say here.
It was written in the slump of his
shoulders, and the way he poked one claw
gloomily at the mud puddle beside him.
Something reassuring about Kinkachu?
No?
Something else.
Something she didn't want to say, but she
saw that she kind of had to, and the
others were even leaving an odd moment of
quiet in the conversation, waiting for
her to say it.
You should go, she said, forcing it out
past the growl in her throat.
I'll just wait for you out here
somewhere.
Really?
Turtles said with an enormous smile.
You don't mind?
We'll be back soon.
I bet.
After you've all talked in secret about
me and what you're going to do next and
whether to fly off without me.
Sure, Peril said, then wondered if that
sounded sarcastic and tried again.
Sure.
Okay, that one sounded worse.
I mean yes, fine.
I want to go hunt in the desert anyway.
There's a big sandstone arch west of the
city, set up high so you can see
practically the whole kingdom of sand
Moon said.
That's where Kibli and I have been going
to wait for winter.
Whenever we're not with Kinkaju or in the
library.
Let's meet back there.
Winter still has 2 more days, Kibley said
quietly.
We told him we'd wait a week.
He's not coming, Moon said.
I've seen inside his mind, Kibley.
He's so loyal to his family and his
tribe.
I don't think anything will change that.
Kibley made a face that peril couldn't
figure out.
Moon, sometimes you're so busy listening
to what dragons are thinking, you miss
the things they're actually doing, which
can tell you a lot more about what
they're really like.
That makes no sense.
She said.
Should I bring Kinkaju something?
Turtle said, hopping from one foot to the
other in a very unturtle like way.
Peril had never seen him expand even an
iota more energy than necessary for
whatever he was doing.
Flowers?
A fish?
No, she doesn't like fish.
Um, kumquat?
He likes moon and kibli, peril guest, but
he's really here for kinkachu.
Why did he even want to travel with me in
the 1st place?
He could have come here without me.
Did he think I'd be useful protection
along the way?
He didn't need to pretend to be friends
with me.
Boring green puddle dragon.
Humph.
Peril caught Moon's eyes on her, and
didn't like whatever mysterious emotion
was going on in them.
Sympathy, pity, bewilderment?
Whatever she was getting from peril's
brain, Kibley was right.
It didn't mean Moon knew anything about
her, really.
Peril sat down and started examining her
claws as if she found all these dragons
exceedingly boring.
This was another trick she'd learned from
watching Scarlet.
Although she had a feeling she wasn't
conveying quite the right amount of
disdain in the tilt of her wings.
You don't need anything, Kibley said to
Turtle.
Just having you there would be enough for
her.
Maybe she'll be able to hear your voice.
See you soon, Pearl, Turtle said
enthusiastically.
Yeah, maybe, Peril said to the empty air
drowned out by the flapping of their
wings as all 3 of them took off and
headed into the city.
She waited a minute, to be sure they
wouldn't turn around, and then she lifted
her head to watch the glowing green shape
of her supposed friend flying away from
her.
Chapter 9.
Peril didn't quite realize that she was
still in pain from the thorn balls until
she was up in the air again, flying with
muscles that protested with tiny sparks
of agony.
She gritted her teeth, determined to
ignore it until it went away.
She spent the rest of the morning flying
out into the desert, chasing down a
desert fox, who escaped into a hole and
was kind of too cute to eat anyway, and
then catching a large white bird in
midair and eating that instead.
She also set fire to a tall cactus
because it was giving her a superior look
and she felt like it.
One advantage of a desert.
She didn't have to worry about forest
fires, or accidentally scorching a field
of sky wing crops, or whatever other
reasons the queen had always had for
keeping her in the palace.
The queen.
I do still think of her that way.
Kibli's words kept going around in her
head, which was very annoying and made
the next cactus over look like tempting
kindling as well.
Isn't Ruby your queen now?
Well, yes, technically.
But how could you swear loyalty to a
queen who didn't even want you in her
kingdom?
How could anyone feel loyal to a queen
who clearly just wanted you dead?
Peril swerved to fly back toward
possibility and saw a huddle of camels a
short ways off to the south?
Maybe a camel would make her feel
better.
But as she came closer, she saw that the
camels were tied to a palm tree, and
surrounded by bustling scavengers, at
least 10 of them, setting up tents and
scooping water from a small oasis pond.
They all went gratifyingly still when she
shot overhead.
She studied their upturned faces, which
looked like they were mostly eyes
terrified eyes.
She'd never seen such dopey prey.
What were they doing out in the open
desert, where it would be so easy to
catch and eat them?
She'd never eaten a scavenger before.
Queen Scarlet always saved them, either
to fight in the arena, or be served at
special banquets, which peril was never
invited to, because blah, blah, setting
the guests on fire would be unhospitable
blah, blah.
She circled around again, trying to
decide how hungry she was.
As she did, she spotted one scavenger
sitting apart from the others, a little
ways up the nearest dune.
This one wasn't looking up at peril.
Its shoulders were slumped, and its head
was buried in its little brown arms, so
all peril could see was a thicket of dark
fur on top of its head, a sand colored
cloth wrapped around it, and 2 little
brown feet sticking out.
It looked sad.
That's hilarious, Pearl thought.
Do camels get sad?
Do mountain goats mope?
Does a hawk ever have a day where it
feels like none of the other hawks want
to be friends with it?
Maybe I should burn up the other
scavengers and see if that makes this one
feel better.
She thought about it for a moment, but
there was something about the curve of
the scavenger's back that was almost too
achingly familiar, and in the end, peril
turned around and flew away, leaving the
scavengers and camels to deal with their
own problems.
The sandstone arch was easy to find.
High on a butte to the west of
possibility, looping out of the ground
and back into it, in a shape like a rain
wing tail, Peril flew through the hole of
the archway, feeling her wing tips brush
the stone on either side, and then
spiraled around to land on top of it, the
desert spread out before her.
Vast and endless in the hot afternoon
sun.
When she turned around, she could see the
whole town of possibility.
The taller structures clustered around
the river delta, and the trail of smaller
ones leading away along the river.
From here, the dragons winding through
the streets looked no bigger than
scavengers, and sometimes it was even
hard to tell what color their scales
were.
Beyond possibility, across the eastern
horizon, cut the jagged tooth shapes of
the claws of the clouds mountains.
Scarlet was in there somewhere.
Peril was sure of it.
The queen wasn't the kind of dragon to
let herself be uncomfortable somewhere
weird, like the rainforest or the mud
swamps.
She knew the sky kingdom perhaps better
than anyone, and she must have found
somewhere she didn't mind hiding.
A flicker of movement caught Peril's eye
and she swiveled her head to see a dragon
winging his way toward her from the edge
of possibility.
He was a big golden orange sky wing.
Not anyone she recognized, although it
did seem as though he was flying directly
toward her.
Maybe he recognized me from all the way
down there.
Maybe he's coming to yell at me about how
I should leave his precious flammable
town alone.
Is he the one with a basket of snails
from last time?
Or perhaps I flambayed one of his
relatives and he's still grumpy about
it.
She flexed her talons.
Well, if he'd like a fight?
I am certainly in the mood for it.
Clay flashed into her head, wearing his
disappointed face, which was frustrating
because it both made her miss him, and
also made her want to yell at him, that
she hadn't killed anybody, yet, and
couldn't he appreciate that instead of
anticipating her next bad thing?
And then she felt silly, because she was
busy getting mad at him for an imaginary
conversation, when really, she just
wished he was there to nudge her wings
and tell her what to do next.
The Sky Wing was definitely aiming for
the arch and looking at her.
But when he was only a few wing beats
away, he suddenly jerked back, with an
expression peril had seen many times
before, that wonderful fear slash hatred
combination that just the sight of her
face seemed to magically induce.
Except this time, it wasn't for her.
He wasn't looking at her anymore.
He was looking beyond her.
And whatever he saw made him wheel around
abruptly and hightail it back to
possibility as fast as he could fly.
Peril turned and scanned the desert sky.
Two more dragons were flying her way.
This time, it was an ice wing and a big
night wing coming from the northwest.
Another night wing?
Out here?
Could it be one of the ones who escaped
from Thorn's prison?
Or Scarlet's ally?
The sunlight sparked and danced across
the ice wings silver scales, like a 100
little moons on fire.
Peril curled her tail around her talons
and watched him with narrow eyes.
She vaguely remembered the ice wings
who'd yelled at her in the big entrance
hall at Jade Academy, but she doubted
she'd be able to pick Winter or his
sister out from a crowd of white
dragons.
Keeping faces in her head, wasn't a
particular skill of hers.
She always forgot to concentrate on
storing their features, usually because
she was sizing them up as a potential
combatant instead.
Mostly, she'd never had to remember the
dragons she met anyway, since she'd
killed almost all the ones who got close
enough to be faces in the 1st place.
She definitely saw the moment when the
ice dragon recognized her, though.
He immediately altered his flight path to
hurdle in her direction, and his face
wasn't exactly throwing her an
enthusiastic full moon festival.
What are you doing here?
He yelled down apparel, circling over her
head.
The Nightwing stayed back, beating her
wings to hover in place.
What do you care?
Pearl shouted.
It made her instantly grumpy to see how
he stayed up in the air, forcing her to
look up at him as he flew around and
around.
That was basic dragon etiquette that even
peril knew.
If you want to talk to someone on the
ground, you land and look them in the
eye.
Did Scarlet send you?
He called.
Did she send you?
she snapped back.
Last I heard, it was your sister who was
working for her, not me.
That went in, sharp as a sandwing barb.
Winter flinched and frowned even harder.
I'm not going to let you herd my friends
if that's what you're here for.
That's funny.
Pearl said.
I mean, the part where you think you
could stop me.
Even as she said it, she knew Clay would
think it was exactly the wrong thing to
say.
She knew she was provoking the ice wing
on purpose, because she was already
having a bad day, and he was making it
worse, and she knew she should stop and
explain everything, and tell him where
his friends were, but by all the moons.
If he couldn't even handle landing to
have a civil conversation, then why
should she do all the work of keeping
things polite?
Seriously.
Still, she could probably have guessed
what would happen next.
Winter whirled with a roar and shot a
blast of frost breath at one of her
wings.
As she'd learned over many arena battles
with ice wings, this did essentially
nothing, except make the spot feel numb
for a few minutes, while her fire scales
combated the ice.
But it was still rude, and she didn't
like it.
She flung herself into the air and
blasted fire right back at him.
Clay's voice in her head, made her aim to
his left so she wouldn't actually hurt
him, but surely it was all right to scare
him a little bit.
He shot out of the way, no doubt
congratulating himself on moving so
quickly, rather than realizing she'd
deliberately spared him.
With a deft flip of his tail, the ice
wing dodged below her, and then swung up
suddenly to frost breath her back legs
before looping away again.
That doesn't do anything to me, you one
trick dragon, she cried.
How about some claw to claw combat?
Or are you too much of a coward for
that?
Whether or not he was a coward, he was
fast.
He swept around her in dizzying spirals
flashing headaches straight into her
skull with every sun reflecting spin.
She lashed out with her front claws, half
sure she wouldn't catch him, and half
starting not to care if she did, because
this dragon was seriously asking for it.
Fighting in the air was hard.
How did dragons focus on staying aloft
and attacking, and defending all at the
same time?
She'd never practiced against an opponent
in the sky.
Her wings felt all clumsy and in the
way.
Why didn't Scarlet let me learn to fight
properly?
If this is how dragons normally do it?
Why did she only pit me against prisoners
with their wings bound?
For the 1st time in her life?
Peril began to wonder, if maybe she
wasn't actually the most dangerous dragon
in Pyria.
But I am, I am.
I just have to touch him and he's dead.
Wait.
That would be bad.
That would be very, very bad.
Peril suddenly remembered.
This was one of Clay's Jade Mountain
students.
He was Turtle's friend.
Even though he technically attacked her
first.
She still knew how much trouble she'd be
in if she hurt him.
Stop, she yelled.
Don't make me kill you.
Nope, that wasn't the right thing to say
either.
She tucked in her wings abruptly and dove
toward the arch, trying to put a safe
distance between her and Winter.
But at that exact moment, he did another
flip to swoop below her again, and the 2
dragons collided in midair.
Fire and ice, copper and silver.
Winter, and certain death.
Chapter 10.
At first, all peril felt was cold limbs
cold scales, cold wings slamming into
hers.
The shock knocked the breath out of her
for a moment, and they tangled in
startled free fall.
And then winter started screaming, and
Pearl shoved him away, and he plummeted
toward the ground with smoke already
rising from his scales, falling as hard
and fast as Pearl's heart. 3 moons.
What have I done?
Oh my, said the night wing in the air
above them.
Peril had forgotten about her.
Fire scales.
I haven't seen that in a long time.
Get help.
Peril yelled.
She plunged after Winter, who missed the
arch and tumbled to the hard rock below
it.
At the last minute, he managed to spread
his wings, so it wasn't a crash landing
but as he did, peril saw the ropes of
black burns smeared across them, he was
burning, burning up everywhere she'd
accidentally touched him.
He landed heavily and collapsed, writhing
in pain.
I'm sorry, peril cried. landing beside
him.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I was trying to get away.
I didn't mean to burn you.
I really didn't.
I'm here to help your friends stop
Scarlet.
Stop dying and listen to me.
He's going to die.
Winter is going to die, and Clay is never
going to speak to me again.
I'm going to be alone forever.
She took a hopeless step toward him, but
there was nothing she could do.
Touching him would only make it worse.
Not that it could get worse, except he'd
die faster, and maybe that would be a
mercy.
Look at him.
I am as bad as everyone thinks I am.
I'm the one who did this, me and my
monstrous claws.
Peril had never cried.
She wasn't sure if she could.
But she had felt vast emptiness like this
before.
Opening up inside her, when Osprey died.
When she had to leave clay the 1st time
when she found out her mother was dead.
And worst of all, when she saw the dragon
bite viper sink its fangs into Clay's leg
and she thought he would die, and she
would lose him, and the world would not
be worth living in anymore.
This emptiness, though, had freezing wind
shrieking through the darkness, shrieking
this is your fault, your fault, your
fault.
You deserve to be the most hated dragon
empirea.
Your fault, your fault.
Moon, Winter gasped.
Tell...
Moon.
He closed his eyes, folding into
himself.
Winter.
A voice shouted from the sky.
Winter?
Of course they were here.
Just in time to see what peril had done
to witness her monstrosity.
She jumped back out of the way as Moon
Kibley, and Turtle thudded down and
surged into a crowd around winter.
Winter, moon cried again, grabbing his
front talons in hers.
Oh, no, oh, no, oh, no.
It was an accident, peril said.
I didn't mean to burn him.
I didn't.
What are our options?
Kibley said frantically.
I know.
Winter frost breath your scales.
That should numb the injuries long enough
to get him to the river.
Isn't there a cactus sat that heals
burns?
Winter.
Come on, don't pass out.
We can fix this.
The silver dragon lay limply on the rocks
in front of them, shuddering in agony.
He didn't respond to either Moon or
Kibley.
Peril couldn't bear to look at him at the
black scorch marks imprinted all over his
snow white scales.
That had to be too many burns to
survive.
He was probably going into shock if he
hadn't already.
She couldn't look at turtle either.
He was clutching his head and pacing
around Winter's tail, and she knew if she
met his eyes, she'd see how much he must
hate her now.
What can we do?
Kibley asked Moon.
And when she didn't answer because she
was crying too hard, he whirled on
peril.
What can we do?
I don't know, peril cried.
I'm the problem, not the solution.
Use this, Turtle said.
Scrabbling in the pouch around his neck.
His voice sounded weird, like it was
being mangled as it came out of his
throat, and his expression was closer to
terror than anger, now that peril could
see it.
He yanked the grayish white river rock
from the pouch and held it out.
Nothing could have looked more ordinary
or useless.
What?
Kimley said, blinking back tears.
A rock isn't going to, peril started, but
she trailed off as Turtle pushed Kibli
aside and placed the rock on top of one
of Winter's burns.
Winter let out a yelp of pain at the
sudden contact, and Moon reached toward
Turtle's talons, then stopped.
Below the rock, the burn looked as if it
was evaporating.
The blackness disappeared, and the scales
smoothed over, silver and untouched
again.
Turtle moved the rock, sliding it gently
over the burns all along winter's torso
and wings.
It looked as though he was sweeping snow
along behind it.
Every injury disappeared.
Every wound knitted itself back together
and vanished.
The ice wing's breathing became slower
and less ragged.
He opened his eyes, and watched the
progress of the rock, his face a mask of
confusion and awe.
Within a few moments.
Winter was completely healed.
Everyone stared at Turtle, who very much
looked as though he wanted a deep ocean
chasm to hide in, he stepped back
awkwardly twisting the rock in his talons
as though it was a strange growth that
had just appeared.
Did I get all of it?
he asked.
What?
Moon said.
She shook her head and crouched beside
Winter, gently running one talon over a
patch of smooth scales on his torso.
Turtle.
What?
Her voice faded away, swallowed by the
disbelief swooping across her face, Winter
sat up, holding out his talons with an
awed expression, his wings cautiously
expanded to their full width, then closed
again.
The burns were really gone.
Turtle.
Kibley said carefully.
Why do you have a magic healing rock?
No wait.
How do you have a magic healing rock?
Peril couldn't put our thoughts in
order?
She couldn't wrap her brain around winter
surviving what she'd done.
She couldn't even feel relieved yet.
It was too immense and strange and
impossible.
There wasn't any room in her head for all
her new questions about turtle.
She pulled her wings in as close as
possible, watching Winter's perfectly
unharmed scales shift and half expecting
him to suddenly collapse into a pile of
ashes anyway.
It's an animus touched object, Moon said
to Turtle.
Where did you get?
Oh.
Her eyes suddenly went as wide as the
moons she was named after.
Kibley got it a 2nd later.
You didn't find it somewhere, he said
sounding awestruck.
You made it.
You're an animus dragon.
That's your secret, Moon breathed.
She had an expression like someone who'd
just managed to finally alphabetize a
1000000 scrolls exactly right.
An animus.
That's why he thinks he can handle Queen
Scarlet, Pearl realized.
Turtle said, shivering his wings.
I've never heard anyone say that out loud
before.
Nobody else knows.
Actually, can we not talk about it?
It's really not a big deal.
Not, uh, Winter suddenly chimed in, then
cut himself off with a growl lashing his
tail.
You could have told me, Pearl said to
Turtle.
Wasn't that what friends did?
He hadn't told her about Moon's power
because it was her secret, but he could
have told her this.
I was thinking about it, Turtle said to
Parel.
I mean, so we're not so different, you
and I, right?
Well, I never had the option of hiding my
gift, peril thought.
That's a pretty big difference.
Would anyone else like to make a dramatic
confession?
Kibley asked.
Who else is hiding magic powers?
Winter, anything we should know?
A secret ice wing ability to kill dragons
with a sneer?
No.
Trust me.
I'm nothing special.
Winter growled.
Same here.
Kibley glanced around at Moon, Peril, and
Turtle.
At least, that makes 2 of us.
When did you make this rock?
Moon asked Turtle.
Are you all right?
How much have you used your power so
far?
She rubbed her forehead, her wings
flickering like moths around a candle.
Don't worry, my soul is fine, Turtle said
waving at the air.
I have an enchanted very many things.
I mean, I didn't want anyone to notice I
can do this, obviously.
But why?
Winter exploded.
Why would you hide your power?
You could have served your tribe during
the war.
Your queen needed you.
You could have won the war easily with a
gift like that.
Well, Turtles said, shying away from
him.
Um, exactly.
Wait, so it would be all right with you
Pearl said suddenly to Winter, for his
queen to use him as a weapon, but it was
the most unforgivable crime in history
for my queen to use me as one?
An awkward silence dropped over the group
like a dragon flame cactus, full of guilt
suspicion, distrust, judgment, superiority
instead of thorn seeds.
Nobody would meet peril's eyes, not even
turtle.
I get it.
Moon said finally to Turtle.
You should be the one who decides what to
do with your abilities, not your queen, or
anyone else.
Now she glanced at peril quickly, almost
as if she were throwing out a tail for
peril to grab.
Me?
Peril thought.
Did she mean that for me too?
I never get to decide anything?
If I did, I'd probably mess up and nearly
kill or really kill someone else.
Would that rock work on Kinkaju?
Kibli asked.
Could we heal her too?
Turtle squirmed.
We could try, he said.
But I'm afraid I enchanted it to heal
scales and muscles, not internal organs
or bones.
It was only supposed to help me feel less
sore after flying all day.
I know.
I was an idiot.
I should have made it more useful.
And more obvious, Pearl said.
What a dopey thing to enchant.
It looks like every other rock in the
world.
If you drop it while you're leaning over
a river one day, you'll never find it
again.
It might work on your scar, though.
Turtle said to Kibley.
He held out the rock and Kibley jumped
away from it.
No way, he said, touching his snout.
I like my scar.
It's part of who I am.
Get your magic nonsense away from me.
Hey, Winter interrupted suddenly.
Where's Foe Slayer?
Who?
Moon asked.
I was traveling with a night wing?
He said.
Where'd she go?
Peril glanced up and realized the big
night wing was no longer in the sky above
them.
She tried to remember when she'd last
seen her, right after the fight, before
Turtle and the others showed up.
Uh, she said, I might have told her to go
get help.
Or she might have decided I was dead and
left before the same thing happened to
her.
Winter said bitterly.
He stood up in one quick coiling motion.
We needed her.
She was going to help us find the lost
city of night.
The what?
peril said.
Hey Moon said to Winter, trying to nudge
him back down.
Maybe don't make any sudden movements
until we're sure you're all right.
Also, I'm glad you came back, by the
way.
I'm all right.
Winter said, stretching his wings and
neck again.
It's like it never happened.
He turned accusing eyes on peril, who
felt them like little blades of ice
stabbing her own eyeballs.
Except that it did.
This monster threatened you and then
claimed she was here to help you.
I didn't threaten anyone, Pearl protested
not.
I mean, not really.
She is here to help us, Turtle said at
the same time.
At least I think so.
You think so?
Pearl cried, wounded.
I mean, he said anxiously, I guess I wish
you hadn't burned winter is all.
It was an accident.
Perl said.
I was trying to get away from him, and we
crashed.
It looked like a fight from what we saw
Kimley said accusingly.
Beware the talons of power and fire.
Moon said softly.
Maybe it is her.
Pearl looked from one phase to another
her heart pounding.
What are you talking about?
she said.
Moon had a vision.
A prophecy.
Turtle said.
About me?
That couldn't be a good sign.
If moon saw peril in a vision doing
terrible things, then maybe peril's bad
side really was going to win out in the
end.
Maybe it was inevitable.
Maybe she shouldn't even try to fight
it.
But Clay said, Clay believes in me.
He can't be wrong.
Can he?
Not specifically about you, Moon said.
I couldn't see any dragons' faces in the
vision, but there was one line at the
beginning.
Excuse me, Winter said.
Are we really going to tell the villain
everything we know about their evil
plan?
I don't have an evil plan.
Pearl said, starting to panic.
All my evilest spur of the moment.
Turtle, tell them how bad I am at
planning.
Maybe if she knows about the prophecy, she
can do something different, Moon said.
We can change the future, you know.
She turned apparel and said, Listen
Beware the darkness of dragons.
Beware the stalker of dreams.
Beware the talons of power and fire.
Beware one who is not what she seems.
Something is coming to shake the earth.
Something is coming to scorch the
ground.
Jade mountain will fall beneath thunder
and ice, unless the lost city of night
can be found.
Peril looked from her to the others.
Moon's eyes were glowing, as though she
was delivering a message from the stars
themselves.
Her voice got all low and shivery, and it
was decidedly creepy.
Well, Moon asked, what do you think?
You think that 1st part is about me?
Perl said.
Was that what Turtle thought too?
Was he just keeping an eye on her in case
she started scorching the ground and
knocking over mountains?
I don't stalk anyone's dreams?
And I'm exactly what I seem like on the
outside.
Also, sure I have talons of fire, but no
power whatsoever.
If I did have any power, my life would be
pretty different from what it is now
believe me.
Death is a power, winter said.
You carry death in your talent.
He lashed his tail, shooting a hard look
at Kibley and Moon.
Is this really your new ally?
I leave for 5 days and you start working
with a mass murderer?
You left pretty firmly, Kibley pointed
out.
You said you weren't coming back, so why
should you get a vote?
Also, she just showed up with Turtle.
And I can just leave again too. peril
cried.
It felt as if the thorns were still there
digging under her scales.
It felt like another crocodile in the
face.
If what she had with turtle was
friendship, and this was what came with
it, then friends were so not worth it.
I don't need this.
I don't even want to work with any of
you.
I can find Scarlet on my own.
That's what I wanted to do in the 1st
place anyway.
She launched herself into the sky.
Peril, turtle shouted.
Wait.
That was what she'd wanted him to say.
But it wasn't enough.
It wouldn't be enough, even if he could
catch up to her, which he couldn't, and
even if he apologized for his awful
friends, and promised he didn't think she
was some predestined, sinister bad guy.
Which he wouldn't.
Maybe, if he told me he'd leave them and
just be friends with me.
But he wasn't going to do that either.
She wasn't nearly as important to him as
his precious winglet.
Well, that was just fine.
She'd wasted enough time on him.
Now she could get on with finding Queen
Scarlet, killing her, and going back to
clay.
Peril said her course for the Claws of
the Clouds Mountains, soaring directly
over possibility, and beating her wings
to fly as fast as she could.
She did not look back to see if Turtle
tried to follow her.
Well, maybe once.
But he wasn't so it didn't matter.
After some time though, when possibility
was well in the distance, she became
aware of the sound of wing beats behind
her.
It seemed highly unlikely that any of
those inferiorly winged dragonettes could
have caught up to her, but she swung
around with her dangerous face on just in
case.
Oh, said the sky wing behind her.
Catching air below his wings to stop and
hover.
And then he smiled.
He smiled.
That never happened, not when dragons 1st
met her.
What was that about?
What do you want?
Peril demanded.
She was pretty sure this was the Sky Wing
who had flown out of possibility to meet
her, but had run away again once he saw
Winter and Foe Slayer.
Had he been watching for her?
Waiting for her to leave them?
Uh, he said, nothing.
Peril hovered in the air. scrutinizing
him.
He was big, a lot older than her, with
warm orange scales and amber eyes, no
scars that she could see, which was
unusual for a full grown sky wing under
Scarlet's reign.
Huge, powerful wings, long horns with
faint golden markings on them.
He also looked wealthier than the average
sky wing.
There were gold rings on 3 of his claws, a
black necklace with gold spikes circled
his throat, and an armband wove like a
snake all the way up one of his front
legs, with tiny rubies glittering like
eyes at one end.
He also had a kind of black metal sheath
fitted tightly across his chest with a
padlock on the outside, perhaps
containing more treasure.
She was reasonably certain she'd never
seen this particular sky wing before
although it was equally possible she had
and just didn't remember him.
Was he one of Queen Scarlet generals?
Maybe he'd been away overseeing soldiers
in the war.
But then, surely he'd have a war wound or
2 somewhere.
Your peril, he said.
Right?
You say that like there's actually a
chance I'm someone else, Pearl said.
Well, he said, there's always a chance
isn't there?
That was a weird thing to say.
She tilted her head at him.
I have no idea who you are.
My name, he said importantly, is sore.
Oh, Pearl said.
She thought for a moment.
Really?
That's unusual.
Is it?
he asked, deflating.
Well, yes, she said.
Not very, um, aspirational, I guess.
But it's a very sky wing name, right?
He said.
Why?
she said.
It's not like we get more sore than other
dragons.
It's probably the other way around since
we're built for flying longer distances.
Wait, he broke in.
No, no, no.
Not sore.
Soar.
S-O-A-R, like flying high over the
kingdom.
Oh, good grief.
Have other dragons been thinking my name
is sore, all these years?
Probably, Pearl said.
Why are you the 1st dragon to say
anything?
He demanded.
Peril thought for a moment.
Because I'm not polite, she said finally
no one ever taught me to be.
I don't care what dragons think, because
they won't like me even if I say all the
right things, and bow the right way, and
smile until my snout hurts.
So why should I bother?
I know what you mean, he said.
You can do and say everything exactly the
same as everyone else.
But if there's one thing different about
you.
That's all they care about.
I assume so, Pearl said.
I've never actually tried acting like
other dragons.
Well, it doesn't work, he said.
Something was glowing in his eyes.
An old, old anger.
Trust me, you still end up banished from
your own home.
Carol looked at him in surprise.
You were banished from the Sky Kingdom
too?
When?
By Ruby or by Scarlet?
What for?
It's a long story.
He said.
I'll tell you all of it someday.
But the short answer is for being
myself.
Because I had no choice back then.
For a moment, Peril wasn't sure whether
he felt familiar because she actually
knew him or because he sounded so much
like herself.
You don't need those other dragons, he
said.
The ones you were just with.
They can't understand you.
But I can help you find what you're
looking for.
Oh, really?
Pearl said.
Do you even know what that is?
I think so.
He said.
He flashed around her suddenly, heading
for the mountains.
Follow me.
That wasn't terribly convincing.
But it wasn't as though peril had a
particularly clear alternate plan
anyway.
I don't like following anyone, she
called.
With a flick of her tail, she spun
herself around, and caught up to fly
beside him.
Hey, why haven't I ever met you before?
An excellent question, he said.
The only answer I've been able to come to
is that Queen Scarlet prefers to keep her
toys separate from each other.
I'm no one's toy, Peril hissed, curling
her claws in.
Why do dragons keep saying that about her
and Scarlet?
Anyone who tries to play with me will
find that out very fast.
He tipped his head in a conciliatory
way.
My apologies.
I confess, I don't see myself that way
either.
Perhaps it would be more accurate to
say.
Scarlet didn't want her most powerful
friend joining forces against her.
Carol snorted a laugh, sending a little
burst of flames into the sky.
You're one of her most powerful friends.
What can you do?
Pay enemy dragons to run away?
Well, he said, I doubt Scarlet would
consider this useful, but among other
things, it appears that I can father
dragonettes with fire scales.
Peril blinked at him.
He stared back at her, his amber eyes
almost twinkling.
He seemed to be waiting for her to
collapse in a fit of joy, or run around
shrieking with delight or something.
Oh, really?
Pearl said.
Do you mean me?
Was that your idea of a heartwarming
revelation?
You're my father?
Yes.
He said carefully.
You don't seem very excited about that.
Why should I believe you?
She demanded.
Where have you been my whole life?
Why haven't you ever talked to me
before?
What are you trying to get out of me
now?
What made you suddenly decide to say
hello?
Hey, hey, calm down, he said.
Yeah, all right.
That certainly sounded patronizing enough
to make you my dad, Pearl said.
Do it again.
Tell me you know what's best for me.
Say something about how I don't really
understand the world, and you're here to
guide me and teach me and help me grow up
because I couldn't possibly do that on my
own.
Listen.
He said.
I didn't know you were alive.
I'm usually away doing things for the
queen.
So I missed the entire episode where
Kestrel tried to escape with you and your
brother.
By the time I returned, Queen Scarlett
told me you were dead.
She said none of Kestrel's dragonettes
had survived, and that Kestrel had gone
to join the talons of peace.
Everyone was forbidden to speak of
Kestrel, and I had no idea.
I mean, I knew you existed.
The dragonette with fire scales, but I
didn't know you were my daughter until a
few days ago.
Well, Pearl said.
I bet that came as quite a
disappointment.
Not to me, he said.
My daughter is powerful and amazing and
terrifying, who wouldn't be proud of
that.
Peril sort of wished he'd left the
terrifying out of that description, but
still, it was a weird feeling to be
featured in a sentence anywhere near the
word proud.
So, how did you find out?
she asked.
A, uh, a friend told me.
A friend?
Parel echoed.
He certainly took his time about it.
He didn't know either.
Sor protested.
His name is Sirius.
He's with the talons of peace, and when
he told me I had to, I mean, I
immediately came looking for you.
If I'd known sooner.
He trailed off.
You would have what?
Pearl asked.
Saved me from the arena, told me the
truth about the black rocks, stopped
Queen Scarlet from using me?
Stopped Ruby from banishing me?
Could you actually have been useful ever
in my life?
I'm guessing no.
I could be useful now. he said.
I can change everything for you.
I doubt that, Peril said.
She twisted into a spiral, arrowing for
the gap between the 1st 2 mountain
peaks.
The wind buffeted her wings, trying to
knock her off course, but she stayed
straight and true through the path
sweeping up into a mossy valley dotted
here and there with doomed sheep.
As the sheep stampeded in alarm and sore
caught up to peril, she spotted movement
in a cluster of trees higher up the
slope.
Her breath caught in her throat.
She knew that color orange, knew it like
a bloodbath of fear and awe sweeping
through her.
With slow, majestic wing beats.
A glittering dragon rose out of the trees
and plunged toward them.
It was Queen Scarlet.
Peril had found her.
Or she had found peril.
At last.
Chapter 11.
It's the queen, Peril said, squaring her
shoulders.
You run.
I'll stop her.
That's what I'm here for.
This is the moment when I tick her down
forever.
I'll finally use my fire for something
that will make Pyria a safer place.
Wait, Sor said.
Before you attack her, hear her out.
Peril whirled around and read the
betrayal in his face before her mind had
even processed his words.
You're working with her, she growled.
You brought me to her on purpose.
Well, he said, to be fair, that's what
she wanted, but it's also what you wanted
isn't it?
So does that really count as a betrayal?
I mean, now everyone's happy.
So, yay me?
Queen Scarlet arrived then with a wish of
hot air, circling maddeningly around
peril and sore.
Peril had forgotten how bad the scar on
her face was.
The queen looked thin and ragged, but
still alight with fury, like a cold flame
that would never go out.
Oh, ho!
Scarlet called to soar.
That's a phase I haven't seen in a
while.
Me?
Peril thought.
I've been looking for you, she called
back, whipping around to keep the queen
in sight.
You can't threaten my friends like that
and get away with it.
Friends?
Queen Scarlet laughed.
A hi, genuine laugh that bounds to
merrily off the mountain peaks.
Is that what you think glory is to you
darling?
I'm sure she cares about you so very
much.
Do you think anyone would cry if I'd
dropped your decapitated head in their
talons?
Admit it?
Nobody loves you the way you are except
me.
That's always been true, and it always
will be true.
No, it's not, Carol cried.
There are other dragons who like me.
But wouldn't they all change you if they
could?
Scarlet said pityingly.
They would strip away your fire scales
and squash your lovely craziness into a
well mannered box.
Not me, though.
I think every inch of you is just
perfect.
As long as I do what you want, Peril
pointed out, the minute I have a thought
of my own, you hate me.
Oh, Scarlet said.
That sounds new.
Have you had any of these thoughts of
your own yet?
All I've seen from you so far are those
mud wings, thoughts, and decisions.
If you actually do have one of your very
own, I can't wait to hear about it.
Can you 2 please stop arguing?
Peril's father interjected.
He angled down to land on a circle of
giant boulders, peril swooped after him
choosing the barest rock she could find
and Scarlett joined them a moment later.
The 3 Skywings glowered at one another
for a long moment.
At least, Pearl and Scarlet were
glowering, Thor looked infuriatingly
pleased with himself.
I'm smarter than you think, he said to
Queen Scarlet.
I figured it out.
You lied to me all these years, but I
know the truth now.
How thrilling for you.
She replied with lidded eyes, hissing
smoke out her nostrils.
This is Kestrel's daughter, he said, his
voice rising.
My daughter.
His tail flicked toward perils, as though
he were tempted to twine it around hers
but stopped at the last moment.
Yes, I know.
Scarlett said.
She certainly is, but you didn't deserve
to know.
You had no right to do what you did.
And so I decided you'd never get to meet
the monster that came of it.
I'm sure every queen in Pyria would agree
with me.
Why?
What did he do?
Pearl asked.
Her heart felt like a campfire that was
about to be stomped out.
Scarlet smirked.
So, you still haven't told her.
I love it.
Acting all indignant and self-righteous
about me lying to you, and yet here you
are, lying to your own daughter right
now.
Tisk, tisk, tisk.
I'm not agreeing with her.
Peril said to Soor, but I don't like
being lied to.
What is she talking about?
Now is, is not the time, Thor said
awkwardly.
I'll tell her everything later.
You don't need to tell her, said the
queen.
I'll just go ahead and show her.
In a lightning fast move.
She suddenly leaped from her boulder to
sores, flipped him onto his back and
pinned him to the boulder.
Stop.
Sora cried, pushing ineffectively at
Scarlet's claws, peril reared up with her
wings flared wide.
This is it.
I should kill her.
I'd be saving my father.
This is the right moment.
Even Clay would want me to.
Now.
Do it now, peril.
But, what was the truth, Scarlet wanted
her to know.
And what if she attacked the wrestling
dragons and accidentally burned her
father as well?
And how could she kill the dragon who'd
kept her alive when everyone else wanted
her dead?
And what if the queen was right?
What if no one else ever did love peril?
What if killing Scarlet didn't work to
change everyone's minds?
What if she made another mistake, like
she had with winter?
Only someone really died?
And then even Clay had to hate her, and
she got thrown out of Jade Mountain
forever.
And all the queens and all the kingdoms
banished her, and she had nowhere to go
and no one else in the world.
Wouldn't she regret killing her queen
then?
Wouldn't she wished there was someone
left alive who loved her?
All these thoughts flashed through her
head at once, making peril hesitate long
enough to realize that Scarlet wasn't
attacking sore.
The queen was merely holding sore down
while she sliced off the gold spiked
necklace he was wearing.
For such a big, strong looking sky wing
he was obviously not much of a fighter.
He protested loudly, but barely
struggled.
Finally, Queen Scarlet was able to rip
the leather in two, and the choker
clattered to the ground, revealing a
strip of something small and white tucked
into a hidden pocket inside it.
There.
Scarlet said, stepping back with a
satisfied toss of her head.
Sor scrambled to his feet, scowling.
But his eyes were no longer amber.
And his orange scales were shifting
shrinking and changing color, just like
the decapitated not glory head.
Peril jumped back, leaving scorch marks
across the moss on the edge of the rock.
He's not a sky wing.
Was he a night wing?
Could he be the night wing who had
followed her and turtle earlier?
If I'm half Nightwing, maybe I have some
cool powers I don't know about.
Maybe their tribe would take me in.
I bet they'd like me if they could figure
out how to use me.
But sores scales weren't turning black
either.
They were turning green.
Not a rich, dark green like turtles
scales.
In fact, not a color green that peril had
ever seen on any sea wing before.
Sor was now the color of limes and jungle
parakeets, a sort of nondescript
yellowish green that clashed horribly
with the moss under him.
He was also skinnier than he had been
before, with narrower shoulders and less
shiny teeth.
His wings were smaller and his tail, his
tail coiled in a loop behind him like a
monkey's or like a, A rain wing?
Peril said.
Seriously?
My father is a rain wing?
Is this a joke?
He is not much of a rain wing, Scarlett
said, smirking.
That's why they threw him out.
Just like you, actually.
Banished from his kingdom.
Like father, like daughter.
No one wants either of you anywhere.
Except me, of course.
Wouldn't a little gratitude be in order
here?
So what if I am a rain wing?
Pearl's father said to the queen.
When I met Kestrel, I was a full Sky
Wing.
She never knew I was anything else.
Our dragonettes would have been full sky
wings.
That's how it works.
Ha!
Scarlet snorted.
You don't know that.
I say it's no coincidence.
This one turned out the way she did.
Sky Wing should only have eggs with other
Sky Wings, and here's your proof.
That's not proof, he snapped.
Skywings have been having dragonets with
fire scales for centuries.
You can't blame that on me.
It has nothing to do with... with who I
really am.
I'm a hybrid?
Pearl said, not quite following this
conversation.
How can I be half rain wing?
I don't look anything like them.
She held out her talons and tried to will
her scales to change color.
When nothing happened?
She touched her front fangs, wondering
whether they could secretly shoot venom.
Not that she needed extra weaponry, but
it would be pretty cool anyway.
You are not a hybrid, said her father, a
little impatiently, considering he was
dropping a basket full of crazy on her
head.
I was a sky wing when I met Kestrel and
fathered you.
You wouldn't have any rain wing
characteristics.
You're all Skywing.
But what are you talking about?
You were a Sky Wing.
Peril asked.
Turning your scales orange doesn't make
you a sky wing.
Ha, ha, ha.
Scarlet laughed.
You can't even do that, my dear.
No, but I can do other things, he
snapped.
I have a gift, peril.
Look.
He picked up the ripped necklace and held
it around his neck.
Once more, his scales rippled, this time
back to orange, and suddenly soar the sky
wing was standing in front of peril
again.
See, he said, in his deeper, stronger
voice.
I can change my entire self.
Now, I'm a full sky wing.
With a terrible name you gave yourself
peril guest, that explains that.
What's your real name?
Chameleon, he said, dropping the necklace
and turning back into the defensive green
dragon.
Some dragons might say that was a cruel
irony, while others, for instance, an
entire tribe of rain wings, might laugh
and laugh for days once everyone realizes
that the dragon named Chameleon is the
only one in the rainforest who can't
change his scales.
Peril wasn't particularly interested in
his sob stories from the past.
Pieces were starting to come together in
her head.
You're the one who enchanted the head to
look like glory, Peril said.
You're helping Queen Scarlet scare my
friends.
Hey, she pays very well, he said
displaying the rings on his claws.
At least she used to.
I've had more treasure than any rain wing
in the history of Pyria for years now.
The last several months haven't been
quite the same, though.
He shot a disapproving look at the
queen.
I'll have my kingdom back soon enough
Queen Scarlet said.
Although I think you owe me for the prize
you lost a few days ago.
Peril closed her eyes, frowning.
This conversation was distracting her
from her goal, killing Scarlet.
If that was still the right thing to do
was it?
Queen Scarlet didn't seem so terrifying
and monstrous here in this quiet valley
talking about peril's lovely craziness
and her father.
Remember all the terrible things she's
done?
That random mud wings she killed to get
that head?
Sending Clay and his friends to fight in
the arena?
Forcing my mother to kill my twin
brother?
But she kept me alive.
When everyone else in the tribe would
have had me killed the moment I hatched
and she's right, she never wanted to
change me.
She likes my scales the way they are.
I'm not sure even clay feels that way.
She remembered him wincing when he
touched her, and the way he watched her
wings carefully when she was near
anything flammable.
Did Scarlet really have to die?
Oh, clay.
Why can't you be here to tell me what's
right?
She opened her eyes and looked at
Chameleon, who was fiddling with the
metal sheath around his chest.
This was Scarlet's mysterious new ally.
Peril's own father, a disgraced rain wing
with strange shape shifting abilities.
He wasn't so terrifying either.
Would it be so bad if Scarlet did get her
thrown back?
What if Ruby agreed to step down, and
Scarlet agreed to leave peril's friends
alone, and peril agreed to stop setting
dragons on fire, unless they really
deserved it.
And everything went mostly back to
normal.
Peril, said Chameleon, breaking into her
thoughts.
I know I haven't been a father to you
before, but I can change that.
I think I can give you a gift that's
everything you've always wanted.
There's nothing I've always wanted, Pearl
said.
The image of clay wrapping his wings
around her and never letting go flashed
through her head, but she shoved it
away.
She was a long way off from getting that
or deserving it, or feeling as if she
could accept it even if Clay ever stop
thinking about this.
She ordered herself.
Oh, really?
Chameleon pulled out a thick chain of
silvery black metal links, with a black
locket dangling from one end of it.
Peril recognized the metal as the kind
scarlet used to bind the wings and ankles
of her prisoners, impervious to most
dragonfire, but not to perils.
Carved on the outside of the locket was a
dragon shape, wings spread and tail
curled in 2 loops below, inlaid with a
golden copper metal that glinted in the
sunlight, like perils scales.
Peril regarded it for a moment.
You're right, she said.
All my life, I have desperately wanted an
ugly necklace.
Hey, Chameleon protested, as Queen
Scarlet gave a shout of laughter.
Especially one that will melt the moment
I put it on, Pearl said.
Thank you so much.
Best dad ever.
This is the kind of parenting fun you've
missed out on, Scarlett said to him.
You're welcome.
It's not just a necklace, Chameleon
insisted, ignoring Scarlet.
Peril.
No, do you understand what I can do?
I can turn you into anyone you want.
I can make you a sea wing or an ice wing
or even a scavenger.
If you particularly wanted to get eaten
for some reason, I can make you a mud
wing.
I can take away your fire scales.
Don't you see?
You could be normal.
You could be a dragon who can touch other
dragons.
You don't have to be this monster
everyone is afraid of.
I can change you.
Peril stared at him, wondering if her
scales were floating off into the clouds
the way it felt like they might be.
I thought your power was only meant to be
used for special cases.
Scarlet mused.
Something about consequences and risks
and something blah.
This is a special case.
Chameleon said.
I'd do anything for my dragonette.
Aw.
Scarlet said sarcastically.
What a rare and unusual parent.
Something seemed to strike her, and she
inhaled a plume of smoke, turning her
head to gaze thoughtfully toward the
north.
You're serious, Peril said to her
father.
This is real.
I put that necklace on, and I won't be me
anymore?
She couldn't figure out how she felt
about that.
It sounded glorious and awful at the same
time.
No more peril, no more peril.
Everyone would be safe from her forever.
But without my fire scales.
Who am I?
It's up to you, he answered.
This particular necklace is only
enchanted to take away your fire scales.
You'll still be you, the same peril, with
all your own personality and history.
But you'll have normal sky wing scales.
And you'll be able to touch whoever you
want without hurting them.
Can you imagine?
You'd be a regular dragon.
But if you want a different enchantment
turning you into someone else entirely, I
could do that too.
I could be a mudwing.
Someone Clay could be with and love
without anyone hating me for it.
They don't even need to know that I used
to be peril.
Except for him.
I need him to know who I really am.
I'd have to tell him about this
transformation as myself 1st.
I could be peril for now.
Save peril, no fire scales, no danger to
anyone, and then, after I talk to him, I
could become whoever he won.
Clay could decide.
He could imagine the perfect dragon for
himself, and that's what I could become.
Exactly what he wants in every detail.
Then he would have to love me.
Wouldn't he?
She started to reach for the necklace
then pulled back.
It won't work, she said.
That necklace will melt and fall apart
the moment it touches my scales.
This metal is thick and strong.
Chameleon said, and the transformation
only takes a moment.
I think it will last until your scales
are safe.
If you put it on quickly.
It's worth a try, isn't it?
And if it doesn't work, we'll make
something else.
But if it does work, don't take it off.
The more times it goes on and off, the
more chances there are of destroying it.
Peril hesitated, one last time.
This isn't a trick, right?
I'll still be myself?
Of course, said Chameleon.
Just like I am always myself, but each of
my faces is a better version of me.
You'll be peril, but finally, apparel
that dragons can love.
And if it is a trick, Pearl thought.
And I disappear.
Would it be such a great loss for the
world?
Would clay even miss me?
Wouldn't turtle be happy never to see me
again?
She snatched the necklace from
Chameleon's claws and dropped it over her
head, over her horns, until it landed
around her neck, the locket hitting her
chest with a thump.
She waited for it to curl into a molten
mess.
But it didn't.
Nothing happened.
Actually, nothing.
It just sat there.
Peril felt exactly the same.
She poked the necklace.
Nothing, just a necklace, hanging around
her neck, ostentatiously not melting.
How do you feel?
Chameleon asked.
Carol looked up to find both of them
squinting at her.
She held out her talons to examine them.
Do I look any different?
Not much, said Chameleon.
Less incandescent, said Scarlett.
More disappointing.
More ordinary.
She spat out the last word like a rotten
pear, but it sounded beautiful to peril.
Really?
Peril turned, and saw a small yellow
flower growing out of a crack in the
boulder she sat on, she slowly reached
out one claw, her whole arm trembling, and
brushed the pedals.
The flower wobbled.
The flower bent with peril's claw, slipped
back to its place, and fluttered its
yellowness cheerfully in the wind.
The flower lived.
Did you see that?
Pearl gasped.
Yawn, said Scarlett.
Perl poked the flower again, and when it
still didn't burst into flame, she leaped
off the boulder entirely, landing on all
4s in the grass below.
The grass lived.
Peril ran full out across the meadow
stomping her talons into the grass
flicking branches with her wings rolling
in patches of ivy, ramming her side into
trees.
Everything lived.
She startled a sheep out of its hiding
place in a cave, and it galloped across
her path, bleeding with shaggy terror.
Delighted, Pearl thwacked it with her
tail, sending it bouncing across the
grass several feet.
It leaped up and kept running away, and a
grin the size of jade mountains spread
across peril's face.
Look at me!
She shouted to her father and her queen.
She grabbed a tree with her front talons
and shook it until a mortified squirrel
fell out.
I can do anything.
Except wreak fiery vengeance on my
enemies.
Queen Scarlet muttered grumpily.
Peril skipped back across the grass to
them, settling herself on top of the most
flammable patch of foliage she could find
and it survived.
Nothing was on fire in this hole entire
valley.
This was the most beautiful place in the
world.
Don't worry, she said to the queen
breathing a small spurt of perfectly
normal dragon flame from her mouth.
We can still do that.
The vengeance, enemies, whatever thing.
Where do you want to start?
Queen Scarlet sat up and looked at her.
Then she looked at Chameleon.
He bowed deeply.
His wings spread wide.
Add your service, your majesty.
He said with a smile.
I do have one great idea.
Queen Scarlet said, regarding peril
thoughtfully.
Then what are we waiting for?
Pearl asked.
Let's go get your kingdom back.
Part three.
A new peril.
Chapter 12.
They flew north immediately, as darkness
began to stretch across the mountains
below them, and the tiny heartbeats of
stars started to flicker in the sky.
Peril felt light, lighter than she
thought she'd ever felt before.
She was like smoke on the wind, like a
drift of dandelion seeds.
She was free.
I have nothing to worry about anymore.
She did a flip in the air, swooped up
behind her father, who was back in his
sky wing shape as sore, although somehow
without his ripped necklace, that was
weird.
She should ask him how he'd done that
later, probably by enchanting something
else.
Whatever, no big deal.
And tackled him, so he toppled sideways
and had to do a funny, frantic flapping
spiral to recover.
Peril laughed and laughed.
I've never been able to do that to anyone
before, she cried.
I've always wanted to tackle someone in
midair.
She zoomed around him and nudged one of
his wings heartily with one of hers
unbalancing him again, and that I've
always wanted to do that.
Could you perhaps save some of your
affectionate impulses for when I'm not
fighting an updraft?
Chameleon asked.
Ducking out of her way as she dive bombed
him again?
I mean, I love it.
Thank you.
But it's a little vigorous for night
flying for me.
You're the best, Pearl said.
She couldn't stop herself from body
checking him in the side again.
That was the last time.
I promise, she called as he reeled away.
Because when we get to the Sky Palace
there will be lots of dragons to do this
too, I'm going to nudge wings and poke
tails and hug everyone.
No.
Queen Scarlet said sharply.
She swung around and lined herself up to
fly alongside peril.
You can do that, not until I have the
throne back.
No one can know that you're powerless
now.
I need the threat of you, which should be
as effective as the actual fire of you
after the last 7 years.
Once we've secured the throne, and I've
killed Ruby.
Then you can be as dippy and cuddly and
stupid as you want.
Oh, Peril said, her light dimming a
little.
She had been hoping for a triumphant
return as safe peril, ordinary peril, one
of you, a regular sky wing who can
totally just be part of the tribe now.
Let's be friends.
Hooray!
But Queen Scarlet had a point.
She needed peril's help, and that's what
peril was here for after all.
All right, peril said, with a flick of
her tail.
It won't take long to make you queen
again anyway.
You'll have to pay attention, said the
queen.
Don't do anything stupid.
Act exactly as you always have, and don't
touch anything.
In fact, don't say anything either.
Just stand there and look menacing.
I can do that.
Pearl said cheerfully.
I'll practice my menacing face right
now.
You sound like you're digesting an
overweight grizzly bear.
Scarlet commented acidly.
I think it's perfect, said Chameleon.
Thanks, Dad.
Pearl said grinning.
Dragonettes, Scarlett muttered.
I never saw the appeal.
The Sky Palace came into view ahead of
them.
Its towers and turrets and spires jutting
through the clouds around the mountain
peaks like long spindly claws.
The fading sunlight seemed to catch for a
moment in the queen's eyes, adding a
glimmer of menace to her yellow gaze as
she regarded the palace.
That's why this never occurred to me
before, she went on.
But I should have remembered.
It was only a couple of months before the
whole catastrophe.
Chameleon cleared his throat, and the
queen glanced at him, trading some kind
of significant unspoken message.
Won't there be guards?
Chameleon asked quickly, patrolling
around the mountains.
Not as many as there would be if Ruby
were home, Queen Scarlet said, but she's
still off hunting for me, and trying to
identify missing heads.
It's the perfect opportunity to take
over.
And get the leverage I need to keep it
that way.
Two Skywings suddenly emerged from the
mist, flapping toward them with spears
clutched in their talons and fearsome
scowls etched on their snouts.
Still, Chameleon said.
Um, any guards seems like a problem
right?
Not for us.
Queen Scarlet said, tossing her head
triumphantly at peril.
Let's go, darling.
Darling.
Peril thought with delight as she soared
up behind the queen.
That's me.
She does love me.
The 2 guards lifted their spears when
they saw Queen Scarlet approaching, but a
moment later, they saw peril, and she saw
them recognize her, and she saw the fear
that engulfed them.
One dropped his spear and turned tail
instantly, fleeing back to the palace as
fast as his wings could carry him.
The other hovered indecisively for a
moment, shifting her weapon from talon to
talon, and flicking her tail like a leaf
about to be blown off a tree.
Then she, too, broke down and fled.
Peril watched them go, feeling hurt and
lonely, and misunderstood exactly the way
she always had, and trying to reach for
that part of her that was too fierce and
scary to care.
But it's different now, she told
herself.
It'll all be different once they know
that I'm normal.
Maybe we'll even be friends.
That would be cool.
I've never had a real friend before.
Something poked to the corners of her
mind.
Oh, that sea wing, turtle.
I guess he was sort of a friend, apart
from lying to me.
She realized that she should tell Queen
Scarlet that the sea wings had an
animus.
That was definitely the kind of thing the
queen would want to know.
Plus, it would be pretty impressive to be
the dragon who got to tell her such an
important and surprising secret.
She twisted toward the queen, but Scarlet
was already in a dive, aiming for an
opening high in one of the towers.
It was a room peril had never been to, as
far as she could remember, and she flew
after Scarlet, puzzling over what it
could be.
If she'd had a normal dragonette hood, she
might have been able to guess from the
murmur of little voices that came through
the windows.
Then again, if she'd had a normal
dragonette hood, she'd have spent most of
it right here.
They swooped through the highest opening
of the tower, straight into an enormous
space full of Sky Wing Dragonettes.
The wingery, peril realized.
Of course, I'd never have been allowed in
here, staying out of the way of clumsy
floppy dragonettes was always the hardest
thing about moving around the palace.
In fact, the danger of running into peril
was probably why most dragonettes were
confined to the wingery until they had
better control of their limbs.
The youngest dragonettes were play
fighting on the floor, far below peril
near the base of the tower, where black
and gold rugs overlapped.
Toy weapons were scattered around them.
Blunt spears and dented shields, leaning
haphazardly against balls and attack
dummies, and what appeared to be toy
cooking supplies stacked with bits of
half chewed goat bones and other snacks
slightly older dragonettes swarmed the
walls and climbing structures above the
rugs, clambering busily along fake rocky
outcroppings, and jumping to gradually
higher and higher platforms.
A few of them slipped and fell, but the
padded rugs below caught them without
injury.
At the highest levels, closer to the
ceiling was space for flying practice
longer spaces to cross with each leap
ropes to catch on mid-flight, obstacles
to practice swerving around.
Here the biggest dragonettes stretched
their wings, red and orange, swerving
around one another as they cat called and
showed off new moves.
They all seemed so happy.
Not just happy.
Unworried, like nothing could trouble
them, like all they needed was a place to
fly and friends to fly with.
What would I be like if I'd grown up in
this wingery?
Peril wondered.
Would I have friends?
Would I giggle like that?
The memory of turtle tugged at her again
and she shook it off.
She'd known him for what?
4 days?
That hardly counted as true friendship.
He was probably glad she was gone.
The walls in here were not as embellished
with gold and jewels as the rest of the
palace.
Peril wondered if Queen Scarlet didn't
trust dragonettes to keep their grubby
claws off her treasure.
Instead, the room was full of light and
air from windows and skylights, most of
which were barred, especially on the
lower levels.
So none of the crawlers or new flyers
could fall out.
The only decoration was a portrait of
Scarlet, 5 times the size of the actual
queen.
It covered a huge swath of wall, forcing
dragonettes to find ways to climb or flap
around it.
Queen Scarlet's perfect orange scales
bright yellow eyes, and cascades of
jewelry glowed over the whole wingery, as
if she were approving of their play while
also imprinting their young brains, with
a constant reminder that she was the
queen, and always would be, hinted her
expression.
In fact, it was surprising that Ruby
hadn't taken that down yet.
Peril reflected.
Perhaps the interior design of her palace
wasn't quite as high a priority for her
as it had been for her mother.
Look how beautiful Scarlet was, Parel
thought.
She glanced at the disfiguring scar glory
had left on the queen's face and gave a
little shudder of pity.
Glory, how did she get to the queen?
What was I doing when that happened?
How did I fail her?
Queen Scarlet swooped to a perch at the
peak of the tower on a winding branch
carved from wood.
It twisted across the roof as though it
was the finish line for all the
dragonettes, trying to reach the top of
the room.
Peril wanted to sit on it herself.
Her wings were starting to get tired, but
she remembered that she was still
supposed to be all fire scales.
So instead, she made herself hover just
below the queen.
A hush fell over the wingery.
Very slowly, as several dragonettes were
too busy playing to notice either the
growing quiet, or the giant dragon
glowering from above, the Queen Scarlet
waited, smoke hissing from her snout and
ears.
As they noticed her, many of the
dragonettes let out squeals of fear.
A few of them near the floor dove under
whatever they could reach, hiding their
faces behind shields, or rugs, or goat
spattered saucepots, although their
trembling tails were still stuck out in
the open.
A few of the others began to whisper.
Is that the dragon in the picture?
That's not the old missing queen, is it?
What's wrong with her face?
She don't look like her picture.
How'd she get all meltedish?
That's really gross.
Grows like cardinal drooling when he
sleeps.
Shut up.
Way grosser than that.
I wish my face was all melty and scary.
Ew, you do not.
We would so never play with you if it
was.
But you'd be scared of me, and then I
could creep up on anyone in the dark and
give them nightmares forever.
It would be awesome.
Yak.
I bet she can't even look in mirrors
anymore.
My mom said she used to be wicked scary.
And kind of mean, not like Queen Ruby.
She looked kind of meanish now, I
thinking.
Should we be more scared?
Gradually, the Whispers too fell silent
under Queen Scarlet's withering glare.
Hello, dragonettes.
She finally hissed.
I am your queen, Queen Scarlet of the Sky
Wings.
I have returned to take my throne, but I
need something from you.
Someone, actually.
Excuse me?
A little voice piped up.
I'm thinking maybe you in the wrong
palace, maybe?
We already has a queen.
Queen Ruby, she's super nice.
Ruby is not your queen.
Scarlet snarled.
She is an imposter.
I am your queen.
What's a...
Nymposser, asked another voice.
It's furry and sleeps upside down and has
a really chewy tail, said another.
Melty face, ma'am, use wrong.
Ruby's not furry at all.
And I bet her tail's not chewy either, but
I hasn't checked.
She's a very nice queen offered yet
another dragonette, and she visits all
the time, and knows all our names, and
says sorry when she bumps into someone
and brings us snacks, and we like her
lots.
Maybe you could be queen of someone
else.
A small orange dragonette suggested.
Because we already got to good one, but I
hear that there are some night wings
maybe looking for a new queen, and maybe
because they spooky too.
Maybe they like your spooky face.
Ooh, yes, a few others agreed.
She'd be super good, spooky.
They could change their name to spooky
wings, our nightmare faces.
Stop talking this instant.
Queen Scarlet bellowed.
Peril was finding it close to impossible
to keep a straight face.
She wished there had been a chorus of
impertinent dragonets around for every
conversation she'd ever had with the
queen.
Perched on the windowsill.
Chameleon wasn't even trying to hide how
his shoulders were shaking with
laughter.
Sheesh!
One of the little voices muttered as they
subsided.
Just making some helpful suggestibles.
No need to be crank monstery.
I am looking, Queen Scarlet said, cold
and clear. with iron in her voice.
For a dragonette named Cliff.
Now everyone really was silent.
The Skywing Dragonettes glanced around
and easily, and then gradually one head
after another turned toward a small, dark
red dragon with a long neck, who was
clinging to a platform near the ground.
He looked no more than 8 or 9 months
old.
He stared up at Queen Scarlet in peril
his tiny claws trembling.
Suddenly, peril didn't feel like laughing
anymore.
A grim smile spread across Queen
Scarlet's face.
Hello, little prince, she said.
I thought it was time for you to meet
your grandmother.
Chapter 13.
Prince Cliff was by far the teeniest
dragon peril had ever been this close
to.
If she hadn't known that her scales were
safe to touch, she would never have dared
to stand so close, no matter what Queen
Scarlet's orders were.
She tried to wink at him in a friendly
way, but she must have done it wrong.
Friendly wings weren't exactly something
she'd ever had a chance to practice.
Since it just made him throw his wings
over his head and curl into a shivering
ball.
She didn't love that.
She wanted to hug him.
She could hug dragons now, and tell him
not to be scared, that she wasn't scary
at all, not anymore, but she had her
orders, and she couldn't ruin Queen
Scarlet's plan, not when it was working
so well.
They'd marched the dragonette out of the
wingery, and down the long winding
tunnels with sky wings scattering and
panic before them. 3 guards had tried to
resist, standing firm at the entrance to
the throne room, but when Parel stepped
toward them with her talons outstretched
one outright fainted with terror, and the
other 2 were distracted long enough for
Scarlet to leap forward and kill them.
Much better, Scarlett said with
satisfaction, shoving the bodies to the
side at the door, and then setting all 3
guards on fire.
The one who was only unconscious woke up
screaming, but the screams didn't last
very long.
Chameleon herded Cliff into the throne
room, and plunked him on the lower
visitor's throne, which Byrne had often
used during alliance meetings.
Queen Scarlet swarmed onto her own throne
the tall column carved in the shape of
clouds that sat in the center of nearly
all perils memories of her.
Queen Scarlet issuing orders.
Queen Scarlet, scolding peril for
whatever new thing she'd done wrong, Queen
Scarlet, choosing who would die under
peril's talons today.
The queen poked at her throne for a few
minutes, sniffing with disgust as though
she could smell traces of ruby on it, and
then she settled herself majestically and
stared out the open wall opposite her.
From up there, peril knew, the queen
could see a sweeping view of her
kingdom.
The claws of the clouds mountains
scratching the sky all the way to the far
horizon.
Stand next to the prince, Scarlett
ordered peril.
Close enough to grab him if anyone comes
in.
Cliff whimpered. and tried to make
himself smaller.
I remember when you hatched, Queen
Scarlet said to the little red
dragonette.
It was like someone had woken up Ruby for
the 1st time in years.
I'm afraid your mother has always been
very, very boring.
No spark in her at all, which, of course
is why I allowed her to live.
But when she saw you for the 1st time
suddenly, there were sparks.
You'd think your scales were plated with
gold, and you'd crawled out with
sapphires wrapped around your tail.
I can understand a dragon getting excited
about treasure, but that excited about an
ordinary dragonette.
It was very weird.
You are merely ordinary, aren't you
little grandson?
I can tell.
No, Cliff said suddenly, sitting up and
puffing out his chest.
I is not.
Scuffling and stamping sounds came from
the hall outside the throne room, as if a
couple of dragons were trying to put out
the last of the fire.
The queen watched with narrow eyes, as a
dragon with bright red scales edged
inside and threw himself into a deep bow
before her.
Mother, he said, with a little too much
enthusiasm.
She kept her gaze fixed on him, smoke
rising from her nostrils.
Your majesty, he added quickly.
You're alive.
You've returned.
What a, uh, what a glorious day for the
Sky Kingdom.
We are all so, so, so, uh, blessed and
lucky.
And relieved.
Yes, this is thrilling.
It really is.
Vermillion.
Said the queen, and peril shivered.
The weight of the fury in that one word.
Peril hoped she'd never have to hear
Scarlet say, peril, like that.
She might as well have called her son
disappointment.
Uh, great day.
He said, his voice hiccuping over the
words.
He threw a confused look at peril, as if
he didn't expect to see her there, which
was odd because where else would she be?
So...
Great.
Tell me, Vermilion, the queen growled.
Why exactly did you allow your sister to
steal my throne?
Steel, she, he stammered.
I didn't, we thought.
Did you really think I was dead?
Queen Scarlet sat up and spread her wings
so she loomed over the whole space.
Me?
Yeah, yeah.
Yes?
He tried.
His expression clearly indicating that he
wasn't sure which answer would get him
killed faster.
Really, she said.
Oh, never mind dreams, is that it?
Every night, for months, I came to you.
I told you where I was.
I told you to send an army for me.
Then, after I escaped from Bern, I told
you to meet me.
I told you to form a plan to get my
throne back.
I told you to kill your sister.
Did you do even one of those things?
Vermilion?
Yikes.
Parold thought.
She remembered the nightly visits from
Scarlet, full of guilt and rage and
expectations.
It hadn't occurred to her that Queen
Scarlet might be using the dream visitor
to stalk other dragons besides her.
Poor vermilion.
But I didn't know it was real. he
protested weakly, could have been my, um
subconscious.
You mean your guilty conscience.
Queen Scarlet snapped, except I told you
about the dream visitor.
I followed you through every normal dream
you had.
Every night you promised to do as I
commanded.
And then I woke up.
He said miserably, and it seemed crazy to
obey a dream.
Or a queen who wasn't right in front of
you, Scarlet guessed, because it was
easier to be a coward, and obey my little
mouse daughter, and hope I never came
back, rather than to be loyal to your
true queen.
I'm sorry.
Vermilion dropped his head, and his wings
drooped to the floor.
I know you're going to kill me.
Or would you rather have me kill myself?
Not just yet?
Scarlet said, flicking her tail.
I want to know what Ruby has ruined in my
absence.
It looks like she's been prying my
treasure right out of the walls in here.
Pearl glanced around and realized the
queen was right.
The throne room used to have so much gold
inlaid in the walls that stepping inside
on a bright day would give you an instant
headache.
At least half of that gold was gone now
maybe only wisps of cloud shapes here and
there.
Um, said Vermilion.
Yes, about that.
Or was it other dragons stealing from me
Queen Scarlet guest.
As soon as they thought I was gone, and
they knew a weakling was in power, did
they immediately start stripping the
bones of the palace?
No, no, Vermilion said.
No one did that.
It was Ruby.
She took the gold and used it to...
Uh, she spit it out.
The queen hissed.
She turned your arena into a hospital.
He blurted.
She pardoned all the prisoners and
brought in doctors and healers from other
tribes to teach ours everything they know
and she made space for all the wounded
soldiers from the war, and she's been
finding them all places to live and jobs
to do, and using the gold for all of
that.
A long silence followed.
Queen Scarlet flicked her tongue out and
in, regarding vermilion with slitted
yellow eyes.
You like her.
She said suddenly.
You think Ruby is a good queen.
No, he protested, flapping his wings with
alarm.
Never.
You're the only good queen.
I liked my arena job.
It's absolutely terrible here now.
We always loved all the, uh, the
fighting.
We missed you so much.
Hmm, said the queen.
Well, luckily your opinion counts for
nothing.
The throne is mine again now.
And Ruby can either accept that, or fight
me and die.
She cast a sideways glance at Prince
Cliff, and a serpentine grin slipped
across her face.
When is my hapless daughter scheduled to
return?
she asked.
Tomorrow morning, said Vermilion.
She sent an advanced messenger.
Excellent.
Queen Scarlet tapped her claws on the
edge of the throne.
I think I'll wait for her right here.
Vermilion.
Make an effort to be useful and send up
food from the kitchens.
She hesitated, then added with a growl.
Perhaps it's worth noting to anyone
involved that Prince Cliff will be
tasting everything before I eat it.
Oh, peril thought.
She's afraid of being poisoned?
She never was before.
Vermilion bowed again, and stumbled out
the door in his haste to be gone.
The night wore on with a procession of
sky wings, skittering through the throne
room, bowing and scraping, and
apologizing, and extolling the wonders of
Scarlet's return.
But peril couldn't help thinking, there
should be more of them.
The halls were quieter than she
remembered them being, and there was a
general hush over the palace, as if half
the dragons were in hiding, waiting for
something to change, waiting for Ruby to
return presumably, waiting to see what
would happen, and who would win?
The ones who came in were betting on
Scarlet.
Hoping that by throwing themselves at her
feet right away, they'd be safe, and
perhaps even elevated in her renewed
regime.
Peril could see Queen Scarlet assessing
them each.
Filing their faces away in her memory.
Five of the biggest dragons were assigned
to stand guard, filling the throne room
the way it had always been filled.
And yet.
Peril was sure she wasn't the only one in
here, wondering how deep each Sky Wing's
loyalty really went.
At least she has me, she thought.
She stretched out her talons to look at
them, feeling pleased.
It'll be worth it eventually.
All these looks of hatred I keep getting
because soon they'll know this new me.
Soon, Queen Scarlet will be back in power
safe and sound, and I can start changing
everyone's minds about me.
Still, there was something unsettling
about the looks, as though her scales
were thinner now that they weren't fire
scales.
Or maybe the looks were different.
There was something about them that said
betrayal, and backstabber, where before
it had just been normal fear.
Strange.
Maybe she was imagining things.
Long after midnight, Queen Scarlet curled
her tail in and fell asleep on her
throne.
Perel's father too, was already asleep.
His big orange wings flopped out on the
floor on the far side of the throne from
peril and cliff.
The little prince was not asleep though.
He was tracing his claws along the
grooves in the rock below him, singing
softly to himself.
At one point he sat up, looked up at the
sleeping queen, and then glanced
hopefully at peril.
Sorry, she said, hoping her voice sounded
kind, although to her ears it mostly
sounded drippy.
I'm under orders to stay awake all night
which means not letting you escape.
He looked down at his claws again.
Okay.
He poked the rock once more, then raised
his giant eyes to her again.
They were sort of the color of goldfish, a
golden orange that was much prettier than
scarlet's yellow eyes.
Want to hear a song?
He whispered.
A song?
Pearl said.
Really?
I made it up myself just nowish, he
said.
All right.
But quietly, said Pearl.
The queen would really hate to be woken
up.
The queen.
Oh.
You mean grandmother, he said.
Peril stifled a laugh.
She didn't think anyone had ever dared
call Queen Scarlet grandmother before.
Ready?
Prince Cliff flipped his wings back and
stretched his long neck theatrically.
You, the audience.
So listen up.
We, the dragons of the sky.
We can fly and fly and fly.
We go up so super high.
We the dragons of the sky.
And we know my mom is best, better queen
and all the rest.
She come save us from this mess.
We, the dragons, dragons, dragons of the
sky.
Peril arched her browse at him.
Cliff gave her a cheeky smile.
What you think?
He asked.
I think maybe don't sing that song to
your grandma, Pearl suggested.
I think maybe mess and rest don't rhyme
so right, he said.
Test, West, Vest.
Hmm.
I'm a good rhymer, mommy says so.
You don't seem all that scared anymore
said Pearl.
Yeah, he said, with a small flick of his
dark red tail.
Because Uncle Vermilion said, mommy's
coming in the morning, and she makes
everything better no matter what.
Pearl wondered if she could actually
collapse around the chasm that had
suddenly yawned in her chest.
She makes everything better.
Peril had never felt that way about
anyone.
Queen Scarlet kept her alive, gave her a
purpose, valued her, but made things
better, no.
Mostly perils days were made worse
whenever she encountered the queen.
So why do you follow her?
Whispered a tiny part of her brain?
Because what choice do I have?
peril whispered back.
Who else am I going to follow?
No one else wants me.
Grandma's kind of mean.
Cliff observed, watching Pearl's face
closely.
Mommy said she was, but I thought she
couldn't be because no one is ever mean
to me, but then she really was.
Did you see?
What did you think was so mean?
Parel asked curiously.
She said eyes ordinary.
Cliff drew himself up to his full tiny
height, looking outraged.
Me.
I never, so mean.
What's so bad about being ordinary?
Parel opened and closed her talons
again.
Feeling her new secret prickle along her
palms.
Sounds great to me.
What?
Cliff's voice was loud enough to make
Queen Scarlet stir in her sleep, and
peril shushed him quickly.
He lowered himself into a crouch and
whispered furiously, Mommy says I'm
special.
Everyone say it.
I'd be number one most beautiful singer
Empirea one day.
Friends with every dragon in the whole
world.
Mommy thinks I can do anything and great
things at all things.
Wow, Pearl said, friends with every
dragon?
Yup, Cliff said proudly.
I gotta practice my, no, no, leave me
alone, face, or else everyone want to be
with me all the time.
Don't wish to be alone, peril advised.
Alone is awful.
Yeah, he said, probably.
Better than ordinary though.
She shook her head.
You're a weird little dragonette.
Cliff's eyes were hopeful again.
So, Maybe escape now then?
He sidled toward the edge of the throne.
Nope, no, sorry, peril said, waving him
back.
We wait for your mother, and then she
won't be queen anymore.
You know that, right?
He hummed a line of his song.
We see.
He paced around the top of the throne for
a moment before finally lying down, and
then, at last, quietly singing himself to
sleep.
Peril did not sleep.
She watched the stars creep slowly across
the night sky.
She watched a distant meteor streak
between 2 of the moons.
She watched the little prince's breath
rise and fall in small puffs of smoke.
She watched the sun slide and sprawl
lazily across the mountain peaks as it
rose, and very soon after sunrise, she
saw the shapes of a wing of dragons
flying toward them at full speed.
Ruby knows, peril guest.
Someone snuck out to warn her.
Your majesty, she whispered to the
Queen.
Ruby is coming.
Queen Scarlet was awake in an instant.
She ran her talons over her spikes and
flexed her claws.
She made sure her jewelry was all
adjusted perfectly.
For a moment.
Her talons hovered over her scarred face
as if she wanted to tear it off.
But then they dropped, and she lifted her
chin, glowering defiantly out at the
approaching dragons.
It wasn't long before they swooped in
through the opening.
Ruby, and more guards than peril could
count in a glance, but Ruby was in the
lead, landing in a run that brought her
nearly to the foot of the thrones before
the 5 guards stepped in her way.
Mommy!
Cliff cried.
He leaped up, waving his wings joyfully.
Not another step.
Queen Scarlet said, in a voice of pure
ice.
Or you know exactly, what will happen to
your precious dragonette?
Chapter 14.
Ruby stood frozen, quivering with fury.
The guards standing between her and the
Thrones had their shoulders hunched, a
kind of shame sketched in the shape of
their wings, but she wasn't glaring at
them, or even at scarlet.
The full force of her anger was directed
at peril, who stood a step behind the
prince.
If you touch him, Ruby choked out, if you
dare.
She won't, unless I tell her to, said the
queen imperiously.
But believe me, she will, the moment I
give the order.
Huh?
Peril thought.
Would I?
If I still had fire scales?
And Scarlet ordered me to burn the
prints?
What would I do?
He's so little.
And I don't kill dragons anymore, rang a
different kind of note inside Peril's
mind, familiar, and unfamiliar at the
same time.
She blinked.
Don't I?
Why not?
I knew it.
Ruby spat.
I knew you couldn't be trusted, you fire
scales monster.
I'm just following orders, Parel
protested.
She was queen first, you know, and she
didn't banish me or wish me dead, unlike
some dragons.
I don't know why you'd expect me to be
loyal to you instead.
I don't want your loyalty.
Ruby shouted, but this?
threatening innocent dragonettes, helping
her, after everything.
That's not exactly the great peaceful new
dragon you are claiming to be, is it?
I knew you were lying.
You have always been the reason for
everything that's wrong with the Sky
Kingdom.
Me?
Pearl cried, astonished.
Ruby really did hate her more than anyone
else.
Peril wasn't just being paranoid.
But why?
I just do what I'm told.
Like everyone else?
I kill Queen Scarlet's enemies.
That's all.
What did I ever do to you?
Excuse me, said Queen Scarlet from the
top of her throne.
I feel like we're getting off topic.
I'm the one who's here to take back the
kingdom.
Those eggs on the brightest night, Ruby
said. clutching the floor.
Behind her, Pearl saw several of her
guards nodding, frowning, remembering
something awful, and hating peril for it
when Pearl couldn't even remember it
herself.
Or could she?
She saw a flash of white eggshells
turning to black between her talons, here
in this very room.
What did I do?
What did Scarlet make me do?
And my sister, Ruby hissed.
Do you even remember her among the 100s
of dragons you've killed?
Peril stared at her for a long moment
racking her brain.
No, she said finally.
Who?
Ruby shrieked a long scream of rage.
So apparently that was the wrong thing to
say.
But high up on her cloud thrown, Queen
Scarlet was laughing.
Oh Ruby, she said, shaking her head.
Ruby, you empty headed princess.
Is that what you thought all these
years?
Have you been hating my poor little
champion for the one terrible thing she
actually didn't do?
A blistering hush swept over the throne
room.
Ruby was looking at her mother now
confusion starting to ebb between the
lines of fury and her expression.
What?
she said finally.
Peril didn't kill Tourmaline.
Queen Scarlet said airily.
She's not even dead, actually.
She's not?
said Ruby.
Where is she?
Let's try to focus.
Shall we?
said the queen.
I'm here for my throne.
Thank you for keeping it warm for me, but
it's time to give it back.
Mommy, Cliff called.
Mommy, I have to tell you something.
Mommy.
Grandma is kind of mean.
I know, sweetheart.
Don't worry, Ruby said.
She clenched your jaw, fixing her eyes on
her mother again.
You can't have the throne back.
You can't just saunter in here and claim
it after being gone for months.
A queen who abandons her throne has
abdicated it forever.
Oh, really?
Scarlett said.
I don't believe this question has ever
come up in the Sky Kingdom before.
So where did that convenient rule come
from?
Ruby lifted her chin, her eyes burning.
I decreed it.
As queen.
Aha.
I see, said Scarlett.
She leaned over the edge of her throne
arching her neck as a little burst of
flames curled from her nose.
Then, as queen, I un decree it.
What are you going to do about that?
I am the queen.
Ruby said firmly, and you can't challenge
me for it.
Only sisters, daughters.
Yes, yes, yes, blah, blah.
Scarlett said, waving one talent in the
air.
But my dear, you can quote rules at me
all day long, and it won't change one
particular important fact.
I have your son.
Ruby looked down at Prince Cliff again.
He waved timidly, and she made a little
gesture with her shoulders, which seemed
to be a quiet signal to sit up and look
brave, because that was what he did
next.
Peril felt a brief, wild impulse to pick
up the dragonette and throw him to the
safety of his mother's arms.
I can't do that.
That would really ruin everything for my
queen.
But is it the right thing to do?
Came that strange whisper again, as
though her mind was haunted by some other
version of herself, she poked one claw
into her ear, scratching, as if she could
drag it out and examine it.
So really?
There's only one question, said Queen
Scarlet, with all the self important glee
that had ever been mustered in Pyria.
Which would you rather have?
The throne or your dragonette?
Your majesty, said one of the dragons
behind Ruby, and it took peril a moment
to realize he was talking to Ruby, and
not Scarlet.
We can fight.
We will fight for you.
Your supporters outnumber hers and we're
more loyal.
I know, said Ruby.
But a 100,000 Skywings still couldn't
save Cliff in the next minute if my
mother sets her creature on him.
Peril felt the sting of Ruby's bitterness
from across the room.
The confirmation that once again, peril
had ruined everything for her.
I'm just being who I am.
Pearl thought.
Although, I'm not a creature anymore
actually.
I'm only pretending to be dangerous for
Queen Scarlet.
So I'm not really being my new self at
all.
But I promised to be loyal to her.
Isn't that an important part of me?
So why haven't I been?
Something was shaking at the corner's
apparel's brain, shaking and tugging and
pulling and trying to come loose, but she
couldn't sink her teeth into it.
She couldn't remember.
All right.
Ruby said to Queen Scarlet, you win.
If you promise me that Cliff will be safe
I'll give up my kingdom.
No, exploded one of Ruby's soldiers
stumbling forward.
To peril's surprise, he was not a
Skywing.
He was a mudwing.
Skinny and tired looking and spattered
with dirt.
Peril.
He said, holding out his talons
beseechingly.
What are you doing?
You don't want this.
Nobody wants this.
What would Clay think?
Peril tilted her head at him.
The thing in her mind was really flapping
now, but it still didn't have a shape or
anything useful that she could pin down.
Clay?
She echoed.
Who's that?
Chapter 15.
In the silence that fell, the only sound
was Ruby inhaling sharply.
It's a spell, she said.
What did you do to her?
She whirled towards Scarlet.
Behind her, in the huddle of Skywing
guards who are now flapping and
whispering among themselves, Pearl saw 2
of them slip out into the sky and wheel
around to fly south.
If they were up to something, she
couldn't imagine what it might be.
So she decided she didn't need to point
them out to the queen, who was, in any
case, quite busy giving Ruby an
exaggeratedly shocked expression.
Ah, didn't do anything at all.
Scarlett protested, batting her wings
airily.
Peril is my most loyal subject, just as
she always has been.
That's why she's my champion, and you are
going to be dead soon.
Peril would never just forget about clay
said Ruby.
How did you erase him from her brain?
What kind of horrible animus touched
object did you get your claws on?
Hey, I'm not under a spell, Peril
interjected.
I just don't know who you're talking
about.
I don't have a great memory.
No need to get all smoky and bothered.
On the other side of Queen Scarlet, orange
scales moved, and Perel remembered that
her father was there, listening.
Her father.
Clay is the dragon who changed you, Ruby
said, at least according to you.
He's one of the dragonettes from the
prophecy who ended the war.
Remember?
You met in the arena?
You saved his life in the kingdom of sand
when a dragon bite viper bit him.
He's.
She stopped and looked down at her
talons.
He's the only dragon who is willing to
give you a 2nd chance.
Well, there's me, Scarlett said
smoothly.
The dragon who gave you your 1st chance
and never required a second.
That's all you really need to remember.
I am the one who cares about you.
That sounded true.
And not true.
Wait.
There's turtle, peril blurted.
That was the one dragon she could think
of who'd ever been friendly to her.
He laughed at her jokes, even the ones
that peril hadn't done on purpose.
She remembered that.
And hang on.
Why would Turtle be friends with her?
If she was really Scarlet's dangerous
weapon.
He liked me with my fire scales.
But without my queen.
Who's turtle?
Her father said tensely.
He glanced up at Queen Scarlet.
You never mentioned anyone named Turtle.
Anyway, Scarlett said, we were in the
middle of a wonderfully peaceful transfer
of power.
Ruby, dear, since obviously I can't trust
you anymore.
I'm going to have to lock you up until I
figure out what to do with you.
I'm picturing some kind of grand
ceremonial execution.
Maybe to celebrate turning my arena back
into an arena the way it's supposed to
be.
But Cliff, Ruby started.
He'll be fine, Scarlett said, safe with
his loving grandmother.
For now.
At least until this whole
misunderstanding is quite cleared up, and
the balance of power is right back where
it should be.
Guards, she added commandingly.
Take Ruby to the prison in the great hall
the one where we kept Kestrel.
Lock her in, and then notify all the
cowards in this palace that it's time to
come out and swear their allegiance to
me.
There was a long, dreadful pause that
felt like someone taking a dragon wing
and stretching, stretching, stretching it
just beyond its extension.
Scarlet hissed dangerously.
Or, she said.
We can all watch this little prince burn
to death, followed by every disobedient
dragon in this room.
Do as she says.
Ruby turned to the soldiers behind her.
Whatever it takes to keep Cliff safe.
You too.
I want you to be the ones to lock me up.
But your majesty, one of them began, then
stopped as Ruby shook her head.
It's done.
She said.
Let's go.
Cliff.
I love you, little one.
Don't be scared.
You're still going to change the world
all right?
The dragonette nodded, his wings drooping
forlornly.
He looked back at peril.
Can I give mommy a hog?
He whispered.
I think she need a hug.
Pearl shook her head.
Sorry, little friend.
Cliff watched Ruby walk out of the throne
room.
Her head held high, and he did a little
shake with his wings, as if trying to
imitate her stance.
Clear out.
Scarlett snarled at the other soldiers.
I don't want to look at you anymore.
Someone muttered, the feeling is mutual.
As most of the Skywings filed out.
The one mud wing gave peril an anguished
look as he followed them.
Try to remember clay, he whispered.
Please.
Soon they were gone.
And peril was left alone with her father
Queen Scarlet, and the little prince.
Who is Clay?
She asked the queen.
Should I remember him?
Do you?
Scarlett shrugged.
Barely.
He's some nobody who thinks he's a hero.
Don't worry about it.
They seemed really sure that I knew him.
Peril said slowly.
Ruby said I saved his life.
But I don't remember ever saving anyone's
life.
I would definitely remember that.
Wouldn't I?
Maybe she's got you confused with some
other dragon, Scarlett said.
This conversation is ever so boring.
I'm going to tour the palace to see what
other damage my dreadful daughter has
done.
Vermilion.
The red dragon poked his head in the door
immediately, as if he'd been hovering a
claw step away.
Yes?
Are my prisoner towers still in place at
least?
Scarlett demanded.
Er, he said.
I'll take it, that's a no, she said.
She let out an enormous, aggrieved sigh.
Those took ages to build, and they were
genius.
I'm going to have to kill at least 7
disloyal traitors to cheer myself up.
Fine.
You too.
She barked at peril and chameleon.
Take this dragonette to the tallest spire
of my palace and stick him on the highest
ledge you can find.
Wait.
Lizard, can you fly yet?
My name isn't Lizard, is Cliff, said the
prince boldly.
And...
Not so much.
I practice lots, but I falled lots too.
Good, said the queen.
As long as he can't fly away, he'll be
stuck up there.
Keep an eye on him until I get back.
She swept out of the throne room with
Vermilion. leaving peril with a
bewildering impression that the queen had
just run away from an awkward
conversation.
Chameleon picked up Prince Cliff and
perched him on his back.
Hold on tight, he said.
The prince obligingly threw his arms and
wings around Chameleon's neck and buried
his face.
They flew out the open wall and soared in
a circle for a moment, assessing the
palace.
Peril realized that the tallest spire she
could see was the chimney for the
crematorium, a long, long tower that
carried the smoke of burning bodies as
high and far away from the rest of the
palace as possible.
But sitting on top of it, would put them
right in the middle of the smoke and the
smells, and Perel had a feeling that
might be a little traumatizing for Cliff
plus not much fun for her and Chameleon
either.
So instead, she chose the 2nd tallest
spire.
A lookout for guards near the outer wall
of the palace.
At the top of the tower was a small
pavilion, with room for 5 or 6 dragons to
fit comfortably.
A shallow hole in the floor was intended
as a fire pit, for heating the tower when
it was cold, or for cooking prey.
The walls were open on all sides, but the
position of the tower was clearly
directed west to watch for attacks from
ice wings or sand wings.
Cliff slid off Chameleon's back and began
to prowl around the pavilion.
There's no things to play with here, he
complained.
Use your imagination, Chameleon said
unsympathetically.
The prince snorted, flicked his tail at
the fire pit, and curled up in a small
ball, with his wings flopped out to
either side.
If his intention was to make a point by
sulking, it didn't last long, because he
was asleep a few minutes later.
Peril sat at the edge of the tower and
looked down at the Sky Palace.
It still seemed very quiet.
Usually there were dragons flying from
tower to tower, or coming in with reports
or sailing out with messages.
Usually the palace fluttered with
activity, and wing beats filled the air.
But not today.
Today, an eerie stillness suffused the
clouds.
The mountain peaks looked frozen in
time.
Where was everyone?
A light rain began to fall?
Peril glanced up and saw darker storm
clouds rolling in, thickening the fog
around the palace spires.
The daylight had a smoky green tinge to
it, as if the sky, too, knew that
something was wrong.
Something was unbalanced in the world
below.
Even the sky rejects the old queen, she
thought.
The sky itself chooses Ruby.
She shook out her wings, trying to
dislodge the unfaithful thought.
How are you feeling, daughter?
Chameleon asked.
Pearl glanced at him.
Wondering whether she should call him
sore while he was a Sky Wing, or if it
was all right to keep just one name in
her head for him.
He was fiddling with a sheath on his
chest, as though he were trying to avoid
her eyes.
Great, peril said.
She stretched her wings, her safe
touchable wings, and thought for a moment
was she still feeling great?
She'd been so happy yesterday, but the
pretending, and the hatred from Ruby, and
Cliff's drooping wings, and this weird
feeling of holes in her brain.
It was all kind of making her happiness
flicker and dim.
A little worried, she admitted.
Don't listen to those other dragons, said
Chameleon.
You're essentially the 2nd in command of
this palace.
I wish I'd had that much power in my
tribe.
I'd have made everybody regret every
moment of disrespect, every mocking laugh
and disgusted whisper.
Why were they mocking you?
Pearl asked.
I thought rain wings were all mellow and
calm and friendly, and sleepy all the
time.
Ha!
Chameleon said bitterly.
As long as you aren't too different
sure.
But I had the one problem the tribe
couldn't understand.
I can't change my scales.
You saw my rain wing color.
When I'm a rain wing?
I'm stuck that way.
The same green all the time.
No camouflage, no flamboyant emotional
outbursts, no self absorbed displays of
clever special effects.
I could never play their little rain wing
games.
Oh, peril said.
Weren't there any other rain wings like
you?
Not in living memory, he said.
The healers guessed that it was because
of my sleep problem.
As myself, I can never sleep for longer
than a few minutes at a time, an hour at
most.
They thought it affected my scale
shifting abilities.
But knowing that didn't help.
Everyone still teased me, and then
whispered about me.
And then avoided me.
Finally, the queen banished me, saying I
was making everyone uncomfortable, and
perhaps there was a better tribe for me
outside the rainforest somewhere.
Ouch, peril said.
That seems really unfair to throw you out
for something you couldn't control?
Exactly, he said.
He brooded for a moment, staring down at
the fog with hooded eyes.
Then he let out a bark of laughter that
made Prince Cliff shiver in his sleep.
The joke's on them though, isn't it?
What I can do now?
My shape shifting power.
It's far more magnificent camouflage than
anything a mere rain wing could
accomplish.
He held out its orange talons to admire
humming softly with pride.
Peril studied him out of the corner of
her eye, wishing she could think of a
clever sideways way to find out what she
wanted to know, but that wasn't her
clever or sideways.
How does it work?
She finally asked.
Flying at the question directly was the
only way she could think up to attack
it.
How did you get your shape shifting
power?
He flicked his tail and looked at her
thoughtfully.
Peril tried to arrange her face to look
deeply, immensely trustworthy.
Not even Scarlet knows this.
He whispered.
He glanced back at the prince, who was
fast asleep.
A quiver of excitement ran through peril
a secret.
She never got to be the only dragon who
knew a secret.
Oh.
I forgot to tell Queen Scarlet about the
sea wings having an animus.
Okay, later, I'll have to remember next
time I see her.
You can tell me, she whispered back.
There's no one I would tell anyway.
Not even Queen Scarlet.
He asked.
She shook her head.
You're my father, she said.
You changed my scales, and made me safe
and normal.
My loyalty is to you first, her second.
Hmm, he said.
Very interesting.
You have a stronger personality than most
um, most dragons I've met.
She wondered what he'd been about to
say.
Most what?
That is one of the many things most
dragons don't like about me, she
admitted.
I like it. he said.
It's something we have in common.
He touched the metal sheath around his
chest, fiddling with the lock for a
moment before it clicked open.
Inside, the sheath were 2 things, a small
pouch that seemed to be full of coins or
jewelry, and a scroll wrapped in a black
leather binding.
Chameleon laid them carefully on the
stone between him and peril, shifting so
their backs were to cliff, and spreading
his wings, so the prince wouldn't see the
objects if he woke up.
He tapped the pouch first.
In here are my other shapes.
Each piece enchanted with someone new.
All my beautiful faces.
I can take on and off whenever I want
to.
I have one for each tribe.
You've met one of them before, actually.
I have?
Pearl said, her scales prickling.
Sirius, the ice wing, he said.
Remember him?
Queen Scarlet's spy in the talons of
peace?
Perfect, because there are so few ice
wings in the talons, that they never
figured out how little I knew, or that
I've never been to the ice kingdom.
I made him cold and calculating and not
much of a talker.
That's when you 1st found out about me.
Peril realized.
That conversation about Kestrel.
You were standing right in front of me.
Yes, he said.
Scarlet had sent me to find out if the
talons knew where those dragonettes went
the ones who stole her prisoner?
They didn't, of course.
The talons have always been remarkably
useless, in my opinion.
Apart from gathering the dragonettes of
the prophecy, and giving serious excuses
to practice killing.
He spoke casually.
But his words sent a chill down Peril's
spine.
He was looking for Moon, and Kibli, and
Winter.
Would he have killed them if he found
them?
Would I kill them now?
If Queen Scarlet told me to?
She frowned at her claws, hearing that
echo in her head again.
I don't kill dragons anymore.
But why?
But why, but why?
And then I followed you.
Chameleon went on without noticing her
distraction, he touched the pouch again
fondly.
In my night wing form.
That one's my favorite.
I call myself Shapeshifter.
Isn't that a perfect nightwing name?
A bit on the nose?
Peril offered.
Exactly, he said.
Like all night wing names.
I'm quite proud of that shape.
And then you found me, she said.
But I still don't understand how you make
these shapes at all.
Now he touched the scroll carefully
reverently.
This, he whispered.
It's the strongest magic in the world.
He undid the binding, and slowly rolled
the scroll open.
As he did, Peril could see that the 1st
3rd of the scroll had riding on it, while
the rest of the scroll was blank.
I've never read the whole thing, he
said.
I still don't really like reading.
I had to find someone to teach me to read
so I could understand the scroll in the
1st place, but then, I only had to read
the beginning to realize what it could
do.
Chameleon rolled it to the end, where it
looked like some of the scroll had been
torn out.
And then I had to learn how to write, he
added wryly.
That was frustrating.
Peril remembered Osprey teaching her how
to read and write, although she couldn't
hold a scroll or any writing instrument
so it didn't do her very much good.
She could read street signs and scrape
out messages in the sand if necessary.
That was about it.
Oh, she realized.
That can all be different now.
Without fire scales, I could read every
scroll in the world if I want to.
That cheered her up quite a lot.
She leaned toward the scroll, giving her
father her eager attention.
I write my enchantment here, Chameleon
said, brushing the paper with his claw.
I describe the shape I want to shift into
riding the magic into that piece of paper
then I tear off that part of the scroll
and hide it in something, usually an item
of jewelry, like a necklace or bracelet.
Or an ear, Pearl said.
Suddenly remembering a disembodied head
changing shape in front of her.
Where was that?
Uh, yes, he said.
Only that once, though.
I don't use this very often.
I've told Queen Scarlet that I have a
limited animus power to transform dragons
and that it's dangerous for me to do it
very much.
I don't want her to know about the
scroll.
Why not?
Peril asked.
He looked at her in alarm, and she
quickly added, don't worry, I still won't
tell her.
But why would you help her as much as you
do and not tell her everything.
If she knew about this.
He said.
She would take it away from me.
He started to roll up the scroll again
and once she didn't need me anymore.
She would probably kill me.
Besides, I want to be in charge of what
this scroll does.
It's mine.
If Scarlet knew I had unlimited power.
She'd make me do much more terrible
things than anything I've done so far.
He stopped and looked at peril.
I'm not an evil dragon peril.
I like the security of having a queen who
will pay me handsomely for my services
and I love the luxury of so much
treasure.
But I'm not going to give anyone all this
power, especially not Queen Scarlet.
I am much too smart for that.
Oh, Pearl said.
Her mind was spinning a little.
Was he implying that peril wasn't that
smart?
Would she have given Scarlet that scroll
without even thinking about it?
Wasn't that what loyalty was about?
And if he didn't trust Scarlet
completely?
Why help her at all?
Have you done anything else with a
scroll?
she asked.
I mean, Couldn't you use it to make your
own treasure somehow, instead of waiting
for Scarlet to pay you?
Chameleon opened his mouth, closed it, and
blinked at her for a moment.
I suppose I could, he said slowly.
Scarlet hired me before I'd gotten very
far with using the scroll.
She caught me transforming, and gave me
the option of explaining how I did it, or
coming to work for her.
I chose option B, obviously, and I
haven't wanted to do anything risky that
she might find out about.
I have a very nice life, though.
He said quickly, and so can you.
Once this kingdom is all sorted out, we'll
be her right claw dragons, and we'll be
together.
Maybe you can help me come up with clever
uses for the scroll.
It'll be nice to have family at last.
Yes, peril agreed.
Family.
That sounded amazing, actually.
She'd barely had a chance to meet Kestrel
before her mother died.
And if there were any other dragons
related to her in the Sky Palace, they'd
never introduced themselves.
But something new was starting to bother
her.
Wait, she said, if you're the one who's
been helping Queen Scarlet all along.
Does that mean you're the one who put
Kinkaju in the hospital?
Chameleon stared at her for a long
moment.
The muscles in his jaw tensing and moving
like little snakes crawling over one
another.
He picked up the scroll and the pouch
locking them back in his chest sheath
before answering.
You mean that rain wing who was traveling
with the ice wing prince?
He said finally.
She's not dead.
You actually were trying to kill her?
Pearl said, appalled.
Really?
She's just a dragonette.
She's a rain wing, he hissed.
She'd laugh at me just as much as any of
her tribe, if she'd met me before I found
my power.
Wow, Peril said.
She tried to picture the tiny, brightly
colored rain wing.
I've never met anyone who hated rain
wings before.
They're so inoffensive.
It's like hating caterpillars.
I'm not terribly fond of caterpillars
either.
Chameleon observed.
Nasty crawly things.
Of all dragons, peril thought.
I should be the one who can understand
fury and vengeance and wanting to lash
out whenever someone hurts me.
He's my father.
And she's a dragonette.
I don't even know.
I should be on his side.
But still, it seemed as brutal and
unnecessary as the idea of hurting the
little Sky Wing Prince.
She glanced over her shoulder at Cliff, or
rather, at the space where Cliff used to
be, she whirled around, her eyes tearing
apart the empty pavilion, but there was
no mistake.
The Skywing Prince, was gone.
Chapter 16.
Cliff?
Peril cried.
Cliff.
Chameleon flared his wings with a
horrified expression.
Where did he go?
Peril ran to the opposite edge of the
tower.
Had he rolled off in his sleep?
It was a long, long way down.
Wouldn't he have woken up and cried out?
Wouldn't they have heard him?
She frantically searched the slick wet
rocks and rooftops below for a broken red
figure.
And then, through a break in the fog, she
saw a tiny flapping shape struggling in
the rain.
He can fly, she cried.
That little liar, Chameleon yelled, after
him.
He leaped from the tower and plummeted
toward the dragonette.
You know, Peril called, catching up to
him.
I thought I remembered that Skywing
Dragonettes could fly pretty young.
That's so funny that Scarlet didn't know
that because she avoids dragonettes like
the plague.
Rain pelted her wings and snout and
scales, falling harder and harder every
moment.
Shut up and catch him.
Chameleon shouted.
Nearly drowned out by a crack of
thunder.
Or we lose the palace, and Scarlet kills
us both.
She wouldn't dare, Parel thought.
Well, all right.
She might dare, but she can't.
Not if I take off this necklace and use
my fire scales again.
The locket thumped against her chest, and
Perel realized it must have a scrap of
that scroll inside of it, enchanted to
make her normal.
She hadn't seen her father write it.
In fact, it had been all ready for her, so
he must have written it before they even
met.
Because he loves me.
Because he understood what it's like to
be different, and he predicted my wish to
be normal.
There was something though.
Something that still felt wrong.
Cliff looked over his shoulder and saw
the 2 dragons hurtling toward him.
With a terrified squeak, he flung himself
through the nearest window and
disappeared.
Worse luck, it was a window big enough
for a year old dragonette, but too small
for peril or her father's sky wing
shape.
Chameleon roared in frustration.
You know the palace, he shouted at
peril.
How do we get in there?
He thumped the stone wall with his tail.
Peril wiped rain from her eyes and looked
around.
The window was in a covered rampart that
led to the central keep of the palace, the
keep where the throne room, the great
hall, and Ruby's prison were.
Come on, she said, beating her wings.
One option was going through the open
wall of the throne room, but if Queen
Scarlet was in there, things would get
ugly fast.
A better choice was to fly to the top of
the keep and enter through the open roof
like she had done once to rescue
Kestrel.
She shook her head hard.
Who did I do that with?
Why is it all fuzzy?
As they soared up the cliffside, peril
had a dizzying sense of déjà vu, a
feeling of wild freedom, terror, and hope
that didn't match the current situation
at all.
She glanced behind her and realized she
was expecting to see someone other than
her father.
Who?
A moment later, they reached the top and
dove through the hole into the great hall
which was as eerie and deserted as the
rest of the palace, Peril saw one or 2
snouts poke out curiously at the sound of
her wing beats, and then vanish in a
hurry.
A guard stood listlessly by the throne
room, but she didn't even look up as
peril flew by.
Down at the bottom of the hall.
Ruby was trapped below a grate of metal
bars in the lowliest prison Scarlet had
been able to come up with for her least
favorite prisoners.
I guess someone fixed the great, Pearl
thought, remembering her own claws
burning through those very bars.
Two sky wings stood beside the grate
looking less like guards and more like
guardians.
They were staring up at the commotion of
peril and chameleon diving toward them
and so they didn't see the small red
shape that darted into the room from a
hall behind them.
Prince Cliff reached the prison bars
before peril did.
He threw himself on top of the grate and
reached through, clasping one of his
mother's talons in both of his.
Cliff, Ruby cried.
Get back.
And suddenly, a moment before peril
touched down on the stone floor, Ruby
came surging out of her cell, flinging
aside the crisscrossed bars as if they
were nothing.
As if it wasn't actually locked, or never
really fixed at all.
That's it, peril thought.
Ruby wouldn't have wanted a prison like
that anyway.
And the Skywings who locked her in were
loyal to her.
They only pretended to do it, enough to
make Scarlet believe it.
She isn't giving up.
She's not the mouse her mother thinks she
is.
What else is Scarlet wrong about?
The 2 guards threw their wings open
facing peril in battle positions as Ruby
cleared the cell in one leap and called
her son up in her arms.
I knew you could do it, she said to him
you clever, clever, clever little
moonbeam.
I'm not a moonbeam, he protested
snuggling into her chest.
Today, I'm a super secret self agent
flyer, hero of the world.
Yes, you are, she said.
A deafening roar suddenly shook the
entire hall.
Peril pressed her talons over her ears
unconsciously trying to make herself as
small as possible.
This was a familiar war.
A roar that always heralded shouting
scorn, and severe punishments.
Queen Scarlet could never hit her, of
course, but she'd found plenty of other
ways to make peril's life miserable.
The sky wing queen seemed to arrive from
everywhere at once, her flapping orange
wings filling peril's whole field of
vision.
No, Scarlet shrieked.
Hurtling past the guards and slamming
straight into Ruby and Cliff.
The 3 of them tumbled and crashed into
the back wall, and before Ruby could
stand up again, Scarlet grabbed her neck
and pinned her against the stone.
Cliff scrambled under his mother's wing
and she tightened it around him, glaring
at Scarlet.
You think you're so smart, pathetic
daughter, Scarlet hissed.
But your love for this dragonette is a
weakness.
After I kill you.
Do you want to know what I'm going to do
to him?
I'm going to make him fear me.
I'm going to make him so loyal to me that
he'll forget your name.
He'll obey my every command.
Will not, Cliff said defiantly.
Scarlet ignored him.
I'll use him, until he becomes a dragon
you wouldn't recognize.
By the time I'm done with him, he'd kill
you with his own talons if I tell him
to.
Will not, Cliff said again.
Sounding both outraged and scared.
Would never.
He'll be my adorable little weapon. said
Scarlet, and he'll forget all about you.
I will be his everything.
I'm the only one who cares about you.
No one will ever love you except me.
You'll always be a monster to everyone
else.
Scarlet's words rang louder and louder in
peril's head, what she was describing.
That's what she did to me.
She made me obedient.
She made me loyal to her.
She made me think I had no choice.
But I do.
Stop, peril shouted.
She stepped forward.
And for a moment, the guards wavered, as
if wondering whether this was the right
moment to sacrifice themselves on her
burning scales.
She stepped forward again, and they
parted before her, leaving her a clear
path to the tangle of royal family
members.
Queen Scarlet glowered at peril with
narrow yellow eyes.
What did you say?
I won't let you hurt Cliff, Pearl said.
I won't let you do any of that to him
either.
It's not right.
He's not your toy.
And if you can't earn a dragon's loyalty
by being a good queen, then you don't
deserve it at all.
She reached for the black chain around
her neck and saw Scarlet's eyes widened.
No, Chameleon cried.
Don't take that off.
Three moons.
I am under a spell.
It hit peril with the force of a 1000
sons.
There's something else in the
enchantment.
Ruby was right.
My father betrayed me.
Peril ripped the necklace over her head
and dropped it, just as the metal began
to sizzle.
Chapter 17.
Everything came rushing back.
Clay, clay, clay, clay.
Peril's heart sang.
How could she have forgotten about him?
How could any spell do that?
She looked around at the circle of
watching Skywings, orange and red heads
peering over the balconies and wing beats
bringing in more.
Ruby and Cliff trapped under Scarlet's
claws, the guards watching her warily.
Is this what I become without him?
I go right back to being a monster?
She held out her talons.
Wisps of smoke were starting to rise from
them again.
The fire skills aren't what make me
dangerous.
Even without them.
I was as bad as ever, because I was
willing to follow her.
Pearl lowered her claws and advanced on
Scarlet.
You stay away from me, Scarlet Hissed.
Get back.
Do you hear me?
I'm your queen, remember?
You are my champion.
You do what I tell you to do.
Not anymore.
Peril said.
She reached toward the scarred ex queen
and Scarlet leaped off Ruby with a
shriek.
Her orange wings flailed in the air as
she backed away from peril.
Have you ever wondered what it felt
like?
Peril said.
What you made me do to all those
dragons?
Because it's over now.
You are the last dragon I will ever
kill.
Wait, Ruby said suddenly.
Peril, stop.
Stop.
Scarlet was so close.
And Perel finally had the courage to do
what she should have done a long time ago
and this was the right moment with
everyone watching to cheer her on.
But Ruby was her new queen.
And if Pearl wanted to prove she could be
trusted, if she could ever be trusted
again.
She should start by listening to her.
She stopped.
Keeping her wings spread so Scarlet
couldn't escape.
Yes, Your Majesty, she said to Ruby.
There was a stunned little pause, dappled
with growls and hisses from Scarlet, and
then Ruby collected herself.
Don't kill her, Ruby said.
You shouldn't have to.
This is my fight.
She gently moved Cliff behind her, tucking
him back against the wall, and then stood
up tall.
Queen Scarlet of the Sky Wings, I hereby
challenge you to a duel for throne and
kingdom.
A gasp scattered around the hall like
leaves in a windstorm.
You don't have to do that, said one of
the nearby guards, very bravely peril
thought.
It meant he'd be the 1st one in flames if
Scarlet ended up winning.
You are the queen we want, Queen Ruby.
Just order us to kill her for you.
Or me, Parel offered.
Order me to do it.
Ruby shook her head.
I want to take my throne the right way.
The way I should have done before.
If I hadn't been such a coward.
I'm going to follow Skywing tradition, and
when I win, no one will be able to
question my position anymore.
Scarlet chuckled.
Smoke billowing from her snout.
When you win.
How thrillingly hilarious.
After all the challengers I've killed, you
think you stand any chance at all?
My mousey daughter, who can barely speak
in a room with more than 2 other dragons
in it.
Let's find out, Ruby said, flexing her
claws.
Maybe I'm not who you think I am.
Queen Scarlet started to laugh.
She laughed and laughed so much that
peril was extremely tempted to set her on
fire just to shut her up.
Very well.
She cried finally.
I accept your challenge.
Come at me, daughter.
Peril stepped aside, so the 2 dragons
could face each other.
Ruby met Pearl's eyes, and something
entirely new passed between them.
I'll protect Cliff, Pearl said to her.
No matter what happens.
Thank you, said Ruby.
That was all she needed to say.
That was more, peril suspected, than
Scarlet had ever said to either of them.
To the arena then.
Scarlett growled.
Ruby shook her head.
It's full of wounded soldiers and healing
supplies.
Choose somewhere else.
Scarlet looked momentarily unsettled, but
recovered quickly.
She glanced around at the gathering crowd
and peril wondered if she'd choose to
fight right here in the great hall.
And then maybe Ruby could accidentally
throw her right into me, and I could
accidentally catch her, and whoosh, no
more scarlet.
Perhaps the same thought occurred to
Scarlet, because she nodded at the open
roof and said, up there.
The 2 sky wing queens took off 1st
soaring toward the sky.
And then what seemed to be the entire
palace lifted off to follow them, dragons
jostling for airspace as they competed
for a ringside seat at the fight.
Peril couldn't fly through a crowd like
that, not without seriously hurting
someone.
She backed up against the wall next to
Cliff.
Hello, he said.
I think today, I'mma be a warrior
champion, and go swish, swish with my
claws, and whar with my mouth, and save
mommy.
Maybe we should stay down here.
Peril said.
She didn't want poor little Cliff to have
to watch his mother die if everything
went wrong and Ruby lost.
It probably wouldn't be the greatest
feeling to watch his mother kill his
grandmother either, even though he had
experienced Scarlet's evil firsthand.
No!
Cliff shrieked at her. making her jump.
I want to see it.
Three moons calm down, Peril said.
I just don't want you to get upset, and
bites can be very, um, upsetting.
I won't get upset, Cliff shouted.
I want to see mommy kill grandma.
Carol had to stifle a giggle.
All right, you bloodthirsty little
barbarian, she said.
Let's wait until there's space and up
we'll go.
He gave her a sideways look.
You different now?
Yes, Pearl said.
I'm better now.
Not a bad guy?
he said.
Well, I hope I'm not a bad guy, Pearl
said.
I was under a spell before.
Hmm, said Cliff.
A spell.
He scampered over and picked out the
necklace.
From this?
Right, peril said.
She took the necklace and clasped it
between her claws, letting it melt into a
blackened hunk of metal.
I wasn't thinking for myself.
I was thinking what someone else wanted
me to think.
But I'm all right now.
She hesitated.
Now that I'm thinking what Clay wants me
to think.
What if he really was gone from my life?
What would I be like then?
Which reminded her?
She turned to scan the hall, but
Chameleon had flown off along with
everyone else.
There seemed to be a clear enough path to
the roof now.
We can go up, Perl said.
Stay close to me, but don't touch me.
Why not?
Cliff asked, immediately reaching for her
tail.
She flicked it out of his reach, because
I'm very hot and you'll get burned.
Oh, he scoffed.
I'm not afraid of me burned.
I am, peril said.
Be careful, and don't get close to mommy
either.
She's very busy right now, so you need to
leave her alone.
Until she wins, Cliff sang, vaulting into
the air.
If she wins, peril thought, as they flew
up and out into the driving rain.
What happens to Cliff if she doesn't?
The roof of the keep led out onto a rocky
mountaintop with dizzying views of peaks
all around them.
Small tufts of fierce little scrub
brushes clung to the dirt here and there
but mostly it was all rocks, long
overlapping shelves of gray rock, and
lumps of boulders like giant stone eggs.
Scarlet and ruby were grappling in the
center of a crowd of dragons.
Some were standing on the rocks, and many
were hovering in the air, so they could
watch, but also make a quick escape if
necessary.
The sky kingdom is going to be a mess if
Scarlet wins, Peril thought.
She's going to want to kill at least half
the dragons here for disloyalty.
Cliff wobbled over to a boulder that was
taller than the others, with a view of
the battlefield.
The dragons on it saw him and peril
coming and cleared off quickly.
As her talons landed on the slippery, wet
rock, peril could see that already the
battle was not going well for Ruby, a
long slash down her neck, and another
across her back were bleeding, turning
the puddles thick and red around her
talons.
The venom scarred side of Scarlet's face
always looked as if it were melting, but
the rain slithering off it now made it
even worse.
The triumphant Lear didn't help either.
She looked absolutely terrifying, and a
little bit insane.
Scarlet whirled around and cracked her
tail across Ruby's snout.
Ruby let out a yelp of pain and jumped
back, blinking blood and rain out of her
eyes.
She tried slashing at Scarlet's nearest
wing, but missed, stumbling on the slick
rocks.
Cliff edged a little closer to peril's
heat.
Mommy, he whispered.
This poor little dragonette.
What do I do if Ruby loses?
Maybe then I can kill Scarlet myself.
I doubt anyone would try to stop me.
But then there'd be no one left to be
queen of the Sky Wings, since Scarlet
brilliantly disposed of all her airs.
A jolt ran through her.
What about tourmaline?
If Scarlet was telling the truth
Tourmaline was still alive somewhere, and
a backup air would probably be fairly
useful right about now.
Where could tourmaline be?
Ruby would know if her sister were in any
of the usual Sky Wing prisons.
But peril already knew.
She could have guessed from the moment
she ripped off the necklace.
Nobody knew where Tourmaline was, because
Tourmaline wasn't herself anymore.
Like peril, she must have been enchanted
by chameleon.
She could be anybody now.
Which meant that only Chameleon and
Scarlet would be able to identify her.
Peril narrowed her eyes, searching the
audience of Skywings.
One thing about Chameleon's disguise as
sore, he blended right into the rest of
the tribe.
It took her several minutes to spot him
and then she only did because she caught
his eyes watching her instead of the
fight.
She pointed at him, and then at the rock
beside her.
Come here, right now.
He wavered for a moment, then flapped
down to land, she noticed, in a way that
kept Cliff between him and her.
Oh, very brave, father, hiding behind a
dragonette, classy.
I was thinking, he said quickly, before
she could speak.
Perhaps we should try a different
enchantment.
Maybe you don't even want to be a Sky
Wing anymore.
We could both be mudwings.
In fact, I could do that right now, and
we could fly away from here together.
What do you think?
I hear the Mud Kingdom is tolerable.
We could start a new life together.
Very far away from whoever wins this
fight.
I don't want a new life, Pearl said
bristling.
I want my own life, with all my memories
intact, thank you very much.
You could word the enchantment yourself
he said desperately, or slyly.
Parel wasn't sure.
She found him hard to read, even when he
wasn't drowned out by thunder and rain.
We could, no, peril said.
I'm never letting you change me again.
I can't trust you.
He wilted a little, but she was pretty
far from feeling sorry for him.
Now tell me what you did to Tourmaline
she added.
Me?
he said.
Tourmaline.
I don't.
Well, I can't even...
Was there?
Who's that?
Very amusing, she said.
Almost as amusing as your ears on fire
would be.
All right, all right, yes, I changed her
he said.
She was getting too ambitious.
Scarlet wanted her out of the way, but
not dead.
She couldn't get rid of all her heirs, a
kingdom without any heirs is in perpetual
danger.
I think all the queens learned that from
what happened to the mud wings a couple
of centuries ago.
So Tourmaline is still available if
Scarlet ever needs her.
She just doesn't know it herself.
He trailed off, regarding the battling
dragons and rubbing his snout worriedly.
You shouldn't do that, peril burst out.
You can't just take away a dragon's
memory.
Turn them into someone completely new.
That's horrible.
I thought becoming someone completely new
was exactly what you wanted, he said
ruffled.
I like being different dragons.
Yes, but you still have your memory when
you do that, Pearl said.
You know who you are underneath.
Tourmaline, I assume, does not.
True, he said.
But she was safer that way.
Otherwise, she would have challenged
Scarlet and wound up dead before she
turned 11.
Pearl shook her head.
Scattering the cloud of steam that was
forming around her, as raindrops hit her
fiery scales.
You're like 18,000 different kinds of
untrustworthy.
Are you even really my father?
Yes, he said firmly.
Kestrel didn't know who I was.
She thought I was assigned to partner
with her.
But I knew her.
I am unquestionably your father.
Wonderful, Pearl said.
Such fantastic news.
So where is Tourmaline?
Is she here now?
He hesitated, and then nodded.
At the same moment, Ruby let out another
cry of pain, a scarlet slammed into her
chest, knocking her off her feet.
Lightning cracked the sky in half above
the fighting dragons, illuminating
Scarlet's gloating face as she advanced
on her daughter.
Why isn't mommy fighting better?
Cliff cried.
Pearl looked down at Cliff's anguished
face.
You know what?
She said to Chameleon.
Fine.
Keep your secret.
It doesn't matter who Tremaline is
because Ruby has to win this fight.
For the entire Skywing tribe, but mostly
for Cliff.
Oh, Chameleon said.
She can't.
Peril stared at him.
Yes, she can.
Of course she can.
What are you talking about?
Uh, nothing, he said.
You're right, of course you can.
Did you do something?
Pearl asked.
Did you do something to Ruby like you did
to me?
Below them, Ruby leaped up and sliced one
claw across Scarlet's throat, but Scarlet
caught her arm and kicked Ruby back into
a boulder.
Ruby struggled back to her feet, her
wings drooping and heavy with rain.
Well, he said, even if I did, it's not
working anyway.
This shouldn't be able to happen at all.
So really, anything could happen next.
It's basically like I didn't do
anything.
What did you do?
Pearl's wings flared open, scattering
warm raindrops all over cliff.
Nightmare possibilities were flashing
through her head.
He could have done anything to Ruby with
that scroll.
He could have enchanted her to fall
asleep whenever Scarlet hit her.
He could have enchanted her to go blind
whenever she tried to hit Scarlet.
He could have enchanted her to lose any
challenge battle with Scarlet.
But he'd need a thing to enchant.
That's how animus magic works, peril
remembered.
Something with room for a piece of scroll
inside.
She stared wildly down at the battling
queens, trying to spot something on Ruby
that might be hiding an animus touched
scrap of scroll.
There.
Ruby had one small earring that she
always seemed to be wearing.
Peril had never seen her without it.
A teardrop shaped pendant hung from it
studded with rubies, and just big enough
to open and fit a piece of paper inside.
Wait here, Pearl said to Cliff.
But, he protested as she lifted off.
But you said not to interrupt mommy.
Parel dove at the wrestling sky wings
just as Scarlet was about to stamp her
talons down on Ruby's face, but she must
have heard something over the wind and
thunder, because she looked up at the
last moment, saw peril hurtling toward
them, and leaped backward instead.
Ruby scrambled up and turned to look at
peril too.
Don't interfere.
She gasped.
Her heaving sides slick with blood and
rain.
I have to win this myself.
Peril skidded to a stop in front of her.
I know, but it's not a fair fight right
now.
Don't move.
She reached out and crushed the dangling
earring pendant between 2 of her claws.
The metal exterior melted first, caving
in, and Peril called a glimpse of
something white inside before it crumbled
into black ash, and then the whole
pendant dropped to the ground.
Why did you do that?
Ruby cried.
That was a present from my sister, from, I
have a...
She stopped.
Her talons moving slowly to her head, as
if a glacier were trying to climb out her
eye sockets.
Ruby's dark red scales glimmered once
twice, and then faded softly into dark
orange instead.
Her horns curved inward, and her snout
lengthened slightly, and her whole body
seemed to get thicker and stronger.
Not only that, but all her wounds
vanished.
What in the sun?
Ruby trailed off, blinking at her newly
sharp talons.
Peril was surprised too.
She hadn't expected Ruby to be something
different underneath.
I'm sorry, she stammered.
You were under a spell too.
All I know is that it was enchanted to
stop you from winning this battle, and I
thought that wasn't fair.
Tourmaline?
Vermilion said, stepping out of the crowd
of gawking sky wings.
But aren't you dead?
Not yet, said Scarlet, but she will be
soon.
She shot a glare at peril.
This is Tourmaline?
Pearl cried.
But if I'm Tourmaline, said the
transformed queen, then where, or who, is
Ruby?
Chapter 18.
A new flash of greenish lightning
illuminated the horrible crooked grin on
the old queen's face.
There is no ruby, Scarlett said with
malicious delight.
I made her up.
It turns out, when you're the queen, no
one questions which dragons you claim as
daughters, I invented Ruby completely
exactly the way I wanted her.
After all, I've always been disappointed
in the daughters I actually had.
If she was hoping for a more devastated
reaction, she must have been
disappointed.
Tourmaline only narrowed her eyes at her
mother, and lifted her chin, with an
expression that looked exactly like one
of Queen Ruby's, Your Majesty, Peril said
to Ruby Tourmaline, my advice is to
finish killing Scarlet, and then figure
this out.
I have someone who can answer all your
questions when you're done.
Tourmaline set her jaw.
Good idea.
She launched herself at Scarlet with
startling speed. suddenly full of all the
ferocity and danger that peril had
expected before.
With 2 quick slashes, she ripped into one
of Scarlet's wings, and then sank her
claws into Scarlet's shoulders, and her
teeth into Scarlet's neck.
Another heavy roll of thunder rumbled
over their shrieks.
Peril backed away from the fight
cautiously working her way to the boulder
where Cliff was waiting.
Below the thunder and dragon roars.
She caught some of the conversations
running through the crowd.
But who is that?
Where did Ruby go?
Did peril do something to her?
Doesn't matter.
She's winning now, isn't she?
I remember Tourmaline.
I thought the queen had her killed a long
time ago.
How does a dragon just change like that?
Who did that magic?
We don't have any animus dragons in the
Skywing tribe?
Wait, I liked Ruby.
Can we get Ruby back?
Peril climbed back up onto the boulder
and found dismayed faces on both
chameleon and cliff.
I wish you hadn't done that, Chameleon
said.
So publicly too.
It's going to raise a lot of questions.
And I'm afraid it'll be really awkward
for me around here if you start pointing
talons.
Oh, I'm sorry, Pearl said.
You're right.
I should have let Ruby die, so you
wouldn't have to feel awkward.
Where's mommy?
Cliff asked, reaching out his little
talons?
You said you not a bad guy.
You said that.
Where did you put her?
He started to cry.
I want mommy back.
Now peril really did feel sorry.
She wished desperately that she could hug
him, or at least take one of his talons
in hers, the way Clay did when he was
comforting someone.
It's all right, little prince.
She said, crouching to look him in the
eyes.
She has to look like that to win this
fight, but she's still your mother.
She's just bigger and tougher and a
different color, that's all.
She still loves you the same.
Well, she might not, said Chameleon.
That was a whole other personality I
built for her, with a lot of false
memories in it.
She may feel differently about everyone
now, even him.
Cliff buried his face in his talons and
started to sob.
Stupendously helpful.
Peril said to her father, for our next
trick, Let's burn out all your teeth one
by one.
He took a nervous step away from her.
I only mean that I don't know what will
happen.
Ruby wasn't supposed to be able to
challenge her mother at all. and
certainly never win, but she's been
wearing that personality for over 7 years
now.
Maybe over that much time, it becomes
real enough to change, like a real dragon
would.
So she became strong enough to make the
challenge.
You were strong like that already.
I couldn't believe how quickly you
overcame the loyalty to Queen Scarlet.
Peril snorted in disgust.
You specifically put loyalty to her in my
spell?
Of course, he said.
That was my assignment before I ever knew
you were my daughter.
Remove fire scales, add Queen Scarlet
loyalty, subtract all memories of clay.
I'd say you are the worst dragon I've
ever met, Pearl said.
But Scarlet still has you beat.
Another wild scream came from the
combatants, drawing peril's attention
back to the fight.
Scarlet was trying to sink her claws into
Tourmaline's eyes, but Tourmaline was
holding her off with brute strength
pummeling her underbelly with razor sharp
back talons.
Scarlet's scales were more red than
orange now, covered in blood from her
shredded wing, shoulders and neck.
The rain slammed down on their backs, and
the clouds seemed to be leaning in closer
as though they wanted to watch the fight
as well.
Suddenly, Scarlet slipped on the wet
rocks. and went crashing down on her
back.
Tourmaline immediately leaped on top of
her, digging in her talons.
You shouldn't have come back, mother, she
said.
Tourmaline glanced up at the waiting
crowd and shouted, For the Sky Wings.
And then, with a ferocious crack.
She snapped Queen Scarlet's neck.
For a long moment, the only sound was the
rain falling, pattering on rocks and
scales, and wings.
Then someone shouted, Long live Queen
Ruby!
Queen Ruby!
The crowd roared in response.
I gather that most of these dragons
missed the message about who she really
is, Chameleon said dryly.
Shows how smart you are, Pearl said.
She really is Ruby to them, and if she
has all her memories.
Isn't she really Ruby?
What else makes a dragon who she is?
Moral fiber?
A voice suggested behind her.
A coherent philosophy of life.
Peril whirled around.
Turtle?
she cried with delight.
The sea wing edged out from behind one of
the boulders, nervously eyeing the
raucous, celebrating sky wings.
He looked extremely wet and somewhat
bedraggled.
I, uh, came to rescue you?
he said.
Well, to find out what was going on
anyway.
I heard there was a spell or something
but then I got here, and it was very
stormy, and I couldn't find you, and
suddenly there were 8000000 sky wings
pouring out of the mountains, and a big
fight going on, and I thought, maybe
better to stay out of the way until it's
over, right?
Yes, smart thinking.
If Scarlet had won, it might have gotten
a little dangerous around here, Pearl
said.
But don't worry, I rescued myself.
No more spells on me.
She gave Chameleon a sharp glance, and he
nodded frantically.
Plus, also, I kind of saved the day.
It was epic, and you missed it.
Nuh-uh, Cliff said, suddenly looking up.
His face was still streaked with tears
but indignation had broken through his
distress.
Cliff did that.
I saved the day.
Well, a little bit, peril admitted, but
it was maybe 85% meat.
It was 90, 65, 90 person me.
Cliff objected.
I have little brothers, Turtle said to
Parel. trust me.
You're not going to win this argument.
She couldn't believe Turtle was here.
That was something only a friend would do
wasn't it?
Come to rescue her from a spell?
Deep inside another tribe's kingdom
risking the wrath of a dangerous queen?
Maybe you do like me after all, she said
to Turtle.
You're alone, he said.
Of course I do, even when you're scary
which, let's be fair, is most of the
time.
But what if I'm the talons of power and
fire, parallel asked?
Shouldn't you beware me instead of being
friends with me?
I can be wear you and like you at the
same time.
He joked.
Besides, if I have a choice, I think I'd
rather be on the side with any talons of
power and fire, frankly.
Cliff Cliff.
Tourmaline came bounding over the crowd
barreling through sky wings with her
wings spread.
She landed on the boulder and swept Cliff
up in her arms.
Did you see that?
Mommy won.
He wriggled anxiously, trying to see her
face.
But where is mommy?
He pleaded.
You don't look like mommy.
I want her.
Tourmaline winced, set him down gently
and looked over at peril.
Scarlet's blood had almost turned her
scales back to red, but the rain spilled
over her wings and back, revealing
Tourmaline's unfamiliar orange again.
Do you know how this happened?
She asked peril.
Do you know who can fix it?
Fix it?
Peril asked.
She skewered chameleon with her gaze as
he started to sidle off.
Yes, change me back into Ruby, said the
new queen.
Behind her back, Chameleon shook his head
furiously, and clasped his front talons
together, like he was begging peril to
keep quiet.
Peril blinked away raindrops.
You, you want to be Ruby again?
I am Ruby.
Tourmaline answered.
I remember everything about being her.
All I need is to look like her again.
But don't you want to be yourself?
Peril asked.
The real true actual tourmaline?
Tourmaline put one wing around Cliff and
shook her head.
I will be myself.
Ruby is the sky wing queen, and Cliff's
mother.
Now that I know the truth about my sister
about me.
I can be even better at both of those
things.
If I show her what chameleon can do, I'll
be giving another queen his power.
He could fly away right now with no one
the wiser about his scroll or his shape
shifting.
But if I let him do that, no one will
know what he's doing with it, he could
end up working for another terrible
queen.
I guess it comes down to who I trust
more.
My new queen, who always hated me, or my
father, who betrayed me as soon as he met
me.
She thought about clay, and loyalty, and
everything he'd ever said about the
family you make, and the dragons you
should trust, and how to make the world
safer for everyone.
Peril sprang across the boulder and
cornered chameleon just before he could
take off.
This is the dragon you need, your
majesty.
The Queen took them to a quiet library
room of the palace, lined with scroll
jars, desks, and wooden sculptures of
trees that made peril very nervous, but
it was private enough that they wouldn't
be interrupted.
She kept her wings and tail tucked in
close to her, and ignored her father when
he noticed and gave her a significant, I
can still help you with that Look.
Show the queen, Pearl said to him.
Do I have to?
he asked.
Yes said Tourmaline.
Let's ask my talons.
Pearl said, lifting them up and nodding
thoughtfully at them.
Oh, guess what?
They say yes too.
Cliff giggled.
He and Turtle were the only other 2
allowed in the room, and both watched
curiously as Chameleon undid his metal
sheath again.
This time, he did not reach for his pouch
of shapes, and Peril decided not to point
that out.
She could leave him one secret, since he
loved them so much.
But he did bring out the scroll, and
undid the leather binding with an
aggrieved sigh.
Carefully, he unrolled the blank end of
it along the floor.
This is what I use.
He said.
It's animus touched.
Tourmaline tilted her head at it.
Where did it come from?
I found it, he said evasively.
All I have to do is write an enchantment
in here.
Tear it off, and give it to you to wear
in whatever way you want.
Then as long as you wear it, you'll be
whatever the enchantment says you are.
Chameleon straightened his shoulders, and
gave Tourmaline a sly, sideways look.
In fact, I could make you anything, he
offered.
For the right price, I can make you
invincible.
I can make you as strong as 10 dragons.
I might even be able to make you a mind
reader.
Imagine the possibilities.
What have you always dreamed of being?
Don't trust him.
Peril interjected.
Queen, said Tourmaline, both as
Tourmaline and as Ruby, that was what I
always wanted to become, and I did.
Without any strange magic.
She tapped the scroll.
I wanted to say, turn this dragon back
into Ruby, Queen of the Sky Wings, with
all her memories intact.
That's it?
Chameleon said irritably.
No superpowers?
That's it, Tourmaline said.
I want to watch you write it.
Do it now.
She leaned over his shoulder, staring
narrowly at the page as he dipped his
claw in a small ink pot, and wrote in
scratching crooked handwriting.
As soon as he was finished, he blew on
the paper, tore out the written part, and
passed it to the queen.
Check this for me.
Tourmaline said, holding it out for peril
and turtle to examine.
You saw me ride it, Chameleon protested.
When could I have snuck in any extra
instructions?
Turtle took the paper and studied it on
both sides, bringing it close to his
eyes.
It said exactly what Tourmaline had asked
for.
I think it's the best possible solution
he said, handing it back to Tourmaline.
Peril nodded.
If this was what the queen really
wanted.
She wasn't going to argue.
She could understand it.
But as for herself, she was staying peril
exactly the way she was, fire scales and
all.
No more magic shortcuts to becoming a
better dragon.
For clay or for any other reason.
In the end, it didn't matter what other
dragons thought of her.
What mattered was learning to accept the
dragon she was, and then making herself
the dragon she wanted to be.
The long, hard, real way.
Chapter 19.
This doesn't feel like a normal Skywing
party somehow, Peril said to Queen Ruby.
That's because it's missing all the fun
brutal murder parts, Queen Ruby
explained.
They were standing on the top level of
the great hall, looking down at a mass of
dancing, singing sky wings.
Peril watched them hug and spin, and clap
wings with one another, and thought
wistfully of the full moon festival, and
how she might never get to dance with
anyone in her entire life, even if she
could ever talk clay into it.
She had a feeling he was the kind of
dragon with 4 left talons.
I mean, Ruby went on.
Think about how Scarlet's parties usually
went, or what they were for.
Actually, you'll sleep better if you
don't know.
She added to Turtle, that was true.
Pearl shivered.
Parties for executions, parties for
thrillingly bloody arena days, parties
for Scarlet's hatching day, or Burns
visits that featured all kinds of dragon
killing entertainment.
The Sky Kingdom probably hadn't seen a
party in 20 years that didn't revolve
around Scarlet's gladiator fetish.
But the Sky Wings were making up for it
now.
Somehow about 8 orchestras worth of
percussion and stringed instruments had
materialized over the course of the day.
Now that night had fallen and the storm
had passed, music filled the halls of a
palace that had once reverberated only
with the shrieks of burning dragons.
Peril looked down at her claws.
Your Majesty?
I, I'm sorry about the eggs on the
brightest night.
Stop, Ruby said.
She drew Cliff closer under her wing.
He'd insisted on staying up till midnight
and he looked a lot more awake than
turtle who kept yawning and leaning on
things.
Listen, you were only a dragonette.
Not much older than Cliff, and Scarlet
was the only parent you ever had, or
friend, or anything.
None of the rest of us even tried to see
you as a real dragon.
I saw a weapon, and that was it.
But now, I think about what could happen
to Cliff, if he'd been born with fire
scales, or if my mother had gotten her
claws into him.
I think a lot about how he'll turn out
with me as his mother.
So I don't blame you anymore.
Gosh, I do, Pearl said.
All the things I, I mean, if you just do
the arena numbers, plus the random
dragons she disliked, and all the burning
and then you think, peril.
Turtle interrupted, this might be one of
those instances where less detail is the
way to go.
I know it was bad.
Ruby said, but you can make up for what
you've done.
At least you can try.
If we let you try.
Oh, peril said.
You bet.
Of course I'll try.
I just need a few more epic battles to
the death that I can throw myself into.
Point me at some more dragonettes in
distress or viper bites I can tackle.
I'm also great at toasting squirrels and
boiling water anytime you need either of
those.
Ruby laughed, then glanced at her
dragonette, and looked serious again.
This should be obvious to everyone who
saw you save Cliff, she added.
But just to make it official.
You are no longer banished.
You are welcome throughout the sky
kingdom and anywhere Cliff and I go.
If you want to move back to the palace
you can.
Oh, Peril said, oddly embarrassed.
Thanks.
I'll think about it.
Is this it?
Is this what being a hero feels like?
Is this what clay and tsunami and Sunny
feel like every day?
I thought I'd be more... different.
I thought suddenly it would be easier to
be good.
I thought it would come naturally, once I
did enough good things, or the right big
good thing.
But I still feel just as muddled about
what to do next.
And I kind of still want to set that
guard over there on fire because I swear
he's laughing at me.
Not to mention, there are lots of
wonderfully vengeful things I could do to
chameleon that keep parading through my
brain.
Speaking of chameleon.
Pearl frowned down at a commotion on the
level below them.
Your Majesty, she said, isn't that one of
the guards who is supposed to be keeping
an eye on com- er sore?
Queen Ruby didn't have to answer.
The guard was now swooping up toward them
with a terribly alarmed expression.
I'm sorry. she cried, landing next to the
Queen.
I don't know what happened.
I know you said not to let any other
dragons in or out, but suddenly there was
a night wing there, a really big one, and
he came from inside the room, and I don't
know how he got in there, and he knocked
out Harrier with his tail in one blow, and
then he flew off and the sky wing was
gone.
I'm sorry, I'm so, so sorry.
She flung herself into a deep, abject
bow.
On the other side of the queen, Turtle
sat up, all his sleepiness gone.
He looked much more worried and much less
puddle like than usual.
Queen Ruby reached out and raised the
guard to standing.
I'm not going to hurt you, she said.
We didn't expect him to run, so it's my
own fault for not taking more
precautions.
Go make sure Harrier is all right.
The guards' face was all relief from
snout to horns as she bowed and flew away
again.
How worried should I be?
Queen Ruby asked peril.
What do you know about that dragon?
Peril had thought there would be more
time.
Time to tell her queen everything.
Time to make chameleon feel safe here, and
figure out what to do with him, and how
to deal with the scroll.
She hadn't thought he would bolt the 1st
chance he got.
Without saying goodbye, without thinking
about me at all, maybe.
I know he's really a rain wing, she
confessed.
He could use that scroll for anything, but
so far, he mostly only uses it for shape
shifting.
I think because he could never change his
scales when he was a rain wing.
I don't think he would do evil things
with it on his own.
That was just for Scarlet.
But actually, I don't really know him
that well.
He has a night wing shape, Turtle said.
And he was working for Scarlet?
Is he the one who hurt Kinkaju?
Peril flinched.
Why had she let herself forget about
that?
Because he offered me everything I
thought I wanted?
Yes, she admitted.
He hates rain wings because they banished
him from the rainforest.
Then we can't let him wander around free
with a weapon like that, Turtle said.
I should have taken it from him right
away, Queen Ruby said, shaking her head.
I was trying to reward his cooperation.
All right, I'll send out a search party.
She saw the anxious expression on
Turtle's face and added, or 6, 6 search
parties.
Don't worry, we'll find him.
She spread her wings and flew down to the
throne room with Cliff right behind her.
We can't wait, Turtle said to Parel.
We have to go after him right now.
Yes, she said.
But, Turtle, one more thing you should
know.
He's my father.
Wow, he said.
You have had bad luck with parents.
But good luck with friends, she said
grinning at him.
You big sap, he said, and I can't even
punch you to shut you up.
You could, she said.
That would be pretty funny for me.
He flicked his tail ladder and lifted off
sailing through the open roof and into
the star speckled sky.
Peril followed, feeling the rush of cold
wind against her blazing wings.
Every moment that she got farther away
from that necklace, she felt more and
more like herself again.
No more troubling or guilty thoughts
about Scarlet, nothing but clear memories
of clay.
Can I go back to Jade Mountain now?
Have I done enough?
The questions somehow felt less pressing
than they had before.
She still missed clay very much, but she
had important things to do, such as find
her father, get that scroll into talons
that could be trusted, and maybe help
turtle and his friends stop some big new
terrible prophecy if they'd have her.
If he's a night wing, he'll blend right
in up here.
Turtle called to her, lashing his tail in
frustration.
One of the moons was almost full, but
leftover clouds from the storm hid most
of the moonlight from the mountain
peaks.
We need help.
He angled south abruptly.
Uh-oh, peril said.
Tell me we're not off to find a mind
reader and an ice wing who might be
holding a grudge.
I left them in that valley, Turtles said
pointing.
They said to signal when I needed them.
His scales began flashing, and peril
nearly flew into a cliff, she was so
startled.
She knew Seawings had glow in the dark
scales, but she'd never seen a dragon use
them at night before.
Luminescent spirals and shapes like
webbed talon prints lit up all along his
wings.
It was sort of beautiful in a weird, fishy
way.
Almost immediately, she saw an answering
burst of twin flames from the dark valley
below them.
Soon after that, 3 shapes rose up to meet
them, 2 of them pale and ghostly, one
barely a flicker of shadow.
You did it?
Kibley said, as soon as they were close
enough to talk.
You actually rescued her?
Not exactly, Pearl said.
But thanks very much for the skeptical
tone, Turtle said.
Is she safe to be around?
Winter asked harshly.
What do you think?
He tilted his head at Moon.
I am, Pearl said.
She thought mushrooms and mongooses at
the night wing as loud as she could, and
moon started giggling.
That seems like a good sign, said Kibley
giving Moon a smile that reminded peril
of that night wing who always followed
Queen Gloria around.
Guys, we don't have time for a prickly
reunion.
Turtle interrupted.
Scarlet's ally has escaped, and it's
worse than we thought.
He's a shapeshifter.
So he can look like a dragon from any
tribe.
And he's got this animus touched scroll
that can enchant anything, as far as we
can tell.
Moon let out a Yelp so loud, it echoed
off the mountains.
A scroll?
she cried.
Really?
You're sure?
Uh, yes, Turtle said.
We saw it.
Moon looked deeply agitated now.
Peril regarded her with new interest, was
the night wing hiding something from all
of them?
Even her alleged friends?
What do you know about this scroll?
Peril asked.
Nothing, Moon said.
Was it wrapped in a black leather
casing?
Yes.
Turtle said, staring at her.
Maybe you should tell us all the nothing
you know about it, Pearl suggested.
I just, I heard a story once, Moon said
about a night wing scroll from long ago
that was animus touched.
It sounds like this could be the same
scroll.
She fidgeted anxiously, twitching her
tail over her talons.
That would be bad.
We would really, really need to get it
back if it's the same scroll.
That's what I know.
I was hoping you could try listening for
him.
Turtle said.
He escaped the palace not long ago, so he
can't have gone too far.
He's in his nightwing form, Pearl added
the one where he calls himself
Shapeshifter.
Very subtle, said Kibley.
Moon said, closing her eyes.
I don't think I could pick up anything
from way up here.
Let's fly along the river, Perl said.
I have a feeling he's gone that way.
He said something to me about becoming
mudwings.
She saw the hesitation in their wing
beats.
Should we trust this dragon?
Are we really going to follow her?
But when she turned and swooped away
Turtle was right beside her, and the
others weren't far behind.
Going to the mud wings sounded like the
next thing her father would do.
He wouldn't become Sirius again, now that
peril knew that shape.
She guessed he wouldn't be comfortable
underwater, even in a sea wing form, and
he'd have to worry about keeping the
scroll dry.
Going west to the sand wings meant Queen
Thorn, who already had a reputation as
someone impossible to corrupt, and she
couldn't imagine him returning to the
rainforest, either as a rain wing or a
night wing.
But the mud wings were close, and Queen
Morin had once been Scarlet's ally.
She might be willing to take in a strange
dragon, who offered mysterious power in
exchange for treasure.
Peril dove toward the Diamond Spray River
which glimmered like molten silver in the
places where moonlight broke through.
She remembered clay swimming away down
this river with his friends, heading home
to the mud kingdom, and away from her.
The memory still made her chest ache.
But at least, I have that memory.
Suddenly moon banked right and stopped.
Hovering in place with her front talons
pressed to her head.
After a moment, she lifted one of them
and pointed.
I think he's over there, she whispered.
They slipped after her, gliding as
quietly as they could.
In a clearing by the river, fiddling with
something in his talons, hulked a large
black shape.
He made himself enormous, peril thought
the kind of scary nightwing everyone is
always whispered about.
Kibli flicked his wing to catch her eye
then pointed to each of them, conveying
silent instructions.
A moment later, they landed in a circle
around Chameleon.
Peril's talons were only an inch from his
tail.
Don't move, she said.
Chapter 20.
The night wing reared up, flaring his
wings, and he was so big and unfamiliar
and angry looking, that peril had a brief
moment of fear that they had cornered the
wrong dragon.
No, that's him all right, Moon said.
I'm sure.
Then peril saw the pouch of shapeshifting
jewelry at his feet, and the case that
held the scroll around his chest.
This was definitely him.
Father, peril shouted.
Stop.
I don't want to hurt you, but I will.
And so will we.
Winter hissed.
The sound of frost breath gathering under
his words.
Chameleon froze, but peril still had
never seen such a look of fury and
disgust on him before.
That's him, Winter said to Kibley and
Turtle.
That's the dragon who attacked us, and
wounded Kinkachu.
Turtle growled softly in his throat, and
Kibley raised his venomous tail, digging
his claws into the muddy river bank.
But that's impossible, Min said.
We hit him with my fire and your frost
breath.
This dragon has no scars, no injuries
nothing.
It's the enchantment, Kibley guessed.
It probably starts to shape off new and
uninjured every time.
He just has to take it off, and all the
wounds disappear.
Then when he puts it back on, the scroll
makes him a night wing, purr the
instructions all over again.
No lasting damage, ever.
That's useful, said Pearl.
She remembered how Ruby's injuries had
disappeared when she turned back into
Tourmaline.
Is that right?
Chameleon breathed a small spire of smoke
then nodded.
She wished he would say something, instead
of just glaring at all of them, at her
especially, with those narrow black
eyes.
Listen, she said, we just want the
scroll.
No.
He spat.
Spike's bristling all along his back.
Actually, I want the scroll and justice
Winter said.
I think he should pay for what he did to
Kinka Jew.
Me too, said Turtle.
Me too, said Moon, but the scroll is the
most important thing.
And I think taking it from him will be
punishment enough, said Peril.
Winter snorted disbelievingly, and she
ignored him.
I'm sorry, father, but you can't keep
it.
Not after what you've done with it.
We can't trust you.
I won't do anything terrible, he said.
I was only following Scarlet's orders.
You know all about that.
You weren't following her orders when you
put Kinkaju in the hospital.
Kibley observed.
That was all you.
And you could have chosen me over her
once you knew we were family, Pearl
said.
You didn't have to betray me by taking
away my memories.
You could have also stayed and been loyal
to Queen Ruby, but it's clear you're not
planning on that.
You've had choices, and we haven't seen
you make any good ones yet.
But this is an easy one, Moon said.
Give us the scroll, and we let you go.
Or don't give us the scroll, said Kibley
and get another face full of flames and
frost breath.
Wow, try saying that 5 times fast.
You'll still have your treasure, Pearl
said, and she would leave him the scraps
of scroll he'd already enchanted with his
different shapes.
He could still be sore, and shapeshifter
and Sirius, and whoever else, when he
didn't want to be chameleon.
She knew what it was like to wish for
different scales, and she knew how much
he needed them, as a rain wing with no
scale shifting powers.
You'll keep having your great life
wherever you decide to go.
You just won't be able to hurt anyone
else.
Winter hissed again.
But it's mine, Chameleon said.
Clutching the metal sheath to his chest.
I found it.
I get to keep it.
Why should you have it?
What makes you all any better than me?
Peril didn't really know the answer to
that question.
Was she any better than her father?
Did she know these other dragonettes well
enough to say that they were?
What would they do with power like that?
But she knew one thing.
She couldn't leave it with Chameleon.
Give it to us, she said.
Please don't make us fight you for it.
Or do, said Winter.
I'm ready.
You think you can hurt me?
Chameleon snarled.
But I've made some modifications to this
shape since we last met Ice Wing.
Shapeshifter already has strength beyond
any dragon.
But now I also have scales that cannot be
harmed, and flames as hot as my
daughter's scales.
I foresee a pretty horrible death ahead
for most of you.
Peril felt sick.
Why hadn't she seen this?
Dangerous power hungry side of him
before.
She didn't want anything bad to happen to
Turtle.
She was pretty sure she'd even be able to
muster some sadness if anything happened
to winter.
But father, she started.
What's happening?
Chameleon suddenly shouted.
He scrabbled at his chest?
How are you doing that?
Stop.
It's mine.
Peril stepped back in astonishment as the
sheath unbuckled itself and started to
wriggle free of the hulking night wing's
talons.
Chameleon held on to it desperately.
No, he roared.
You can't take it.
The metal sheath hesitated, poised in the
air as if it were trying to launch itself
out of Chameleon's claws, and then it
pivoted abruptly and bashed him in the
face.
Chameleon yowled with pain, let go of the
scroll and fell back, covering his snout
with his talons.
Blood was running from one of his eyes.
The sheath bashed him in the face once
more, with what looked like the force of
a mountain behind it, Chameleon shrieked
and Perl guessed that several of the
bones in his snout were broken.
That's enough, she cried.
She knew that soon he'd recover from the
shock and gathered the strength to take
off his night wing shape, and then he'd
be healed instantly.
But it was still beyond horrible to see
him suffering like that.
No matter what he'd done, she believed
there was a part of him that had wanted
to help her.
That had wanted to be a family.
For a moment, the sheath hovered in the
air, as if considering whether to listen
to her, and then it spun slowly, and
floated over to land in turtles' talons.
Let's go.
He said.
They all spread their wings and lift it
off at once.
Peril swerved to make sure she stayed
clear of the others.
That scroll is mine.
Chameleon screamed as they flew into the
dark clouds.
I'll find you.
I'll take it back.
You'll be sorry.
It's mine.
It's mine, it's mine.
Peril glanced left at Turtle's determined
jawline, and then right, at Moon's
nervously twitching talons.
Now that they had the most dangerous
scroll in Pyria.
What were they going to do with it?
They flew south for a long time before it
felt safe enough to stop.
Peril kept imagining she could hear a
shapeshifter's ominous wing beats
following them.
But soon they came to a part of the
mountains that was jagged with canyons
and steep ravines, and at the bottom of
one of these, they found a cave deep
enough to crawl into and set a fire
without anyone seeing them from above.
Moon caught some kind of mountain cat for
them to eat, and they huddled against the
stone walls, listening to the rain that
had started again outside.
Peril ate her portion in a famished rush
keeping herself on the far side of the
fire from the others.
Even if Turtle still had his ridiculous
healing rock, she imagined it wouldn't go
over well if she burned any of them
again.
Turtle put the scroll carefully on top of
a ledge at the back of the cave.
Everyone kept looking at it, although
Pearl thought that Moon had the most
interesting range of expressions about
it.
What did that one mean?
And that one.
What was she thinking?
You didn't have to do that, turtle, Moon
said finally. breaking the silence.
You shouldn't use your animus power if
you can help it.
Maybe, you shouldn't use it ever.
Aren't you worried about your soul?
How do you feel?
A little cold, he said with a shrug.
But only the tiniest bit evil.
I'm serious, she protested, as Kibley
laughed.
I read about what happened with
Albatross.
My murderous ancestor, I know, Turtle
said.
But my enchantments have been so small
and I feel exactly the same as I always
have.
I think you'll notice if I start turning
homicidal.
Moon did not look in the least bit
reassured.
It's all right to use animus magic, if
you're careful about it, Winter said.
In the eyes kingdom, our animus dragons
used to spend their lives planning one
enchantment that would benefit the whole
tribe.
They used their magic once for something
beautiful and useful, and they were fine
all the rest of their lives.
Huh.
Kibley said.
I thought I heard something about an
animus ice wing queen went crazy once, a
long, long time ago.
Oh, Winter said, shifting on his talons.
Maybe, but she...
Well, she used her magic more than she
was supposed to.
If it's the queen I'm guessing it was
anyway.
What do we do with this scroll now?
Pearl asked.
Should we take it back to Jade Mountain
and give it to Clay and the others?
She added hurriedly.
Maybe, Turtle said.
But I'm not sure anyone should have this
much power, no matter how good we think
they are.
It can't be good for your soul.
I think a very wise and good dragon would
know how to use it the right way.
Kibli objected.
I think we should give it to Queen
Thorn.
Maybe we should give it to Queen Glacier
Winter snapped.
We shouldn't give it to anyone, Moon
said.
It already belongs to someone.
The fire crackled in the silence that
fell. devouring the scraps of wood they
had found to burn.
Everyone was watching Moon now, and Perel
wondered what she could hear in their
minds.
What do you mean?
Winter asked finally.
Just as Kibley said, who?
The animus dragon who made it, Moon
said.
He put all his power into that scroll, so
that he could use his magic without
damaging his soul, which is pretty smart
right?
He was trying to protect the world from
whatever he might become, or give himself
unlimited power, Winter observed.
But doesn't it seem like a good idea?
Moon asked.
If his magic doesn't turn him evil, he'll
only do good things with it, right?
Doesn't?
Kibli echoed.
Moon, I thought you said this was some
ancient legend.
So why are you using the present tense?
Because, she started, then hesitated and
started again.
Because he's still alive.
Who?
Winter said, rising to his feet.
And he's trapped, she said, her words
suddenly spilling out like smoke.
I started hearing his voice in my head
when I got to Jade Mountain.
He stuck underground somewhere, and he's
starving and alone, and he just wants to
get out, and the scroll is the one thing
that could help him do that.
So I said, I said I'd look for it.
And give it back to him?
Turtle said, then answered himself.
Actually, I guess that's fair.
It is his magic after all.
Moon, Winter growled, his voice low and
ominous, who is he?
Well, she said.
First, I want you to remember that
everything you know about him is 2000
years old and comes from stories told by
the dragons who defeated him.
You don't really know him, even if you
think you do.
Dark stalker?
Winter roared, are you serious?
There's no need to yell, Kibley said
standing up as well.
If the dark stalker is trapped and
starving and alone, that is exactly what
he deserves, Winter said.
Oh, really?
Moon countered.
What about the misunderstood nightwing
that you set free?
Wasn't she a legendary enemy of the ice
wings too?
Yes, but she didn't have horrible powers
Winter said.
Moon's wings flew open, and she rose onto
her back legs, growling.
Horrible powers?
You mean mind reading and visions of the
future?
You mean my horrible powers?
And, uh, winter trailed off, glancing at
turtle.
And my horrible power, turtle finished.
Well, peril said, flexing our talons, at
least he doesn't have mine.
He killed his own father, Winter said
rallying to his argument again, our ice
wing prince. isn't your whole tribe
terrified of him?
Yes, Moon admitted, but they don't know
him either.
And you do?
Kibley asked.
The question hung in the air.
And Peril noticed for the 1st time, the
intensity in Kibley's eyes as he looked
at Moon.
She couldn't interpret it exactly, but
she got the feeling there were several
layers to the question he was asking
layers like, if he's so important to you
why didn't you tell us about him before?
And one she especially recognized, do you
like him better than me?
Moon looked away 1st.
Maybe, she said.
I think so.
I don't know.
I can't let you use this scroll to free
the dark stalker.
Winter said.
What you can't do is order me around, Moon
said sharply.
What you can do instead is have a
rational conversation with me, and listen
to me, and try to talk me out of it if
you must.
But not right now, Turtle said.
Right now, we should all sleep, and then
we can talk about it in the morning.
All right?
I agree, Kibley said.
Fine, said Moon.
Fine. said Winter.
Peril found herself wondering again, if
friends might be more trouble than they
were worth.
She was quite glad she was not snarled up
in this fight.
I'll sleep outside, she offered, standing
up.
In the rain?
Turtle asked.
It won't bother me.
Pearl said, and I've been told I'm a
restless sleeper.
Oh, Turtle said, eyeing her wings
nervously.
In that case, sure, absolutely.
You bet.
Great plan.
Peril shot him a grin as she went out of
the cave into the rain.
There was a somewhat sheltered spot at
the base of the cliff, and she huddled
there, thinking about the scroll and the
argument, and whatever this dark stalker
was, until she finally fell asleep.
And for the 1st time in years, Her dreams
were peaceful.
No furious queen Scarlet chased her
through winding hallways with too many
doors.
Nobody burned between her talons.
There was no fire, no smoke, no death or
screaming, just long, quiet, dreamless
slumber.
Peril, peril.
She was awoken by something poking her
gently in the shoulder, followed by
turtle yelling, ah, and leaping backward
as the stick he'd poked her with burst
into flames, peril stretched, yawning.
Well, what did you think was going to
happen?
she asked.
And then she noticed the 2 serious faces
lined up behind Turtle.
Uh-oh, she said.
Moon's gone, said Turtle, and she's taken
the scroll with her.
Chapter 21.
The world after the storm was dazzling
sunbeams glinted off all the new puddles
and the sky felt as though it had just
taken a dive in a lake.
It seems as if more dragons were out
flying than peril had seen in ages.
Everyone wanted to spread their wings in
the beautiful air.
She saw a lot of sky wings, especially
and realized guiltily that they should
have let Queen Ruby know the scroll was
safe.
Except, apparently, it wasn't very safe
after all.
She wouldn't.
Winter fretted as they flew south, she
wouldn't.
Kimley was silent for once, deep in
thought.
Uh, Turtle said, maybe she, I thought we
were all going to talk about it, Winter
yelled.
Maybe she didn't think you'd be a good
listener, Pearl suggested.
I mean, I haven't known you very long, and
even I can already see that.
I listen, Winter growled, when there is
something worth hearing.
Yeah, I don't think that's the same thing
Pearl said, shaking her head.
You can fly faster than us.
Kibley said suddenly.
He twisted himself in the air so he could
look at peril.
You can fly faster than her.
Maybe you can catch her.
Oh, yes, Pearl said.
Probably.
You guys are slow pokes.
It's like flying with a trio of banana
slugs.
So go, Turtle said wildly.
Fly as fast as you can, stop her before
she sets him free.
Um, all right, Peril said.
Except how do I do that?
Just tell her what a bad idea it is
Winter said.
Ah, okay, Pearl said.
So stop her with words.
Well, write, don't set her on fire, Turtle
said.
Let's be clear about that.
Are you sure?
Parel said.
It would be very efficient.
I bet it would stop her right away.
Just a tiny bit of her tail.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
She hadn't exactly been kidding, but she
could tell from the expressions on their
faces that she'd better act as though she
was.
Not that she wanted to use her fire
scales on moon, but if the alternative
was some big ancient nightmare dragon
rising from the earth, then shouldn't all
the options be open?
Kibley looked close to panicked, though
and winter was giving her the most
suspicious, untrusting face, and even
turtle looked worried about this plan, so
no.
The answer was evidently, let the
nightmare dragon escape rather than
harming even one of Moon's scales.
If she insists on doing it, Tell her at
least to wait for us, Kibli pleaded.
Tell her she shouldn't release him
alone.
All right, Pearl said, flicking her wings
to rise to a higher up draft.
I'll try.
But I suspect, I might be exactly the
wrong dragon for this particular
mission.
She'll be close to Jade Mountain
somewhere, Kibley called after her.
He must be buried near there if that's
where she could hear him.
Got it, Parel called back.
She was surprised when she hadn't caught
up with Moon by midday.
Either the night wing had a much bigger
head start than peril had guessed, or she
flew a lot faster than peril would have
expected.
Peril stopped only once, to drink from a
mountain lake, and spent the rest of the
day flying as fast as she could.
She was exhausted when the 1st stars of
the evening began to emerge, and she saw
Jade Mountain starting to fill the sky
ahead of her.
Clays in there, she thought, with a
thrill of excitement.
I could see him tonight.
I can tell him everything that's
happened.
But 1st, she had to stop Moon.
Carol slowed down as she got closer to
Jade Mountain.
She began to scan the peaks around her
with her eagle sharp eyes, looking for
unusual movements.
Once she swooped down, only to discover
an extremely startled moose.
The 2nd time, she nearly got a snout full
of porcupine quills.
But on her 3rd try, she found the dragon
she was looking for.
Moon wasn't exactly hiding.
She was sitting on a grassy slope on the
western side of a mountain not far from
Jade Mountain.
The sunset cast golden rays over her
huddled form, and her shadow sloped like
a long 2nd tail up the hill behind her.
Peril looped around overhead, studying
the ground around Moon, until she spotted
a boulder where she could safely land.
It wobbled slightly as she thumped down
threatening to tumble into the narrow
ravine nearby, but she steadied it with
her claws.
The night wing didn't look up.
She was curled over the scroll, reading
it so intently that her claws were
crushing the binding where she held it.
Um, Peril said, so, hello.
I've been instructed not to set you on
fire, in case you were worried, she added
hastily.
Moon raised her head, and peril realized
that her eyes were full of tears.
In fact, her whole face was full of
tears.
She looked as if she'd been crying for a
while.
Yikes, Pearl said.
I'd offer you a hug, but I just wanted to
hear him again, Moon said.
I wanted to tell him we found it, to talk
to him, and remember why I trusted him.
But then I started reading, and he
clearly didn't want me to, and I found
this.
She trailed off, touching the scroll with
one mournful claw.
Pearl tilted her head at the paper.
She could see that Moon was on the page
where the writing stopped, and the rest
of the scroll was blank, but she couldn't
read the letters from where she was, and
she didn't dare get any closer.
What does it say?
Pearl asked.
When Moon stared into space instead of
answering, she added, hey, I'm not a mind
reader.
Different horrible power over here
remember?
Stop talking, Moon said sharply, making
peril jump.
Oh, not you, she said to Parel, him.
He's talking to you right now?
Parel said.
That's creepy.
He has trouble reading your mind too, Moon
said.
Although he agrees, it's a lot less
Inferno-esque than it was before you went
to the Sky Palace.
Yay?
A dragon's not a thing.
Moon suddenly exploded, talking to the
air again.
You shouldn't be able to enchant someone
like that.
It's wrong.
Don't you?
No, stop.
It doesn't matter how bad he was.
This.
She jabbed the scroll so hard it ripped a
little.
This is the cruelest thing I've ever
read.
Okay, you really have to tell me now.
Peril was itching with curiosity.
I am, Moon said.
I am going to tell her When you do
something this terrible, you kind of
cancel out any privacy rights.
She turned to peril.
Remember how Winter said, that dark
stalker killed his father, Prince
Arctic.
Yeah, peril said.
That confused me a bit.
Why was his dad an ice wing?
Long story, not important, Moon said.
I mean, except to the ice wings.
Anyway, the other rumor I'd heard about
Dark Stalker was that he did something so
awful that it terrified the entire night
wing tribe into abandoning their city and
going into hiding so that he would never
find them again if he ever came back.
They thought he was gone, maybe dead, but
they still uprooted the entire tribe to
hide from him, just in case.
Yeesh!
And I thought my tribe hated me.
Pearl tried to joke.
She was starting to get a creepy, crawly
feeling under her scales.
This menacing dragon was buried alive
somewhere right below their talons.
Well, Moon said, now I know what it was.
Yes, I do.
I'm sure.
If I saw a dragon do this, I'd go into
hiding too.
Yes?
Peril said impatiently.
Moon dropped her voice.
He used his magic on his father.
He enchanted him as if Prince Arctic was
no more than a necklace or rock or a
piece of cheese.
Ooh, peril said, momentarily distracted
by the idea of an enchanted piece of
cheese.
The spell is right here, Moon said.
She spread her front talons on the scroll
starting to cry again.
Enchant Arctic the Ice Wing to obey my
every command.
That's it.
It's that simple.
What did you make him do?
she demanded.
You made him kill himself, didn't you?
Whoa, peril said.
Is that possible?
That could happen?
Could turtle do that?
Moon gave a furious shake of her head.
There was a long pause, and then she
yelped, disembowel?
Did you seriously just say disembowel?
Who disemboweled who?
Pearl asked.
Oh, gross.
Did Arctic disembowel himself?
That is much worse than anything that
happened in the arena.
Oh my goodness.
Scarlet would have loved to get a self
disemboweling dragon in her arena.
She's dead, by the way.
Did we mention that?
But Moon was lying down on top of the
scroll now, pressing her talons over her
ears with her eyes closed.
Carol wondered if she should try to get
Moon away from Dark Stalker's voice, but
she couldn't think of a way to do that
without either touching her or throwing
rocks at her to get her attention, which
seemed a little heartless considering
what Moon was going through.
So she decided to watch over her and wait
for the others.
That seems like a sensible plan of
action.
She glanced around, found a tree that was
growing at an angle out of a ravine, and
lit its branches on fire.
That should help turtle, Kibli, and
winter find them.
It felt like hours of moon not moving, and
peril sitting there watching her not
move.
But at last, peril heard wing beats, and
she turned to see the other 3 dragons
straggling up, looking much the worse for
wear after flying all day.
Turtle in particular looked like the
world's unhappiest squashed frog.
There she is, he gasped.
Moon.
Kibley and Winter cried at the same
time.
And hello to you too, Parel said.
The 2 of them landed and ran over to Moon
but Turtle came over to Peril's Boulder
first.
What happened?
He asked.
Has she?
No, she hasn't freed him, Pearl said.
I don't think she's going to.
She's had some bad news though, so don't
be a phlegm snorting rat breath adder.
She yelled over to Winter.
Kibli crouched beside Moon, covering her
gently with one of his wings.
Tell us what happened, he said.
Is he talking to you right now?
Yes, and he won't shut up, she said
sitting up and wiping away her tears.
Winter, you were right.
We can't free him.
She passed the scroll to Winter, who let
out an almost imperceptible sigh of
relief.
Kibley breathed out a small flame so they
could both read it.
Whoa.
Kibley said after a moment.
We absolutely can't free him if he can
control other dragons that way.
That easily, Moon said.
And we can't free him, because he's the
kind of dragon who thought of doing it in
the 1st place.
She listened for a moment.
He says he promises he won't ever do that
again.
Dark stalker.
How can we trust you?
No one could ever stop you with a power
like that?
No, stop.
I don't want to see another fairy tale
vision.
I'll have my own visions.
Thank you very much.
Winter let his wings drift softly down, as
though there were heavy weights he could
finally drop.
So, what do we do with it?
Kibli asked. taking the scroll from
Winter's claws.
He brushed one talon lightly across the
blank space.
I was thinking about it today while we
flew.
We could do a lot of good with this.
We could use it to protect our queens.
I could enchant something so that Thorn
will never die, or make her palace immune
to attack.
Moon, think about it.
We can enchant something to make all the
night wings love glory.
You know how many of them hate her
probably better than anyone, because
you've seen into their minds, but imagine
if they all loved her instead.
What if she could rule without the threat
of assassination hanging over her?
She wouldn't want that, Moon said.
She wouldn't want enchanted obedience or
fake love.
How about buyerproof scales at least
Kibley said?
Ooh, peril thought.
We could give all my friends fireproof
scales, which I guess means turtle, turtle
could be fireproof, and safe for me too.
Kibli went on, holding the scroll closer
or something that could warn glory before
someone tries to kill her.
Wouldn't that be a good idea?
And then you wouldn't have to use your
own powers to help her.
You could do whatever you want with
them.
Moon put her talons to her head.
He really doesn't love this
conversation.
If we're in the business of protecting
queens with magic, Winter growled, we
should include Queen Glacier.
She's a good queen too.
And what about my mom?
Turtle interjected, or Queen Ruby for
peril.
But if we enchant all the queens to never
die or be magically protected or whatever
peril said, then won't we end up stuck
with the same queens forever?
Wouldn't that be bad too?
Not in the case of Queen Thorn, Kibley
said stubbornly.
Look, the 3 of you have these crazy gifts
and you're figuring out how to use them
safely, aren't you?
Shush.
Moon whispered, closing her eyes.
I've been fine without you.
Kibley paused, with a puzzled
expression.
Not you, Pearl explained.
The crazy dragon in her head.
So if I can trust you with your powers
Kimley said.
Couldn't you trust me to take care of
this one?
To think carefully about the consequences
and only use it for good?
You, Winter snarled.
By yourself?
We just let you saunter off for the most
powerful talisman in the world.
Why should you get it instead of me?
Maybe I should take care of it.
Or maybe all of us together?
Turtle suggested, but no one was
listening anymore.
You just flew off and abandoned us in
possibility, Kibley shouted at Winter.
You were really mean to Moon, and you
haven't even apologized.
Winter opened and closed his mouth
looking at Moon with an oddly heartbroken
expression.
So how could we trust you, Kibley
demanded.
At least I'm a prince, and have some
experience making decisions to help my
tribe.
Winter shouted.
Oh, awesome logic, Kibley shouted back.
Your royalty.
So you've always had power, so you should
get to keep any new power that comes
along.
Stop fighting.
Moon cried, covering her ears again.
All of you.
Dark stalker, stop yelling at me.
Kibley and Winter were too busy roaring
at each other to hear her.
Turtle was curled in a ball below Peril's
boulder, with his wings around him
looking indecisive and worried.
Fighting over power, peril thought, like
every dragon ever.
But it's not their power.
It's dark stalkers, and they want to use
it, the same way Scarlet used mine.
But that scroll is too dangerous to be in
this world.
Even if a good dragon controlled it?
Even if it didn't change that good dragon
to have that much power?
Even if we could somehow guarantee that
it would never fall into evil talons.
It shouldn't exist.
Look how good dragons are fighting over
it already.
Nobody should be the boss of someone
else's magic.
And nobody else should ever be hurt by
that scroll.
Peril sidled to the edge of the boulder.
Hopped down onto the grass, hurried
through the scorched path she made toward
the fighting dragons, and paused, right
behind Kibley.
The sandwing didn't notice her.
He swept his talons wide, shouting
something at winter about being careful.
And Peril reached out and lifted the
scroll right out of his claws.
There was a heartbeat of silence as Pearl
flew back onto the boulder.
She sat down and held out her talons, and
the other dragons turned around, and they
all watched the scroll burn, burn, burn
into tiny black ashes.
As the last piece of the scroll flickered
out of existence, peril brushed the ashes
off her scales.
There, she said.
That solves that problem.
Now nothing can set the dark stalker free
and no one can abuse his power.
She looked down and saw a turtle smiling
up at her.
Moon's expression was all relief as
well.
So, despite a shock on Winter and
Kibley's faces, peril felt a sudden, clear
bolt of that was the right thing to do.
For once, she was sure, and not because
someone else was telling her what the
right thing was, but because she could
feel it in her own bones.
I did it.
I saved the world.
And Clay wasn't even watching.
Even if he never knows about it, I'll
still know I did the right thing.
She lifted her head to the rising moon
taking a deep, tranquil breath.
Wait, why was the moon wobbling?
It wasn't the moon.
It was the ground.
The ground was shaking, harder and harder
an earthquake trembling through all the
veins of the mountain, Peril's boulder
toppled into the ravine, and she had to
leap into the air, pounding her wings to
get as far away from the shuddering
hillside as possible.
The other dragons threw themselves aloft
too.
What's happening?
Turtle yelled, is Jade Mountain falling?
Is this the prophecy?
Peril twisted in the air to look toward
the academy.
Clay.
But Jade Mountain wasn't moving.
Only this mountain was, and in fact, it
was doing more than shaking and dropping
giant rocks everywhere.
It was splitting apart.
An enormous crack appeared in the earth
and out of the darkness rose the hugest
dragon the world had ever seen.
Silver scales glittered in the corners of
his eyes, and along the underside of his
black wings.
His bones were visible under his skin.
He was long and frighteningly thin, with
a narrow, handsome face, long twisted
horns, and eyes as black as underground
caverns.
Dark stalker, stretched his wings out to
their fullest reach, as wide as the
mountain itself.
He swiveled his neck, expanding in every
direction, like a dragon who hadn't been
able to turn or stretch or move in 2000
years.
And then, he smiled down at peril.
A smile that was all teeth.
Somehow menacing and charming at the same
time.
Ah.
That's infinitely better, he said.
Nice to finally meet you, peril.
Thank you so much for your help.
Epilogue.
Starflight was working late in the
library.
Or was it early?
He wasn't sure how long he'd been in
there, since he no longer needed light to
work by, but he thought the sun was not
yet up when he heard tiny footsteps
coming into the room.
Hello?
he said.
He tried to run to all the students in
his head, small talon steps, light, but
not kinkaju.
With an extra flap sound when they hit
the floor.
Sea wing talons.
Anemone?
He gasped.
Yes, it's me. said the little sea wing
princess.
What are you doing awake?
he asked.
I had a nightmare. she said.
And then something woke me.
Didn't you feel it?
Feel what?
He heard her cross to the wall of
windows.
It sounded as if she put one talon on the
translucent leaves and stood for a moment
quietly, without speaking.
Something that shook the earth.
She said at last, so softly, that he
wondered if he would have been able to
hear her before, when he could see.
I didn't notice anything, he said.
A small sound.
Anemones wings shivering together.
It felt, she said.
Like someone slithering over my grave.
This is Shannon McManus.
We hope that you have enjoyed this
production of Wings of Fire, Book 8
Escaping Carol, by 2ET Sutherland.
This audiobook was produced by Dion Audio
and directed by Sebastian Zedden.
Executive producer Paul Argagne.
Print edition published by Scholastic
Press, an imprint of scholastic Inc.
Text Copyright 2016 by 2ET Sutherland.
Production Copyright 2016 by Scholastic
Inc.
All Rights Reserved.
A Guide to the Dragons of Pyria.
Updated and edited by Starflight of the
Night Wings.
Welcome to the Jade Mountain Academy.
At this school, you will be learning side
by side with dragons from all the other
tribes.
So we wanted to give you some basic
information that may be useful as you get
to know one another.
You have been assigned to a winglet with
6 other dragons.
The Winglit groups are listed on the
following page.
Thank you for being a part of this
school.
You are the hope of Pyre's future.
You are the dragons, who can bring
lasting peace to this world.
We wish you all the power of wings of
fire.
Jade winglet.
Ice wing, winter.
Mudwing, umber, night wing, moon watcher
rain wing, kinkaju, sand wing, kibli, sea
wing, carnelian.
Gold Winglet, Ice Wing, Icicle, Mud Wing
Sora, Night Wing, Big Tail, Rain Wing
Tamarind, Sand Wing, Onyx, Sea Wing, Pike
Sky Wing, Flame.
Silver Winglet, Ice Wing, Cheng Bai, Mud
Wing, Sepia, Night Wing, Fearless, Rain
Wing, Bodo, Sand Wing, Ostrich, Sea Wing
Anemone, Sky Wing, Thrush, Copper Winglet
Ice Wing, Alba, Mud Wing, Marsh, Night
Wing, Mind Reader, Rain Wing, Coconut
Sand wing, peregrine, sea wing, snail, sky
wing, peregrine, quartz winglet, ice wing
ermine, mud wing, newt, night wing, mighty
claws, rain wing, ciamang, sand wing, arid
sea wing, barracuda, sky wing, garnet.
Sand wings, description.
Pale gold or white scales, the color of
desert sand, poisonous barbed tail, forked
black tongues, abilities, can survive a
long time without water, poison enemies
with the tips of their tails like
scorpions.
Bury themselves for camouflage in the
desert sand.
Breathe fire.
Queen.
Since the end of the war of Sandwing
Succession, Queen Thorn.
Students at Jade Mountain, Arid, Onyx
Ostrich, Pronghorn, Kibley.
Mudwings.
Description, thick armored brown scales.
Sometimes with amber and gold underscales
large flat heads with nostrils on top of
the snout.
Abilities can breathe fire, if warm
enough, hold their breath for up to an
hour.
Blend into large mud puddles, usually
very strong.
Queen, Queen Morhen.
Students at Jade Mountain, Marsh, Newt
Sepia, Sora, Umber.
Skywings, description, red gold or orange
scales, enormous wings, abilities
powerful fighters, and flyers, can
breathe fire.
Queen, Queen Ruby.
Although some dragons still support Queen
Scarlet, who may be alive and in hiding.
Students at Jade Mountain, carnelian
flame, garnet, peregrine, thrush, sea
wings, description.
Blue or green or aquamarine scales, webs
between their claws, gills on their necks
glow in the dark stripes on their tails
snouts, underbellies, abilities, can
breathe underwater.
See in the dark.
Create huge waves with one splash of
their powerful tails.
Excellent swimmers.
Queen, Queen Coral, students at Jade
Mountain, anemone, barracuda, pike, snail
turtle.
Ice wings.
Description.
Silvery scales like the moon, or pale
blue like ice, ridged claws to grip the
ice.
Forked blue tongues, tails narrow to a
whip thin end.
Abilities, can withstand subzero
temperatures and bright light, exhale a
deadly frost breath, Queen, Queen Glacier
Students of Jade Mountain, Alba, Chiang
Bai, Ermine, Icicle, Winter, Rain Wings.
Description.
Scales constantly shift colors, usually
bright like birds of paradise, prehensile
tails, abilities, can camouflage their
scales to blend into their surroundings
shoot a deadly venom from their fangs.
Queen, Queen Glory.
Students at Jade Mountain, Bodo, Coconut
Kinkaju, CMA, Tamarin.
Night Wings.
Description.
Purplish black scales and scattered
silver scales on the underside of their
wings, like a night sky full of stars
forked black tongues.
Abilities can breathe fire, disappear
into dark shadows.
Once known for reading minds, and
foretelling the future, but no longer.
Queen, Queen Glory.
See recent scrolls on the Nightwing
Exodus and the Rainwing Royal Challenge.
Students at Jade Mountain, Big Tail
Fearless, Mighty Claus, Mind Reader, Moon
Watcher.